exposant est grande c'est que est ce que
ce marché peut avoir lieu et ceux qui
vont suivre les prochains jours c'est un
espace n'est pas clôturé un espace d'un
marché n'est pas clôturée donc j'ai fait
le lien avec les parents que les jeunes
qui accompagnent leurs parents donc
également est ce qu'on fait une
différence entre des marchés permanents
et des marchés occasionnels saisonniers
voilà merci poursuit la division la
discussion commune avec d'autres
amendements le 424 me gosselin défendu
le 365 ne l'est pas le 425 gilles
gosselin défendu alors sur cette série
monsieur le rapporteur sera porteur sur
cette discussion de discussion domaine
vous avez la parole sera porteur merci
monsieur le président nous avons tranché
jeu ce débat mardi en commission et je
vais pas revenir sur une justification
sanitaire qui compte dans l'application
du passani terre pour les mineurs un
équilibre a néanmoins été trouvé en
prolongeant le délai dérogatoire pendant
lequel il ne sera pas applicable aux
12-18 ans alors qu'il avait été annoncé
pour un mois par le gouvernement
la commission a souhaité le repousser au
30 septembre et cela me paraît
satisfaisant donc avis défavorable pour
tous les amendements
bonjour monsieur le président mesdames
les députés
messieurs les députés ravi d'être avec
vous ce ravi d'être avec vous en cette
matinée d'autant plus pour aborder un
sujet dont vous imaginez qu'en tant que
mise dès l'enfance et femmes il m'est
particulièrement cher et la question des
mineurs des enfants des mineurs
globalement face quand on a un virus est
évidemment un sujet que je suis avec une
particulière attention depuis le début
de la crise depuis un an et demi en
veillant à ce que les enfants ne soient
pas stigmatisés notamment face à ceux à
cette épidémie comme ils ont pu l'être à
certains à certains moments où l'état de
nos connaissances étaient encore
incertaines sur ce virus est elle le
demeure d'ailleurs vous le savez nous le
savons aujourd'hui les enfants les
enfants les mineurs connaissent
effectivement des des formes moins grave
que les adultes que les plus âgés que
les plus vulnérables parmi nous pour
autant vous le savez aussi les enfants
sont des vecteurs du coc vide ils
peuvent s'avérer moins porteur ils
peuvent s'avérer moins vecteurs que les
adultes mais il demeure vecteur de ce
virus
dès lors les exclure les exclure du pass
sanitaire viendrait à atténuer
l'efficacité ça viendrait mécaniquement
madame la députée mécaniquement cela
viendrait atténuer l'efficacité du
dispositif que nous mettons en place et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
maintenons l'avis est défavorable sur
ces amendements et nous maintenons la
nécessité l'impératif à ce que les
mineurs soient également soumis à cette
obligation liée au pass sanitaire et ce
d'autant plus que nous faisons avec une
approche pragmatique réaliste grâce à un
amendement porté je crois par monsieur
guy fléchard en commission sauf erreur
qui effectivement de façon pragmatique a
reporté au 30 septembre
l'impossibilité et la nécessité de
présenter le pass afin que l'ensemble
puissent être vaccinés et enfin pour
être totalement complet et répondre à
monsieur cattin qui n'avait pas eu sa
réponse hier soir si vous envisagez si
ce que vous évoquez ce sont les marchés
extérieurs
eh bien ils ne sont pas soumis ils ne
sont pas dans le périmètre puisque le
passé ni terre ne concerne que les
grands les grandes les grands centres
commerciaux et les grands magasins
donc si vous parlez si vous évoquez
alors ce n'était pas très clair dans
votre intervention des marchés
extérieurs
ce n'est pas dans le périmètre du
dispositif qui est envisagée si mes
chers collègues auraient essayé de tenir
la jurisprudence a bible d'hier
c'est-à-dire des deux orateurs pas
groupe monsieur cochrane et monsieur
vigier rend la parole merci je pense que
cet amendement est évidemment important
bon vous avez compris à travers les
débats hier que pour notre part nous
considérons que le pass annie terre dans
sa globalité est à la fois un prêt pour
liberté mais aussi même pour son
efficacité en réalité pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
mais là sur les mineurs se pose un
triple problème qui fait qu'on devrait
accepter et voté cet amendement le
premier ça a été dit c'est que ça a été
les derniers servis quelque part et que
même si la date a été repoussée
on est quand même dans une situation où
vraisemblablement tous même s'il le
souhaitait ne pourront être vacciné à
temps par rapport aux dates qui ont été
données la deuxième chose c'est que ça
réglerait le problème
maintes fois répété hier par mon
collègue jumelles sans réponse effective
du ministre sur la question de
l'autorisation
comment les mineurs font quand les
parents ne sont pas d'accord avec le
fait des maximes et ya une troisième
raison c'est que ces interroge votre
stratégie de vaccination
qu'est ce que dit le conseil conseil
consultatif national d'éthique
le 9 juin le bénéfice médical individuel
pour les adolescents est très limité
al'inverse le recul existence par mois
qui vient ne permet pas d'assurer la
pleine sécurité ces nouveaux vaccins
chez l'adolescent le président du comité
d'éthique c'est jean françois delfraissy
j'ai cherché j'ai pas vu jusqu'à
maintenant une déclaration qui
contredisent cette question tout ce que
nous pensons et depuis le début c'est
qu'à partir du moment où vous nous dites
le problème n'est pas pour les mineures
mais il est pour qu'il transmette nous
nous disons mais ton paquet faisons un
effort volontariste pour aller chercher
réellement les personnes à risque
faisons en sorte que les médecins de
ville les contacts mails dont il est
clair qu'ils n'ont qu'un modèle à barral
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous n'avez pas
convaincu et bien évidemment qu'il faut
retirer les mineurs du pas salutaire et
je vous rappelle que les gens m'aiment
vacciner peut transmettre le virus
moi je viendrai c'est en fait on n'est
pas d'accord c'est sur les modalités de
mise en oeuvre de ce pass sanitaire des
modalités parce que c'est pas acceptable
que les gens qui ne respectent pas et
des sanctions financières et surtout des
sanctions pénales
là vous allez beaucoup trop loin le
deuxième point je pense que nos
restaurateurs qui ont souffert pendant
la crise ne sont pas des policiers
et cette part a eu à contrôler le pass
sanitaire des gens qui vont venir chez
eux et surtout dernièrement nous avons
eu beaucoup beaucoup de coups de fil et
d'interrogations pour des présidents
d'associations qui ont des
manifestations qui arrivent dans les
jours à venir
ils n'ont pas mis en place
l'organisation pour contrôler le pas
salutaire et toutes ces manifestations
qui font vie notamment les territoires
ruraux sont annulés les uns les unes
après les autres
donc monsieur le ministre vous voyez
bien que les modalités de mise en place
du pass sanitaire aujourd'hui sur le
terrain sont inapplicables
merci donc nous allons mettre voici
différents amendements tout d'abord le
sang 22 222 7 à main levée donc avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre rejeté alors la série non pas 60
depuis été défendue mais 135g suivant là
c'est un vote électronique chacun put
regagner sa place même avis négatif de
la commission du gouvernement
nous votons sur 135 est identique
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos voici les résultats
votre temps 115 exprimé 113 majorité 57
pour 45 contre 68 l'amendement est donc
rejetée nous revenons à des votes à main
levée le 424 qui est pour contre rejeté
le 335 même pas été défendu le 425 qui
épousent contre rejeté le 145 jocelyn
descent du lequel sens de 746 monsieur
cattin défendu défavorable commission
défavorable gouvernement je me vois qui
est pour
alors attendez monsieur rumeurs humain
sur ces amendements identiques
parce que je pense que les collègues de
droite là ont déposé des amendements qui
sont très intéressants et je trouve
dommage qu'ils ne dépendent pas c'est à
dire que c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
avec la mise en place du pass sanitaires
sans moyens pour aller vers plus de
tests par tous au fond n'y a pas de
solution alternative qui est proposé
aujourd'hui à la vaccination
là ce que disent nos collègues de droite
c'est au fond un autotest pourrait
servir à entrer dans les lieux
je vais défendre des amendements ensuite
mais par exemple en allemagne on a
installé des dizaines de milliers ne
serait ce qu'à berlin de lieu où on peut
se faire tester
pourquoi et bien parce que comme ça il
ya une vraie alternative à la
vaccination obligatoire donc ça
supposerait que là on n'est pas
seulement un projet de loi qui soit de
contraintes sur les libertés mais aussi
de déploiement de moyens pour qu' il
puisse y avoir un vrai usage des tests
et donc voilà pourquoi je pense que
c'était des bons amendements qui
méritait d'être défendue de la part de
nos collègues de droite
et à 2 par amendement merci monsieur le
président mais j'avais peur que vous
ayez un tropisme sur votre gauche
aujourd'hui l'eau ce qui m'aurait donné
de votre part monsieur le ministre
peut-être aurais-je un peu plus de
chance avec vous que j'en ai eu hier
avec le ministre de la santé j'ai évoqué
et je sais que vous êtes attaché à ce
sujet la problématique des adolescents
dont les parents pour des raisons qui
leur appartiennent refuserait la
vaccination mon souci est de savoir
alors le ministre dit regarder la télé
jean michel blanquer rv à s'exprimer
dans quelques jours et vous verrez
l'extraordinaire plan qu'il présente
pour mobiliser la médecine scolaire et
pour répondre à vos questions mais on
est au parlement et j'aimerais bien que
le parlement tienne des réponses au
moment ils discutent de la loi que se
passe-t-il si un ado n'est pas vacciné
et qu'il est exclu des activités
périscolaires des activités de
découvertes culturelles liées au projet
éducatif
lorsque votre place sanitaire
s'appliquera aux 10 18 ans et c'est un
sujet important est ce qu'on applique à
ses mômes la la double peine alors que
l'autorité parentale appartient aux
parents sur l'enjeu de la vaccination
peut-être aurais-je la chance
aujourd'hui d'obtenir une réponse sur
sont importants sujets boisé amendements
identiques défavorable commission
gouvernement qui est pour contre rejeté
c'est david et la parole merci monsieur
le président cet amendement vise à
introduire la possibilité de délivrer le
pass sanitaires sur la base d'une prise
de sang antigénique ne concluons pas à
une contamination par l'aco vide oui
merci les défendu monsieur le rapporteur
la merci de toute façon les autotests ne
sont pas reliés à ses dettes
s'il est peu donc ça ne permet pas
d'avoir un qr code pour le pass sonic et
c'est un avis défavorable même avis
monsieur le ministre je mets se voit qui
est pour contre 1 jeter le nous emmène
une discussion commune le 214e antoine
descendu le 272 défendu le
360 n'est pas défendu le 422 est ce
qu'ils perdent mémoire le 360
monsieur ménagers à la parole oui
monsieur le président je reviens sur le
sujet qui est quand même un sujet
d'importance on a expliqué aux jeunes et
aux mineurs que ce n'était pas
nécessaire de serre vacciner ils sont
pas opposés dans leur immense majorité à
la vaccination est aujourd'hui se
retrouvent piégés par le calendrier que
vous imposez parce qu'on sait bien qu'il
y a qu'à 10 15 semaines parfois entre
pour terminer le parcours vaccinale donc
moi je suis favorable à ce que vous
sortiez les mineurs du pass sanitaire
mais au moins si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec cette possibilité là avec
cette proposition acceptée la première
dose parce que encore une fois ils ont
fait l'effort d'être vacciné une
première fois ils ne pourront pas
matériellement faire la deuxième acte
ans pendant les vacances
vous allez d'ailleurs exclure des jeunes
des relations avec leur famille les
parents pourront aller au restaurant
pourront aller sur les terrasses mais
pas leurs enfants
il ya un vrai problème les jeunes ont
déjà payé un lourd tribut un lourd
tribut à cette pandémie
dans le cadre de leurs études dans le
cadre avec des problèmes psychologiques
fort n'en rajoutez pas et accepter au
moins au moins cette proposition merci
monsieur berry pour 422 oui monsieur le
président monsieur mini chers collègues
pour conforter effectivement cette idée
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens ont
entendu l'appel
l'appel du président de la république
appelle des pouvoirs publics pour aller
se vacciner et il serait bien leur
accorder monsieur le ministre votre
confiance
et justement les prendre en compte est
ce que ces prix nous vacciner développe
déjà une immunité importante ils sont
moins contaminant au sein et convient
d'élargir la validité du pass sanitaires
à ces personnes afin qu'elles puissent
accéder aux lieux les établissements
justement qui retient le passant dit r
je crois que ça sera un geste de
confiance un geste de soutien pour ces
jeunes et pour ces personnes justement
qui devait pas forcément prêtes à la
vaccination qui se sont engagés et puis
on sait très bien que les délais sont
longs et on l'évoquait hier même aussi
il y à des lieux où il va manquer
peut-être aussi de doses de vaccin pour
pouvoir accélérer tout ça alors merci de
les prendre en compte de les considérer
est de faire en sorte qu'ils puissent
bénéficier du pass sanitaires
733 à la vente one défendu à monsieur
les coeurs mais si les coeurs et là on a
fait simplement deux mots pour rappeler
si besoin est et on l'a vu hier qu'il
fallait finalement reconnaître la bonne
volonté et faire confiance donc l'idée
qui poursuivi c'est de faire en sorte
que celles et ceux qui se sont inscrits
dans un parcours est bien puisse être
reconnu en tant que tel je voudrais
quand même profiter de cette prise de
parole ce matin pour faire remarquer à
nos collègues qu'à l'heure où nous
débattons du périmètre et des modalités
d'application de ce futur passe
sanitaires le pass sanitaires en vigueur
depuis hier matin 21 juillet commence à
produire ses effets dans nos
départements et quels effets puisque les
messages d'annulation de manifestations
d'événements culturels et sportifs se
succèdent et donc je crois que ceci ne
peut que nous interpeller sur la portée
de nos débats et la considération dans
laquelle on nous tient
merci alors le merci madame le 1102
n'est pas défendu
le
le d5 est donc sur ces amendements
monsieur la porter avec la discussion
commune se poursuit le 980 madame la
présidente genevard bien fou aux
amendements
oui merci merci monsieur le président
bon c'est un sujet qu'on a déjà débattu
la reconnaissance de l'engagement dans
le parcours vaccinale monsieur le
ministre
hier soir mon collègue du jura jean
marie sermier affaissé livré une petite
expérience toute simple il a voulu
prendre un rendez vous sur dr lee pour
une primo injection
il a voulu faire comme si le premier
rendez vous dans le jura lui a été lui
ai proposé le 13 août trois semaines en
trois semaines donc voyez bien que il ya
des gens qui sont pleins de bonne
volonté qui veulent mais qui sont bien
loin de l'achèvement du parcours
vaccinale avec de tels délais on peut
pas dire vaccinez vous vacciner vous est
proposé une première injection dans
trois semaines c'est pas possible
merci le sous-amendement n'est pas
défendu le 971 dit filippo à la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur
minister collègues
je confirme ce qu'a dit le député des
choeurs sur l'annulation des événements
culturels et sportifs on commence à le
voir malheureusement et beaucoup ne
savent pas sur quel pied danser avec ce
pass sanitaires et comment l'appliquer
les délais sont très courts et la base
légale sur laquelle le décret a été pris
on pouvait en discuter
je confirme ce que dit madame genevard
sur les délais pour obtenir de la
vaccination
le premier ministre lui même mardi a
reconnu qu'il manquerait des doses pour
faire tous les français d'ici pour
vacciner tous les français qui ne sont
pas d'ici la fin août
un parcours vaccinale minimum deux
semaines plus trois semaines plus encore
dix jours maintenant eh bien ça nous
amène au delà de la mi septembre et là
je fais un calcul mathématique avec vous
olivier vers en lui même nous a dit hier
à la tribune que le pic de cette
quatrième vague était projeté à la fin
août
donc on sera déjà dans la phase de
reflux quand les personnes qui se sont
engagées dans le parcours vaccinale au
moment de la prise du décret pourront en
sortir et donc ces mesures seront
inopérantes
donc il faut quand même du bon sens par
rapport à cela la primovaccination offre
une protection qui est satisfaisante 60
75 % et donc on doit pouvoir pour des
gens qui font cette démarche là leur
permettent de travailler normalement et
de vivre un été à peu près normale merci
alors le sous-amendement n'est pas
défendu nouvelle maintenant 342e madame
nouvelle j 342 toujours sur cette
question oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre les français
attendait cette période estivale avec je
dirais beaucoup d'enthousiasmé compte
tenu des périodes de confinement que
nous avons vécu les associations
redémarrer leur activité un petit peu
partout les collectivités auront
réorganise un certain nombre de
manifestations et chacun avait plaisir
de pouvoir participer à ces
manifestations
re faire un certain nombre d'activités
hors des personnes finalement se
trouvent piégés piégé parce qu'elle ne
se sont pas engagés dans un processus de
vaccination notamment les jeunes et
aujourd'hui piégé parce qu'elles ne
peuvent pas tout de suite se faire
vacciner elles doivent attendre un
certain nombre de semaines donc
finalement vous gâcher cette période
estivale pour un certain nombre de
français qui ne peuvent pas aujourd'hui
organiser leurs vacances comme ils
l'avaient entendu qu'ils ne peuvent pas
pratiquer les activités qu'elle
souhaitait pratiquer or si vous
acceptiez ces amendements en faisant en
sorte que les primo vacciner dispose
d'un pass sanitaires vous ne gâche rien
n'est pas cette période estivale pour un
certain nombre de français qui
s'inscrivent dans la démarche que vous
souhaitez donc donner l'heure je dirais
écouter ces français aujourd'hui qui je
dirais se met dans une situation de
semis révolte parce que cette période
était très attendu pour eux merci
merci donc nous en arrivons maintenant
monsieur c'est l'énergie de 216
oui merci merci monsieur le président on
est là sur un amendement qui permet de
conjuguer les objectifs que vous
poursuivez ne pas baisser la forte très
forte intention impressions sur les
français pour qu'ils aillent se faire
vacciner
on ne veut pas que le mouvement qui a
été embauché en engagé par la prise de
conscience collective de la nécessité de
se faire vacciner plus vite que les
messages politiques précédents ne
l'avait suggéré soit gâchée par les
discussions que nous avons aujourd'hui
on ne souhaite pas par contre on
souhaite que ce qui de toute bonne foi
se sont engagés dans un processus
vaccinale puissent continuer à
bénéficier des règles qui étaient en
vigueur et qui vous nous le dites
suffiront le jour où la couverture
vaccinale sera sera plus importante
de surcroît on le voit dans les
différentes productions scientifiques
la première injection produit déjà des
effets donc c'est respecter l'engagement
de toute bonne foi des français dans le
processus vaccinale
cet amendement donc le 200 216 propose
du coup qu'on qu'on compte les premières
injections qui serait faite avant le 15
août le 385 est un peu moins dix ans
mais nous sommes tout à fait
correspondre à l'esprit de la prise de
parole du 12 juillet du président de la
république est dit voilà 1er août 1er
août s'est prise de parole du président
de la république plus les 15 18 jours
nécessaires à obtenir un rendez vous que
ce soit par des organisation personnelle
ou par la disponibilité en centre de
vaccination
ça nous semble des amendements de
respect dû aux français merci d'avoir
présenté donc les deux amendements
la série en discussion commune a été
présenté mais sur la porter à vis de la
commission s'il vous plaît merci
monsieur le président la première
injection assure une protection à peu
près à 30%
papus la deuxième injection assure une
protection à 80-90 pourtant 90 % au
moins pour la deuxième question donc
seuls les deux injections protège contre
le virus avec défavorable pour
l'ensemble de ces amendements le
sous-amendement merci leurs deux prises
de paroles venues me tuer tel monsieur
chénier la parole sur ministres ordonnés
moi j'avais oublié j'avais oublié
pardonnez moi mais ça serait bien de
publier le mais je prévenais déjà leur
demande c'est quand même avec vous ce
matin merci monsieur le président non ça
sera un avis défavorable aussi pour les
pour les raisons les accepter ou pas que
vient d'exposer le vient d'exposer le le
rapporteur sur sur effectivement le
l'efficacité de ces primo de ces primo
injection
moi je voulais quand même revenir sur
quelques propos qui ont été tenus sans
polémique enfin la nouvelle j vous ne
pouvez pas dire que on est là pour
gâcher les vacances des français je suis
désolé on est là depuis le début pour
protéger pour protéger nos concitoyens
par ailleurs j'aimerais rebondir là
aussi sur propos que vous relevez les
messages que vous recevez sur les
nombreuses annulations vous évoquez il
s'avère que y'a pas que les
parlementaires qui vont sur le terrain
les ministres aussi vont sur le terrain
il s'avère qu'en plus vous avez deux
ministres qui sont des anciens
parlementaires et donc je vais vous
partagez moi aussi les expériences que
j'ai eu sur le terrain vendredi dernier
j'étais au festival d'avignon pour aller
voir un spectacle donné par le pour le
jeune public ce qui a toute une
programmation pour les enfants au
festival d'avignon notamment dans le off
il était effectivement suite aux prises
dans les répliques assez inquiets sur la
possibilité qu'ils aient des annulations
que les centres de loisirs qui viennent
de toute la france pour s'ouvrir à la
culture a nulle et en l'espèce c'est
tout l'un vers ce qui se passe
ils ont appelé les centres de loisirs
tous les toutes les personnes confirment
et viennent assister en dépit des règles
sanitaires qui ont été il ya deux jours
j'étais au parc astérix pour voir
comment le pass and it
et oui au coeur au coeur du au coeur du
village
oui au coeur du village des
irréductibles gaulois qui eux aussi qui
eux aussi écouter qui eux aussi
s'inquiétait qui eux aussi s'inquiétait
des possibles annulations liées à la
mise en place du pass sanitaires et des
nouvelles et des nouvelles règles et là
aussi c'est tout l'inversé qui se passe
les taux de remplissage sont importants
et tout le monde confirme sa venue
donc je voulais partager avec vous un
certain nombre d'expériences qui font
contrepoint aux messages que vous que
vous recevez de votre de votre côté et
enfin pour répondre à monsieur jumelles
et à monsieur coquerel sur le sujet des
enfants rappeler une fois encore qu avec
l'amendement de monsieur bouffier
chasser jusqu'au 30 septembre que les
enfants pourront les adolescents en
l'espèce se faire vacciner bénéficier du
pass sanitaire que dans le cas il n'y
aurait pas l'accord des deux parents un
amendement porté par le député sacha
houllier a permis à ce que la corde d'un
seul parent soit possible sachez aussi
que nous réfléchissons à d'autres
situations plus complexes encore les
enfants de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
voilà par exemple pour lequel parfois
les parents ne sont pas disponibles ou
pas en mesure de donner éventuellement
leur accord que fait-on nous sommes en
train de travailler à ce sujet tout ça
pour vous dire que nous appréhendons
bien l'ensemble des difficultés que
peuvent relever un certain nombre de
situations et que avec les acteurs de
terrain en concertation nous essayons de
trouver des situations qui permettent de
concilier la sécurité de chacun et la
liberté la liberté de tous et enfin
monsieur jumelles pour répondre à votre
question et ensuite j'en arriverais là
monsieur le président d'ores et déjà un
enfant qu'il ne serait pas ne
bénéficieraient pas des onze vaccins
obligatoires
écoutez moi monsieur jumelles vous
m'avez interpellé qui ne bénéficieraient
pas des onze vaccin obligatoire des as
déjà aujourd'hui il ne peut pas
participer à des activités
extrascolaires là demain s'agissant
l'accent sur le vide il ya une
alternative qui existera puisqu'il aura
la possibilité de se faire un test
pour bénéficier d'une activité
extrascolaire s'il n'a pas été vaccinés
parce que ses parents s'ils s'y
opposerait donc vous voyez bien que nous
appréhendons l'ensemble des situations
nous mettons en place les alternatives
possibles pour que les enfants ne soient
pas ne soient pas pénalisés mais
participe aussi de façon altruiste parce
que oui il participe aux bénéfices elle
il ya une dimension de bénéfices
altruiste et pour qu'ils participent à
la protection de l'ensemble de notre
pays alors la parole est à matthieu
chanut
puis le président a bad merci monsieur
le président ce ministre vous êtes quand
même l'art de mettre les français dans
des situations absolument insupportable
vous avez mis les jeunes dans des
situations insupportables qui
aujourd'hui évidemment les contraigne
vous nous proposer un calendrier
particulièrement loufoque je pense qu'
un certain nombre de nos collègues qui
vous ont démontré mais pour qu'une
mesure soit applicable pour qu'une
mesure soit compréhensible
aucune mesure ait du sens d'abord faute
à cannes infantilise faut pas qu'elle
pénalise d'une façon totalement
inefficace mais on a l'impression que
c'est plus fort que vous on a le droit
avec vous soit à des mesures un contrôle
autoritaire soit à des mesures
technocratiques complètement débile et
on est en train de vous expliquer que
votre calendrier n'a pas de sens alors
entendez des amendements de bon sens qui
sont simplement fait pour améliorer la
vie des français pas pour les gêner
constamment il y à des français qui ont
fait preuve de beaucoup de bonne volonté
qui sont vaccinés et bien non cela il va
falloir encore aller les emmerder est
alors encore faire en sorte que la vie
soit plus difficile
et puis j'en termine par cette espèce de
fenioux ce qu'on a entendu la part du
rapporteur qui dégringole nom de ces
trous maintenant de l'efficacité
vaccinale serait lors de la première
injection efficace à partir de pour 30%
simplement des câbles enfin qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire on nous a
dit que ça marchait pour 70 % des cas et
ce matin on entend comme ça
sorti d'un chapeau que ça marche pour 30
% des cas enfin un moment un peu de
sérieux arrêtez avec vos mesures
technocratiques complètement débilisante
où vous accès d'autoritarisme parce que
ce sont les français qui au bout du
compte paye vos incompétences et notre
amateurisme
la parole est le président ahmad merci
monsieur le président je voudrais
revenir sur ces amendements sur le
ministre sur la première dose ce que
vous nous secoue
vous proposons c'est quelque chose de
cohérent et deux simples
l'idée c'est quoi c'est tout simplement
de faire en sorte que toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont été primés vacciner en
juillet qui ont écouté le président de
la république le 12 juillet dernier et
qui ont dit je vais me faire vacciner
dans les quinze jours
et bien cela qu'on les sanctionne pas
neuf jours après alors empêchant l'accès
aux parcs de loisirs au théâtre et au
lieu de culture vous nous parliez du
parc astérix je peux vous parler du parc
des oiseaux dans l'ain je peux vous dire
que le parc des oiseaux qui fait trois
cent mille visiteurs par an aujourd'hui
il ya un recul de fréquentation ne faut
pas raconter n'importe quoi
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est quoi la
réalité c'est que malheureusement comme
vous prenez pas les premières doses ceux
qui de bonne foi vont se faire vacciner
dans les quinze derniers jours de
juillet nous ce qu'on vous demande c'est
quoi
on vous demande pas de prendre en compte
la première dose advitam eternam comme
comme valant pas sanitaires on vous
demande simplement de prendre en compte
ceux qui ont été vaccinés au mois de
juillet pendant tout le temps du mois
d'août ce qui permettra tout simplement
à ceux qui sont fait vacciner le vin le
25 ou le 30 juillet est bien de pouvoir
aller au café au restaurant dans les
parcs de loisirs dans les lieux de
culture jusqu'au 30 août le temps
d'avoir la deuxième dose parce qu'un
parcours vaccinale complet c'est au
moins un mois et demi voire deux mois
c'est pas neuf jours c'est pas qu'on
vous demande c'est un amendement de bon
sens de cohérence d'ailleurs les gens
termine par là le ministre hier la
moitié reconnu 2000 la santé puisqu'il a
dit qu'il allait interroger je crois la
haute autorité de santé pour savoir si
on pouvait faire un test qui soit
valable non pas simplement trois jours
mais une semaine pour celles et ceux qui
ont eu la première dose donc là dessus
il faut bouger si vous bougez pas
l'assemblée nationale il faudra bouger
au sénat parce que c'est un manque de
cohérence c'est un manque de bon sens il
faut tout simplement encouragés à la
vaccination
ceux qui sont fait vacciner une première
fois au mois de juillet doivent pouvoir
avoir accès à toutes les activités et
les lieux s'ils se font vacciner en
deuxième dose au mois d'août
merci
donc je mets je vois les amendements 214
est identique défavorable commission un
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre rejeté
je me revois 1981 qui est pour contre
rejeté le 9 santé oms jeudi philippe ok
pour contre rejeté le 342 qui est pour
contre jeter le 216 qui est pour contre
jeter et enfin de 385 qui est pour
contre jeter le 191 monsieur des coeurs
et rapidement
monsieur le président cet amendement
visait à exclure de l'obligation de
passes sanitaires bien sûr les personnes
ne pouvant pas se faire vacciner en
raison de contre indication médicale
afin qu'elle ne soit pas pénalisée par
les mesures restrictives qui sont
envisagées il convient de prévoir ces
personnes puissent se présenter lors des
contrôles un certificat de contre
indication à la vaccination
merci le 557 même faire défendu le 536
oui merci monsieur le président cet
amendement vise à inclure les contre
indications à la vaccination dans la
liste des justificatifs permettant
d'avoir accès à un pass and it erp à
sanitaire qui prendrait la même forme
que pour un autre justificatif à savoir
le format qr code et j'en profite pour
rebondir puisque j'ai pas pu le faire
tout à l'heure sur les propos du
rapporteur
à défaut de respecter le parlement ce
serait bien de pas nous prendre
complètement pour des idiots et à savoir
énoncer des chiffres qui sont des
contrevérités monsieur le rapporteur
une première injection une première
injection
dans le cas du vaccin fader et
astrazeneca protège à 75% contre le
virus et contre le moderna à plus de 68
%
donc soit vous avez d'autres éléments
donc monsieur le ministre soit vous avez
d'autres éléments en capacité
soit vous avez d'autres éléments en
capacité de nous renseigner fondé de
façon scientifique soit vous ne pouvez
pas nous sortir des chiffres du chapeau
en disant 35%
pourquoi pas mais j'étais là hier
monsieur merci alors
voilà les amendements ont été présentés
amendements identiques mais sur la
docteure merci monsieur le président
pour ces trois amendements cette
question sera traitée par le décret
prévu à l'année à 28 l'appel des
constatations et des consultations ainsi
que des garanties sanitaires donc ce
sera un avis d'un fera pour revenir à la
protection certes dans les quelques
jours où la semaine qui suit la
vaccination
on est à 60 % mais au moment de la
deuxième dose c'est à dire quatre
semaines après on arrive à 30% et ça ne
diminue seul ministre avis défavorable
alors j'ai deux demandes de prise de
parole mais alors 3-2
alors monsieur monsieur brun oui
attendez organisez vous entre vous et
moi j'ai un moment donné on s'organise
dans un groupe
moi j'ai vu une demande de prise de
parole de madame voilà oui merci
monsieur le président je crois que c'est
important de prendre le temps de
débattre de cette question des contre
indications médicales au bac 5 et que
c'est important de pouvoir produire un
certificat de contre indication à la
vaccination par le médecin pour les
personnes qui ne peuvent pas se faire
vacciner pourquoi parce que elles
peuvent être atteinte d'une grave
maladie d'un cancer d'un qu'ovide l'on
est dans une situation particulière
je pense important aussi que dans le
débat on éclaire le débat de cas concret
et moi j'ai été saisi dans ma
circonscription d'une habitante qui a
été reçu sa première injection le 17
avril qui vingt minutes plus tard a fait
un malaise important le 23 juin sa
sérologie révélé une immunité 0 elle a
interrogé la rsl interrégions centre
hospitalier elle a interrogé son médecin
et tous hésitent à larrau vacciner et
elle n'a pas de réponse concrète et donc
pour cette personne ne l'a
quid du pass sanitaires pour ce cas qui
n'est pas isolé et donc quid de ses
libertés
je crois que c'est des sujets aussi
qu'il faut qu'on puisse le traiter dans
les débats
alors madame briest non mais coude et à
partir du moment où on respecte les deux
publié de faire tourner de groupe en
groupe
madame liste à la parole merci merci
merci monsieur le président rapidement
je voudrais dire ici mon inquiétude car
les français nous regarder jeu en tant
que médecin je ne voudrais pas qu'on
envoie le message qu'après une première
vaccination on puisse être protégé comme
l'a dit monsieur le rapporteur
ces 33% à partir du 14e jour après la
première vaccination et vous avez tous
autour de vous je suis sur des gens qui
ont été contaminés après leur première
injection
quand on regarde le nombre de malades
hospitalisés ils ont entre leurs deux
injections on est là pour protéger les
français
tout l'objet de ce pass sanitaire c'est
la protection des français quand
j'entends qu'on veut leur gâcher leurs
vacances mais ce qu'on veut essayer
c'est de les protéger c'est pas de leur
gâcher la vie donc au bien au contraire
c'est de les protéger
donc je crois qu'il faut remettre le
sens du débat dans le sens dans
l'objectif dans lequel nous menons merci
je mets donc au bois ces amendements
identiques avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
leur adoption qui est contre rejeté les
900 n'est pas défendu monsieur blanchet
le 200 plants capteurs vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président si
vous voulez je vais défendre les deux en
même temps fort kent en vie le pass
sanitaires sur lequel nous discutons est
un variant du pass sanitaire qui a été
appliqué aujourd'hui est que sur lequel
nous avons voté depuis le mois de mai
pourquoi je dirais que c'est invariant
parce que dans certains lieux il sera
pas obligé de montrer une pièce ont été
pour prouver qu'on a le bon test
déjà c'est une première question qui
interpelle et cet hiver j'ai déjà
interpellé là dessus le ministre par
rapport les dérogations d'établissement
de jour et de nuit notamment
mais le constat que l'on a qui existe
déjà dans certains lieux c'est qu'il ya
un cahier de rappel normalement je
rappelle depuis l'ouverture de certains
établissements combien d'entre nous
avons rempli ce cahier de rappel
lorsqu'on a été dans un restaurant ou
autre je sais pas mais moi pour ma part
pas beaucoup on me l'a pas souvent
proposé ce que je veux expliquer par
sela messieurs les ministres c'est que
le pass sanitaires ces deux étapes je
montre mon qr code
comme quoi je suis positif ou négatif
qui est vérifiée par la personne de
l'établissement et la deuxième étape
je dois scanner le qr code de
l'établissement pour valider le fait que
je sois dans l'établissement j'aimerais
messieurs les ministres que vous me
confirmer que déjà ces deux dispositifs
sont bien de ce que l'on parle à présent
si c'est bien le pass sanitaire que l'on
évoque à présent s'il ya bien les deux
étapes
si tel est le cas le présent amendement
les présentes amendement vous propose de
responsabilité les clients et peut-être
pas porter la responsabilité sur les
professionnels responsabilisant les
clients parce qu'on voit l'inefficacité
qu'il y aura de cela parce que
simplement on ne contrôlera pas
l'identité
dans des lieux et on voit aujourd'hui
avec le recul de 15 jours là où s'est
appliqué que déjà il ya quelques failles
parce que certains magouilles en ne
montrant des fausses pièces d'identité
pour repasser avec leur coeur code
donc comme on sait en plus qu'on ne
pourra pas on n'aura pas l'obligation de
montrer sa curiosité
donc ça va être la foire à tout donc
plutôt que de continuer comme ça j'ai
terminé en 10 secondes noces et le
président je préférerais qu'on
responsabilise les clients en disant
'vous scanner le qr code et talisman ça
fait un match globalement je vous
remercie de me suis donc les deux
amendements étaient présentés monsieur
le rapporteur
merci monsieur président donc sur le 274
le cahier de rappel relève du domaine
réglementaire et du décret du 1er juin
donc c'est un avis défavorable et sur le
275 le non respect des mesures prises au
nom du régime de gestion de la crise
sanitaire avait déjà sanctionné par les
dispositions générales prévues à
l'article l 36 31-1 et cela me semble
suffisant ce sera aussi un avis
défavorable sur ministre défavorable
également madame fiat a nommé monsieur
monsieur lac
merci monsieur le président juste pour
revenir sur deux trois points leur
effectivement après une première
injection
on n'est pas autant protégé qu'au bout
de deux se trouvent sexy qu'on nous
explique et qu'on nous fasse la leçon
mais que hier on nous ait appris que
avec deux injections quand on sait qu'on
peut être encore porter qu'on peut avoir
le virus
on nous explique qu'on pourra enlever le
masque des fois il faut être quand même
nom mais qui dit non mais fait la leçon
aussi à monsieur castex je crois qu'il
n'a pas tout compris non plus
donc il faut savoir faire les choses
monsieur blanc c'est ce que vous dites
la puissance comme le faisait remarquer
monsieur coquerel à partir de demain
monsieur castex nous l'a dit hier on ne
sera plus qu'à contact avec le pass
sanitaire avec deux injections
donc on va plus remplir les cahiers
abîme alors non mais on trouve ça aussi
choquant mais je pense qu'il va falloir
expliquer ya vraiment un monsieur le
premier ministre le virus et les vaccins
donc pour tout ça il ya vraiment une
difficulté et pour revenir à
l'amendement précédent moi je veux bien
que vous prenez tout par décret mais je
vous rappelle que pour prendre des
décrets faut quand même que les chocs
anaphylactiques soit notée dans la loi
merci alors abandonné le problème chez
mollat que je précise que sur le 125 qui
interviendra un peu plus tard la demande
du groupe socialiste et apparentés il y
aura un scrutin public
le scrutin est annoncée dans la salle de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur malacca
la parole oui merci monsieur le
président non je conseille aux collègues
pour savoir qui est vaccinée pour savoir
qui est malade pour savoir si la
première injection ça sert ou pas il ya
un excellent article dans le monde qui
montre qu'en fait on n'en sait
strictement rien parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'étude précise qui s'en fait
c'est le monde d'al donc je suppose que
c'est pas une fake news donc c'est quand
on dit que 98% des gens qui ont été
infectés par le cos vides sont des non
vaccinés en fait on n'en sait
strictement rien c'est ce que dit
l'article du monde donc c'est quand même
intéressant
d'une part d'autre part j'aimerais bien
j'ai une question précise pour le
ministre quand quelqu'un a eu le coc
vide
j'ai des remontées de circonscription et
le président du groupe monsieur
penchèrent en a aussi comme quoi les
gens qui roulent qu'ovide qui sont
normalement guéris ne peuvent pas avoir
le pass sanitaire directement et ça ça
pose un problème évidemment parce que ça
veut dire vous ne pouvez pas être
vaccinés parce que de toute façon vous
venez d'avoir le coc vide et en même
temps vous n'avez pas le droit aux
passes sanitaires donc il ya un problème
là donc j'aimerais bien qu'on ait un
éclaircissement parce que visiblement il
ya quelque chose qui n'est pas clair
dans la tête des des médecins merci je
me dis qu'on voit le 274 défavorable que
messieurs gouvernement qui est pour
[Musique]
qui est pour les 230 14
qui est contre
alors donc que je recommence tout que
l'incertitude qui est pour
pour elle
[Musique]
qui est contre
donc il est adopté alors le suivant
tombant le 4e 26 le 426 monsieur
gosselin yougoslave 426 défendu
défavorable commission des savoirs
gouvernement je me suis monsieur isaac
sibille voulait dire quelque chose
non je me vois qui est pour contre
rejeté le 490 ne pardonnez moi vous avez
la parole loin si vous avez la
gentillesse de défendre les deux merci
beaucoup y vient bien entendu donc cet
amendement vise à limiter les contrôles
sanitaires aux activités intérieures
principalement tout en permettant selon
les conditions de de les contrôler les
activer ou si le l'entrée dans les
activités extérieures et le deuxième
amendement vise à au moelleux permettre
jusqu'au 31 à 31 août
donc c'est pour faciliter dans les lieux
où il ya il n'y a pas de densité
particulière ou pas de danger
particulier la possibilité de
s'installer ou de d'entrée sans pâtir
sanitaire quand c'était l'extérieur
merci donc les deux ont été défendus
mais sur à porter merci monsieur le
président je pense que sans entrer dans
le débat des terrasses qui va venir
assez rapidement le passé militaire est
à lui qu indispensable pour lutter
contre la propagation du virus il est
utile partout il ya du public et du
brassage de foule
cela peut se produire aussi bien en
intérieur qu'en extérieur et si les
contaminations en extérieur sont
réduites elles existent et ce depuis
l'opération du virus encore plus depuis
la circulation dû lui variant delta
je rappelle que le plus grand koster
cluster au monde s'est produit aux états
unis dans un
nous rencontrent deux motards face à
cette quatrième vague tous les moyens
doivent être mis de notre côté pour
lutter contre ce virus tout en
permettant l'ouverture des lieux qui y
compris en extérieur ont été fermés lors
des précédentes vagues non c'est un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre mais même
avis pour les mêmes raisons même avis
défavorable suède zèle et monsieur
jumelles oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres les
débats que nous avons sont à cet égard
est extrêmement intéressant puisque vous
voyez bien que le dispositif que vous
proposez et que ce soit le conseil
d'état le défenseur des droits et plus
récemment encore la cnil tous ces
organismes nous disent attention ce que
vous mettez en place est extrêmement
attentatoires aux libertés individuelles
par contre ils disent si vous décidez de
mettre cela en place
en contrepartie il faut absolument que
vous puissiez montrer à la fois
l'opérationnalité du dispositif et
apporte effectivement aussi la preuve de
l'efficacité de tout cela et les débats
que nous avons montrent plusieurs choses
c'est que d'abord une chose est sûre si
vous mettez cela en place
vous êtes attentatoires aux libertés
individuelles ça c'est une certitude
mais que par contre les modalités
opérationnelles et l'efficacité elles ne
sont pas assurées et donc encore une
fois nous ne demandons pas mieux que de
pouvoir un moment donné adhérer à une
politique gouvernementale mais encore
faut-il que cette politique
gouvernementale elle soit fondé
l'ensemble des questions que nous posons
vous n'apportez aucune réponse est donc
votre dispositif est totalement
disproportionnée d'un côté vous êtes
attends-toi attentatoires aux libertés
individuelles et par contre sur les
autres aspects rien n'est fait
sérieusement tout ceci est du bricolage
ça n'est pas sérieux
est ce que je vous ai dit hier je le
pense de plus en plus avec ce que vous
êtes en train de nous préparer hélas
vous nous dites qu'il n'y aura pas de
confinement
ce que je crains c'est que tout cela ça
sera d'une part à pas sanitaires et dans
un second temps du confinement
si monsieur gym à la parole bon notre
collègue pont me pardonnera cette
métaphore maritime et il faut remonter
de la cale pour être sur le pont sur la
question du pouvoir réglementaire et du
pouvoir législatif
je reviens un peu en décalé je m'en
excuse mais à partir du moment où son
schéma un duel vaccinale n'est pas
complet on se trouve confronté à une
privation de nos libertés fondamentales
individuelles
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
pensons que inscrire dans la loi
je reviens sur l'idée de ceux qui pour
des raisons médicales ne peuvent pas se
faire vacciner
la possibilité des dérogations ne
relèvent pas du champ du pouvoir
réglementaire mais bien du champ du
pouvoir législatif puisqu'il s'agit
d'une liberté fondamentale préserver
deuxième élément sur l'amendement porté
par notre collègue jacqueline du bois
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
alors au début vous avez arroser tous
azimuts d'une manière techno empirique
nationale et peu à peu vous avez pris
conscience qu'il était nécessaire
d'adapter les mesures en fonction du
lieu de la situation spécifique et y
compris dans un couple réinventer préfet
maire dans un couple réinventer préfet
maire pourquoi ne pas permettre au
préfet dans un dialogue avec les élus
locaux sur la gestion des espaces
extérieurs d'adapter la situation
sanitaire en fonction de la réalité des
territoires en inscrivant dans la loi le
pass sanitaire obligatoire vous priver
les élus et les préfets d'adaptabilité
démesurée de leur efficacité de leur
opérationnalité merci donc qui est pour
quai pour contre rejeté 552 quai pour
contre rejeté le 7 115 n'est pas défendu
le leur nous en arrivons à la série
qu'il en avait eu un vote électronique
165 n'est pas défendue par contre alain
fiat à la parole pour le 620 au monsieur
bernalicis ou quelqu'un non personne il
n'est pas descendu à vous avez la parole
vous avez ma chère collègue ministre
monsieur collègue hugues ratenon à la
parole au lait cru oui en préambule je
vais rappeler quelques années a tué les
risques liés à l'extension du pass annie
terre des alertes de la défenseur des
droits en premier lieu une forme de
pouvoir de police octroyés aux
entreprises assurent elles-mêmes les
contrôles de la détention d'un pass à
noter pour les personnes souhaitant
accéder à leurs services
or ce contrôle devrait relever des des
autorités publiques justes elles aussi
le manque de débat démocratique ça vous
pouvez pas le nier le risque d'une
double peine pour les plus pauvres
les restrictions d'accès au service 5 le
risque d'atteintes aux droits des
enfants on fait du sport dire l'accès au
droit aux loisirs et à la culture sont
des droits fondamentaux pour les enfants
qu'ils permettre le bon développement et
cetera et cetera
vous avez bien compris que nous nous
opposons à l'élargissement d'un
paternité pour les activités de loisirs
qui ira se faire tester pour aller au
cinéma ou encore ou au bowling comme
exemple ses activités de loisirs auront
elles encore la légèreté qu'elle procure
normalement après un an et demi de
restriction mes chers collègues nous
imposer aux français
encore une vie sous contrainte alors que
les conséquences des confinement à
répétition déjà était désastreuse ou à
la santé mentale et les fins de mois de
nos compatriotes ses activités de
loisirs impliquons donc de nombreuses
contraintes au risque que des
entreprises et sociétés ayant paix au
coeur de métier les loisirs souffre d'un
manque de fréquentation après plus d'un
an de restriction pour ses activités
jugées non essentielles les temps seront
encore plus
sur 6 les contraintes sa loi disent
aussi mes chers collègues je vous
demande d'adopter la suppression de
l'alinéa 8
merci
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président c'est un
moment vise à supprimer les activités de
loisirs du champ du pass sanitaires tout
d'abord parce que la notion qui est
indiqué dans le texte de loi est
beaucoup trop flou est beaucoup trop
large dans sa définition
et puis ça va renforcer le caractère
d'une usine à gaz
inapplicable et excessif du pass
sanitaires ça vient d'être évoquée par
mon collègue ratenon les effets sur les
mineurs en particulier les enfants et
les adolescents et à défenseur des
droits nous le rappelle cette semaine
est extrêmement pénalisant en
particulier pour un droit fondamental
qui est celui de l'accès aux loisirs je
pense notamment un centre de loisirs au
centre de vacances et à d'autres
activités de loisirs qui sont
particulièrement importantes pendant la
période estivale pour pour nos enfants
et pour nos adolescents et puis ils
voulaient le président indiqué qu'on
pourrait faire le parallèle aussi pour
les activités sportives et les activités
physiques qui n'ont jamais été
considérés par votre gouvernement comme
un bien essentiel pendant la crise
sanitaire et c'est une erreur de
soumettre l'accès des équipements
sportifs comme les piscines où les
rassemblements de plus de cinquante
sportifs au pass sanitaires c'est un
bien essentiel et on le sait avec
l'activité physique adaptée aujourd'hui
c'est la meilleure façon de prévenir de
prévenir les facteurs de comorbidité
associé à la convie 19 de lutter contre
la corrida et même de guérir des effets
de l'accueil que vider les séquelles du
coc vide long et je voudrais dire a
ajouté que c'est la meilleure façon
aussi de lutter contre la sédentarité le
surpoids et l'obésité qui vous fera
faire des ravages
nous avons un publié hier avec marie
tamarelle un rapport du comité
d'évaluation et de contrôle sur ce sujet
il faut absolument remettre l'activité
physique au coeur des politiques
publiques est là avec le pass à lithaire
ou encore freiner cette activité
physique le 919
oui merci monsieur le président donc oui
je propose supprimer la linea 8 et il
est lié à l'alinéa 7 7 alinéa 7 nous dit
quoi subordonnés donc la présentation
d'un pass sanitaire nous dit on
et qui pourrait nous empêcher l'accès à
certains lieux établissements et
services ou événements dans le terme de
service vous m'excuserez mais c'est
particulièrement imprécis imprécis aussi
la linea 8 en tant que tel puisqu'il dit
toutes les activités de loisirs
donc la pêche les concernés le tennis
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya deux
personnes qui veulent jouer au tennis a
on peut c'est un service donc on peut
tout simplement fermé le terrain de
tennis enfin je trouve que c'est
totalement imprécis et qu'évidemment le
conseil constitutionnel s'amusera
beaucoup avec ce genre d'imprécisions la
deuxième chose c'est que je n'ai
toujours pas de réponse sur le
certificat de rémission
quand est-ce qu'il est valable à partir
de quand et quand est ce que le no quand
est-ce qu'il peut être un pass annie
terre
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
sur ces amendements identiques
merci monsieur prénom le pass and it et
actu est déjà en vigueur pour les
activités de loisirs dont lui misé dès
aujourd'hui le poste de pas de problème
de définition mon avis le conseil
constitutionnel a estimé dans sa
décision du 31 mai 2021 que la notion
d'activités de loisirs qui exclut
notamment les activités politiques
syndicales ou culturelle n'est ni
reprise ni ambigu donc s'établit des
avis défavorables
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président je voudrais profiter de cet
amendement pour répondre sur plusieurs
éléments d'abord monsieur là qu'il faut
pas raconter n'importe quoi le conseil
constitutionnel a validé la précédente
le précédent projet de loi qui portait
sur activités de loisirs et grand
rassemblement il me semble que là on est
juste dans l'extension activités de
loisirs en matière de seuils et que donc
à partir du moment où il a validé une
fois activités de loisirs je ne vois pas
pourquoi la deuxième fois le conseil
constitutionnel se déjugera lui-même
on ne validant pas donc on peut avoir un
débat sur la précision du terme je
comprends la déjà eu on a eu il ya six
semaines
avoir un débat sur la constitutionnalité
à moins que vous ayez des arguments
constitutionnels supérieurs à ceux du
conseil constitutionnel je pense que là
on sera tous d'accord deuxième élément
je voudrais revenir sur quelque chose
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure parce
que je pense que c'est assez grave
quand vous dites que le monde dit qu'on
ne sait rien de la contamination à
première dose deuxième dose et ses
terres mais c'est complètement faux
monsieur molex est complètement faussé
complètement même de la désinformation
ce que dit le monde
ce que dit le monde monsieur molac c'est
qu'il dit qu'on n'a pas la statistique
complète de tous les vaccinés et donc on
peut contrôler cette statistiquement
c'est à dire que comme dans toute les
prélèvements statistiques on prend un
échantillon représentatif et on procède
par déduction scientifique monsieur
molac vous êtes médecin je crois et donc
vous le savez quand vous êtes un message
donc on procède par déduction
scientifique sur les éléments et ça
ajoute un autre élément mashimo l'axé
qu'il n'y a aucun pays aucun pays qui
libère autant les données les données
d'hospitalisation les données de
contamination les données toutes les
données sur la crise que la france est
ce qui permet d'ailleurs à ce que des
personnes comme guillaume rosiers à ce
que des services comme kobe deux tracker
ou comme kobe de listes puissent se
mettre en place et par ailleurs afin de
contenter votre appétit en statistiques
notamment sur le nombre d'hospitaliser
qui sont vaccinées la france sera le
seul pays dans les jours qui viennent à
libérer les données c'est-à-dire a
croisés puisque vous aimez la technique
le fichier civique avec le fichier est
si vaccins pour faire en sorte que
chaque semaine tout le monde et les
statistiques pour savoir si les gens qui
sont hospitalisés ont été vaccinés ou
pas et à voir tout un ensemble des
détails qui ne sont pas fournis par les
autres pays donc on fait de la
transparence
on fait en sorte que la société civile
les parlementaires
l'ensemble des intervenants puissent
avoir l'ensemble des données et je
rappelle que nous sommes les seuls à le
faire
merci brunel puis monsieur vernalis bien
moi je voudrais d'abord m'exprimer sur
la méthode je mets pas en cause le
président mais c'est quand même un
projet de loi important
et lorsqu on limite la discussion à deux
députés pour l'ensemble des groupes ici
qui sont importants ça commence à être
agaçant à ce niveau là parce que on a
déjà un projet de loi 24 heures après il
faut déjà répondre à toutes les
questions
c'est à face à nice
r dont on n'en veut pas dans le citoyen
n'en veut pas et on a un gouvernement
qui dit c'est comme ça il ya un décret
c'est pas autrement
c'est prévu mais à quoi on sert à quoi
on sert ici on a un on est quand même
des députés on compte pour 1 nous si on
a une situation de la réalité new si on
connaît la jeunesse la jeunesse une
jeunesse qui est sacrifiée c'est une
jeunesse qui est oublié
c'est une jeunesse on peut pas faire
comme si la pandémie n'a pas existé
c'est une jeunesse qui a des troubles
des troubles psychologiques et
aujourd'hui on rajoute deux soudans la
musique en dix ans la jeunette
attention pour les loisirs faites
attention à ceux ci vous devez faire le
point alors monsieur le ministre
avec tous vous possédez administrative
pour des cours pour les jeunes partie de
bowling tout ce qu'on va faire mais j'ai
quand même affolant affolant écoutez
nous changer votre calendrier
écoutez les députés et j'ai noté les
anciennes monsieur goodhand vous ne
remettez pas en cause la présidence je
veux bien noté mais chez bernard six
puisque plus que la présidence et le
règlement de l'assemblée à mon avis qui
est en cause monsieur le vice président
bien sûr les arguments constitutionnels
juste pour dire quelques éléments aux
ministres qui sont au banc par exemple
dans un exemple récent
les mesures de sûreté existe déjà dans
notre droit en matière pénale
et pourtant la dernière fois que vous
avez proposé un texte sur le sujet qui a
été voté le conseil continue elle l'a
censuré parce que les dispositions de la
mesure de sûreté mises les unes dans les
autres étaient disproportionnés on est
dans le même cas de figure le principe
des activités de loisirs et de ce que ça
recoupe effectivement ca s'est établi et
c'était d'autant plus établi qu'on
parlait de grands rassemblements vous
l'avez vous même dit en fait c'est le
conjonction grand rassemblement
activités de loisirs on arrive à
circonscrire le périmètre
là où ça devient problématique ces
activités de loisirs et plus de job ou
potentiellement une jauge par décret ne
peut pas anticiper sur les futurs
décrets en tout cas on peut pas le
prendre en compte parce que vous dites
50 aujourd'hui rien ne nous dit qu'après
demain vous ne direz pas 10 ou 15 août
le prénom de la république en se levant
un matin suite à un conseil de défense
vise baran ce sera à partir de cinq
personnes
rien voilà donc donc il ya un risque
constitutionnel vous ne pouvez pas dire
le contraire mais par-delà par delà tout
ça en réalité on a un problème avec
cette application du passager y compris
dans votre modèle et dans votre logique
puisqu'on pourra si on l'a participer
aux activités de loisir sans masque ne
pas être qu'à contacter alors que j'en
reviens un sujet scientifique
pourrait-on avoir une statistique
établie du pourcentage de chances de ne
pas attraper le variant delta quand on
est vaccinés est ce qu'on à 100%
est ce que c'est on est on est parés à
100%
face aux variants delta quand on est
vacciné je connais la réponse je connais
la réponse
sauf que je vous rappelle qu' hier le
ministre vo nous a expliqué que si on
était tous vaccinés à 100% il y aurait
plus besoin du pass annie terre et que
le virus ne circulerait plus alors fait
savoir
soit il peut quand même circuler soit
ils circulent plus et ce n'est pas
pareil de dire qu il circulera - parce
que c'est pour ça que je suis favorable
à ce qu on se vaccine puisque je suis
pour qu'il circule moins mais arrêtez
d'asséner des contrevérités parce qu'à
la fin vous allez vous retrouver avec
des variants delta partout et une
obligation alors que les ans en matinée
de devoir recourir ici les faveurs d'un
v6 tous sont concernés au vote c'est un
vote électronique chacun a pu regagner
sa place donc donc nous votons sur les
165 est identique
plutôt le 620 identique puisque c'est
celui-là qui était défendu le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votants 65 expriment
et 160 majorité 81 pour 58 contre 102
rejeté le 1134 pas défendu madame kuryk
le 1121 vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président c'est un
amendement en fait qui propose de ne pas
imposer le pass sanitaires sur les
espaces extérieurs des activités de
loisirs ou des activités de restauration
ou encore les foires en extérieur merci
donc l'amendement était présenté à vis
de la commission défavorable à vis du
gouvernement défavorable mais je
président la bad à la parole merci ce
président juste sur les activités de
loisirs ce que qu'est ce que pensent des
responsables doublement nous disent en
gros le pass sanitaires sur le long
terme c'est utile parce que ça sécurise
la clientèle parce que ça permet
effectivement de faire en sorte qu'on
évite des périodes de stop and go
permanente entre le confinement et la
possibilité d'aller dans les parcs
mais le problème que nous avons là c'est
pas le passe à long terme
le problème c'est le court terme et le
timing que vous avez choisi ce que là où
c'est compliqué pour les professionnels
c'est que vous le faites au plein coeur
de l'été en plein mois de juillet le
variant delta il n'est pas apparu au
mois de juillet c'est ça le problème
c'est le défaut d'anticipation permanent
de ce gouvernement qui fait porter la
responsabilité aux professionnels mais
bien sûr que si pourquoi avoir attendu
le 12 juillet pour annoncer cela
pourquoi le faire en pleine vacances
pourquoi au moment même où les parcs de
loisirs sont mes chers collègues en
découdre
cette pression là bas mais j'ai le
président des victoires et donc ce que
nous vous demandons c'est pas d'enlever
le supprimer le pass sanitaires pour les
activités de loisirs
mais c'est de faire en sorte que cette
période transitoire comme on vous l'a
demandé tout à l'heure parce que les
parcs de loisirs aujourd'hui ils ont la
double peine ils ont connu les
confinements et là vous leur mettez un
truc sur la tête au plein de mois de
juillet donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est
anticiper c'est prévoir c'est mieux
organiser les choses parce que le
variant delta ils datent pas du mois de
juillet et datent de bien avant
et malheureusement c'est ce défaut
d'anticipation qui coûtent des points
terriblement important pour tous les
professionnels du secteur touristique
monsieur brun doigt la parole nous
passerons de vote oui merci monsieur le
président un peu dans dans la continuité
de ce que vient de dire le président à
battre jour et attirer l'attention du
gouvernement et de la majorité si elle
veut bien écouter deux minutes sur les
difficultés malgré tout de mise en place
de ce pass sanitaires et s'éteint un des
promoteurs du passani terre qui vous le
dit là à l'époque où vous étiez
totalement opposé au dispositif pour les
activités extérieures y compris dans des
sites fermés où on peut se dire
effectivement il est possible à l'entrée
de contrôle et dépasse sanitaires il
faut expliquer aux français pourquoi
dans ce cas on impose un passani terre
sur des activités extérieures parce que
vous allez avoir des situations par
exemple de réalisation balnéaire où la
fréquentation de rue très commerçante
fera que vous avez une concentration
immédiate de population qui n'est pas
forcément totalement en mouvement elle
peut être plus ou moins statique avec un
risque potentiel si on considère que
l'extérieur est un risque potentiel de
contamination au repas sanitaires et
dans le même temps vous allez imposer
des passes sanitaire par exemple dans
des parcs zoologiques totalement ouvert
où vous avez sur plusieurs centaines
d'hectares la même population qui sera
beaucoup moins concentré locaux réalité
c'est un vrai problème de compréhension
et d'adaptation et là je rejoins
totalement damien abad quand il dit le
problème c'est que on demande la au parc
zoologique à toutes les activités de
loisirs extérieurs et autres de
s'adapter en quelques jours et à nos
concitoyens de s'adapter en quelques
jours là où il faudrait un peu de
souplesse et tous les amendements qui
sont déposés finalement vous demande de
la souplesse peut-être dans
l'application si jamais la mesure doit
malgré tout être maintenu mais au moins
de la souplesse de la part des préfets
dans l'application pour que epa
sanitaires depuis s'être demandé
peut-être à une échéance un peu plus
lointaine de manière systématique et non
pas immédiatement à l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi
je me revois l'amendement 1121
défavorable commission des gouvernements
qui est pour jean option qui est contre
rejeté le 4 100 en régnant dans ma
circonscription nous avons de grosses
activités touristiques notamment à
rocamadour et à padirac
à côté de cela nous avons beaucoup de
restaurateurs qui ont les espaces
extérieurs et surtout tous les activités
de loisirs qui font aussi la vitalité de
notre ruralité pendant l'été l'objectif
de cet amendement
c'est bien entendu pouvoir apporter de
la souplesse nous sommes tous d'accord
qu'il faut trouver des solutions parce
sanitaire vaccination pour enrayer la
maladie mais je suis aussi convaincu que
nous sommes capables de trouver un
équilibre qui permet d'amoindrir aussi
la charge pour notre réalité notamment
dans les circonscriptions où il y a de
l'espace où on peut faire de la
distanciation pour les activités en
extérieur
je vous remercie merci mes chers
collègues alors d'un format semblait que
sur cette discussion commune et permal
d'amendements
et sur le 139 est identique à la demande
du groupe l'est républicain
il y aura un scrutin public le scrutin
est annoncée dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale il en va de même
pour le 568 qui interviendra juste après
la 7 à la demande du groupe socialiste
et apparentés le scrutin est également
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale nous revenons au 219 la dame
nouvelle j à la parole
oui mais merci monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres les discussions
que nous avons ici sur le pass sanitaire
d'abord sur la manière dont les
personnes peuvent disposer d'un pas
sanitaire est maintenant sur le
périmètre des activités montres je
dirais les difficultés d'application et
les difficultés de mise en oeuvre ceux
de ce pass sanitaire dans des conditions
très rapide parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'anticipation et les annonces
effectuées le 12 juillet avec une
application dès maintenant pose un
certain nombre de problèmes
et effectivement cela a un impact qu'un
seul ministre sur les vacances des
français qui doivent pour un certain
nombre modifier l'organisation qui avait
été prévu et regarde ça il est important
de simplifier d'assouplir de prendre en
compte ces éléments et c'est ce qui vous
est proposé au travers cet amendement
nous savons qu'en en extérieur la
transmission du virus est moins
importante en extérieur qu'en intérieur
je pense que cette affirmation personne
ne peut la contredire
nous savons également que tout ce qui
concerne la restauration et sont des
éléments qui participent au bien-être
des uns et des autres qui participe
également dans le cadre d'une activité
économique au niveau du pays dans le
cadre du tourisme
donc il vous est demandé aux traverses
et à mon nom de la simplification et de
faire en sorte que tout ce qui est
activités en extérieur notamment
terrasse ne soit pas pris en compte de
la même manière dans le périmètre pour
le sujet du pass sanitaires merci donc
merci j amendements identiques le 591
n'est pas défendu le médecin de
non plus donc nous en venons maintenant
au 983 983 pas défendu pardonnez moi
même du bon pardonnez moi
merci jean 83 merci monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres
chers collègues je suis attaché à la
mise en oeuvre de ce pass sanitaire seul
gage pour limiter la diffusion de ce
virus et sécuriser les français mais je
suis aussi attaché au caractère
acceptable et accepté des mesures que
nous prenons et que nous mettons en
oeuvre
on a tous un rôle à jouer de pédagogie
tous tous les bancs de pédagogie
d'information les plus objectives et
possible s appuyant sur des faits et des
données scientifiques
on a aussi un rôle d' écoute de nos
concitoyens et nous avons comme je
disais hier la responsabilité de placer
les curseurs des contraintes imposées
aux français et nous savons tous ces
contraintes sont très lourdes pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et on a à
mesurer le bénéfice risque l'image du
gouvernement qui est sans cesse dans
cette réflexion
le bénéfice s'est bien entendu la
protection des français le risque c'est
celui de la diffusion du virus
c'est celui du non respect des mesures
que nous prenons
parce qu elles ne seraient pas acceptées
parce qu'elle ne serait pas comprise ou
parce qu'elle ne serait pas applicable
parce que trop rapide cet amendement et
j'en ai plusieurs visent à trouver de la
et à donner de la souplesse aux mesures
et notamment sur les rassemblements
enfin sur les lieux de restauration les
lieux de loisirs ou les foires en
extérieur et je crois que ça permettrait
aux français d'entrer pleinement bien
entendu dans cette nouvelle dans ces
nouvelles contraintes
avec ce pas salutaire puisque le virus
et la halle virus delta est là et il
faut être solide
je pense dans les mesures à prendre
qui donne justement cette souplesse qui
rend plus accepter acceptable l'ensemble
de ces mesures je vous remercie
merci madame antoine 87 défendu madame
ménard le 30 sept
oui merci monsieur le président en
réalité beaucoup de français sont pas
opposés au pass sanitaires ils sont
opposés en revanche beaucoup d'entre eux
aux modalités d'application de ce pass
sanitaires et si si beaucoup ils sont
opposés c'est parce que votre loi le
manque de lisibilité elle manque de
clarté il y avait des mesures très
simples a expliqué d'abord des dates qui
sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
encore une fois je l' ai déjà dit hier
mais on peut pas avoir des modalités
d'application avec des mesures qu'ils
prennent effet le 21 juillet d'autres le
1er août d'autres encore le 30 août
d'autres encore le 30 septembre c'est
pas possible
les français se retrouvent pas on
comprend plus rien et l'autre modalités
très clair qu'on aurait pu mettre en
oeuvre c'est justement cette distinction
entre intérieur et extérieur
le pass sanitaire en extérieur c'est
extrêmement difficile à appliquer ce
sera impossible pour un certain nombre
de commerces et de restaurants à
appliquer idem pour les foires idem pour
les ovins les français n'y comprennent
plus rien et c'est très compliqué
mon collègue brindeau l'a dit tout à
l'heure quand vous avez un lieu qui peut
se faire mais même s'il est extérieur
mais tu peut se faire mais là c'est
facile
une terrasse de café expliqué aux
restaurateurs qui a 100 pence en place
150 places sur sa terrasse comment il va
faire pour contrôler un pass sanitaires
c'est impossible pratiquement c'est
impossible
et si c'est impossible pratiquement
évidemment ça va c'est une loi qui ne
sera pas acceptée vous sous-estimer
l'importance de l'acceptabilité de la
loi de la lisibilité de la volaille ouah
c'est vraiment le défaut majeur de ce
projet choix merci merci avant de donner
la parole à murcie neri pour 662 qui est
en discussion commune je précise que en
raison de l'importance du sujet en
raison du nombre d'amendements
discussion commune et en raison du
nombre de mains qui se lèvent pour me
demander la parole je donnerai la parole
à
un orateur pour les groupes qui le
souhaitent voilà le 6 ans le monsieur
cinéma parole oui je présente le moment
de notre vice président oui le présent
amendement a pour objet de préserver des
activités de loisirs qui se dérouleront
entièrement en extérieur avec les
accrobranches certains zoos et parcs
animaliers je pense au parc animalier
saint martin à plein dans la loire le
sein des centres équestres et des clubs
de plage
merci merci je signe identique madame
valentin oui merci monsieur le président
donc ça a été dit à la mise en oeuvre de
ce passé complexe
j'ai eu hier - le dirigeant du d'un
accro branches qui effectivement m'a
appelé hier soir en me disant qu'il
s'était fait insulter toute la journée
puisqu'il a voulu mettre en place le
pass les gens font 50 60 70 km pour
venir
et quand ils arrivent en leur dis pas
non je suis désolé vous pouvez pas
monter donc c'est juste la réalité en
fait il faut vous rendre compte
qu'aujourd'hui se passe n'est pas adapté
il ya eu beaucoup trop de trop peu de
temps pour le mettre en oeuvre il faut
laisser un peu plus de marge de
manoeuvre en plus à l'extérieur
le taux de contamination est très faible
donc pourquoi imposer un pass sanitaires
et des activités d'extérieur
merci madame à l'inter je m'autorise a
effectivement précisé que sur les
accrobranches n'y a pas plus extérieur
des accrobranche effectivement également
sur un sujet 139 me gosselin c'est vrai
que les aqua branche à l'intérieur il y
en a un peu moins
oui quelques quelques mots pour revenir
en arrière et en défendant cette cet
amendement sur l'ambiguïté de nos de nos
débats c'est quand même assez terrible
c'est que un bon nombre de nos
concitoyens pensent qu'aujourd'hui nous
débattons du pass sanitaires sur les
parcs de loisirs sur les terrasses de
cafés etc mais pas du tout en réalité
c'est le décret du 20 donc un acte
gouvernemental qui a obligé à partir
d'hier au moment du début de nos travaux
sur ce texte législatif qui a obligé
hier à recourir au pacini terre donc les
gens s'imaginent qu'aujourd'hui cette
nuit nous débattons
l'autorisation ou non de ce pass
sanitaire et que c'est la loi qui le
fixent pas du tout c'est une décision
gouvernementale il est important de le
rappeler est important de rappeler que
cette décision gouvernementale et
précipité oui il y as danger oui il y à
des variantes très bien je dis bien des
variants parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle
du delta mais il y en a d'autres qui
sont en train de se développer et dont
on va bientôt nous parler j'imagine mais
aujourd'hui dans la précipitation les
parcs de loisirs des activités
extérieures se retrouve coincé alors que
réellement on pouvait faire autrement
nos concitoyens se retrouve coincé quand
ils ont commencé leur première
vaccination et n'ont pas pu encore avoir
le second rendez vous et il se trouve
coincé parce qu'il y a une forme aussi
de dogmatisme
on nous dit pour la clarté des choses
c'est intérieur extérieur point barre
jusqu'à présent on nous disait que le
risque
il était essentiellement pour les
activités d'intérieur donc ce que nous
vous proposons ici en bon sens quand il
y à des activités sur des hectares et
des hectares on pense à la cua branche
on pense aussi au parc zoologique et à
d'autres activités
on vous propose de laisser souffler
respirait les gens votre pass devient en
réalité un vrai passeport pour toute
activité un contrôle permanent du
quotidien de nos concitoyens
et si des mesures sont nécessaires oui
parce qu'il y à une crise sanitaire qui
est très grave
ce même si le quotidien n'est pas
acceptable donc laissé au moins les gens
respirent est si à l'extérieur pour des
actes en donner la parole à madame carew
pour défendre le 648 je précise que je
suis également saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public sur le 499 que nous
examinerons dans cette même discussion
commune et c'est une demande du groupe
u10 et apparentés et indépendant et donc
il y aura
secret d'un état non c'est bien madame
carew à la parole
merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui va dans le même sens je
pense que là les arguments étaient ont
été apportées il n'est pas raisonnable
de mettre en place ce pas sanitaires
d'une manière aussi rapide sur les
activités d'extérieur
vous voyez bien que c'est on ne peut pas
mettre en place des mesures qui sont
incontrôlables la nuit non seulement à
la cohésion de la nation mais ça nuit à
quoi personne ne pourra comprendre au
coeur de l'été la manière dont on va
appliquer ça donc au moins limite on le
passe
moi j'y suis pas favorable à ce parce
que je pense qu'une politique de santé
publique ça repose d'abord sur des
éléments de santé publique
des tests des vaccins et pas sur une
fille cage de la population femme je
pense pas que ce soit vraiment la
solution
donc même si je ne suis pas favorable à
ce passe cela étant fait en sorte qu'il
soit au moins applicable dans une
version raisonnable et donc excluant les
activités d'extérieur 6780
8 madame du bouton home alone charles
pardonnez moi madame sardana parole
défendu pardonnez moi alors nous en
venons 568 madame vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre moi ce matin je suis saisi et
c'est un exemple pour pour expliquer
concrètement le manque de lisibilité de
de votre projet de loi je suis saisi par
une présidente d'association qui
organise une journée un soutien à une
chapelle la chapelle de luz année à
montréal du gers dans le matin il y à
une messe pas besoin de passes
sanitaires à midi il y à un pique nique
extérieur il faut le pass and i ter et
l'après midi il y un cancer il faut le
passé ni terre que dois je répondre à
cette présidente de cette petite
association qui n'y comprend plus rien
merci merci alors 499 librado oui merci
monsieur le président une des conditions
monsieur le ministre de réussite de
l'instauration du pass sanitaires c'est
la lisibilité la souplesse le bon sens
et l'intelligence pratique chacun
d'entre nous sur tous les bancs de cet
hémicycle va pouvoir multiplier les
exemples de complexité de la mise en
oeuvre du pass sanitaires sur des sites
extérieurs petit festival ouvert on pas
recouvert pas sanitaires ou papa
sanitaires à partir du moment où ça
rassemble plus de 60 personnes par
exemple d'autres événements qui sont à
la fois en sites qui peuvent être
fermées donc houleux pas sanitaire peut
être demandée facilement et d'autres
ensuite totalement ouvert où il sera
impossible puisque les gens sont en
déambulation et je pense au festival par
exemple de promenades photographiques
que j'ai à vendôme
tout ça crée de la confusion s'il n'y a
pas de la souplesse et les amendements
qui sont présentés le mien en
particulier est vraiment un amendement
d'appel
si jamais cette mesure elle est
appliquée de manière uniforme sans tenir
compte de la réalité de ce que vivent
nos concitoyens de ce qu'on peut faire
de ce que peuvent faire les
organisateurs
alors ce sera un échec sans nom parce
que nos concitoyens vont rejeter ce pas
sanitaires alors qu'il est le seul
instrument possible pour que ne referme
pas demain des lieux de culture des
lieux de loisirs les restaurants les
cafés ce que personne ne souhaite ici
mais je vous en conjure monsieur le
ministre fait passer ses messages donner
des engagements gouvernementaux à la
représentation nationale pour que ce
pass sanitaire qui aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs sur la base du décret n'a
aucun fondement légal soit appliquée de
manière différenciée et intelligente
merci le 38 madame ménard merci monsieur
le président très très rapidement
puisque j'ai déjà exposé mon nom mais
éléments tout à l'armée je reviens sur
la nécessité de la lisibilité de la loi
et de l'acceptabilité de la loi en fait
les français n'y comprennent plus rien y
compris dans vos propres arguments je
vais reprendre l'histoire des terrasses
l'histoire de du daily star du pass
sanitaires pour les adolescents on a
entendu monsieur le ministre de la santé
nous dire en commission mais si vous ne
posez pas le passé ni terre aux
adolescents ça veut dire qu'en fait
l'espèce de deux sanctuaires qui va être
créée par ce pass sanitaires il n'a plus
lieu d'être puisque les adolescents
n'étant pas vaccinés ou n'ayant pas
enfin n'ayant pas le pass sanitaires de
toute façon ils vous réduire à néant
cette espèce de sanctuaires qui induit
par le passé n'étaient donc il nous
expliquait sur une terrasse de café
si vous avez des parents qui ont été
vaccinés qui ont pas sanitaire mais
qu'on ne demande pas le pass sanitaires
aux adolescents ça sert plus à rien ne
pas salutaire de cette furia et dans vos
propres mesures vous acceptez en fait
que les adolescents doivent présenter
leurs passes annie terre qu'à partir du
30 septembre
et dans le même temps ils ne doivent pas
le présenter pourra le lycée et au
collège
expliquez-moi comment les français
peuvent comprendre ce texte de loi
c'est incompréhensible tout le monde s'y
perd aucune lisibilité et donc aucune
acceptabilité c'est pour ça que les
français ont ce sentiment de défiance
envers vous c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
sont dans la rue et moi je vous demande
de les écouter et je vous demande de
prendre des mesures de bon sens se passa
ni terre il ne peut pas s'appliquer à
l'extérieur c'est une évidence
ça ne sera pas possible dans les faits
ce sera possible pour les petites
terrasses de café quand à 4 tables aucun
problème quand vous avez 100 tables mais
ça y est plus monsieur m érigée la
parole pour le 336 oui mais merci
monsieur le président nous avons entendu
hier soir le ministre verrons nous dire
qu'il fallait faire tout ça parce que
nous étions dans une situation d'urgence
et je lui ai eu l'occasion de lui
répondre que l'urgence elle est lié
notamment au fait que nous soyons que
vous soyez en l'occurrence toujours dans
un défaut d'anticipation
parce qu'effectivement les variants
existe maintenant depuis plusieurs mois
même le variant delta et vous venez
aujourd'hui au dernier moment imposé un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont pour
la plupart totalement inapplicable pour
des questions de calendrier
j'ai d'ailleurs peur mais j'espère me
tromper que nous ayons dans quelques
semaines dans quelques mois en même
temps le pass sanitaires et des re
confinement ou des nouveaux couvre-feu
j'espère me tromper mais là encore le
défaut d'anticipation de votre politique
qui est la marque de fabrique de votre
politique à d'énormes conséquences sur
le plan humain mais également sur le
plan sanitaire et sur le plan des
libertés publiques
maintenant vous savez aujourd'hui c'est
quasiment impossible d'avoir des
certitudes
alors sortez de vos postures majoritaire
certes écouter plus le parlement rang
des plus acceptables
le pass annie terre auquel vous tenez
écoutez un peu plus l'opposition fait
preuve d'humilité et accepter au moins
de sortir les activités de plein air
dupas sanitaire si toutefois vous tenez
absolument à imposer cette mesure
merci
imaginez filipe bole 908 qui ferait
l'objet d'influencés beaucoup monsieur
le président messieurs les ministres
il faut comprendre à ce stade que dans
ce projet de passes sanitaire il ya des
choses qui sont complètement
contre-productif y compris d'un point de
vue sanitaire
nous avons été unanimes enfin au moment
du décompte final à reconnaître les
bienfaits de l'activité physique et
sportive dans la protection de chaque
personne contre certains effets
indésirables graves du coc vie
aujourd'hui
vous n'allez pas imposé et tant mieux de
passes sanitaires quand les gens vont
faire leurs courses sur les marchés ou
dans les grandes surfaces
par contre sur des événements en plein
air à partir de 50 personnes pour des
sports individuels je parle de randonnée
je parle de course à pied je parle de
triathlon je parle de course de vélo de
ce que vous voulez où les gens ne sont
pas forcément en contact les uns avec
les autres ça se fait depuis un an et
demi avec des protocoles tout à fait
satisfaisant et vous allez empêcher tout
l'été la tenue d'événements très
important pour nos associations et
l'animation de nos territoires mais
aussi la pratique sportive qui est
essentiel pour un certain nombre de
publics et toutes les générations
alors ce que je vous demande au travers
de cet amendement c'est de retirer les
pratiques sportives individuelles du
cadre du pass sanitaires et non
seulement ce sera une bonne mesure pour
l'animation de nos territoires comme je
les dis mais ce sera quoi qu'il arrive
un bienfait pour la protection de chacun
contre les effets indésirables de
nouveaux variants qu'il pourrait y avoir
et qui pourrait prospérer à l'avenir
merci merci suffisamment de membres je
tenir parole merci bien qu'on use
messieurs mini que je soutiens
entièrement sculptée dans mon calcul dit
filippo il concernant notre territoire
qui sont déjà très impactée depuis plus
de 15 mois l'économie économie
fragilisée malgré les aides financières
en perfusion
les professionnels du tourisme compte
sur le mois d'août pour sauver leur
entreprise
vous devez d entendre mettre de la
souplesse les gestes de barrières
doivent être maintenus bien sûr mais
vous ne pouvez pas rester aussi
inflexible sur le passé ni terrains
extérieurs et permettre en même temps
d'enlever des masques dans les espaces
fermés
merci donc l'ensemble des rendements
discussion commune ont été présentés
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de m'exprimer sur la
question de la circulation du virus sont
extérieurs et qui ne peut pas sûrement
pas être négligé
surtout dans le contexte avec le variant
de delta donc ce sera un avis
défavorable mais voudrait revenir sur
les exemples ont été donnés par les
autres monsieur molac sur le tennis ou
par monsieur gaussin sur les grands pas
certes c'est vrai il ya une
distanciation
mais ne pensez vous pas que même au
tennis il ya des endroits où on est un
peu plus ils ont nous concentrer que ce
soit les vestiaires que ce soit le club
house ou même où même dans les grands
parcs monsieur que ça je pense qu'il ya
des zones aussi une concentration que ce
soit d entrée que ce soit de sortie où
que ce soit certaines manifestations
voit même des restaurants
si bien
bien que vous vous n'auriez pas de
passes pour rentrer il faudrait un parc
pour aller se restaurer c'est à dire
vous empêchez auriez quasiment dans la
journée les gens de ne pas se restaurer
unis de bois avis défavorable merci
monsieur le ministre nous écoute dans le
ministre mais monsieur le président je
voudrais je les ferai ensuite mon
collègue olivier viron développer les
arguments sanitaires mais je tenais à
intervenir à deux titres
d'abord pour réagir un peu à ce que
disait tout à l'heure le président
damien abad vous nous reprochez en
quelque sorte de n'avoir pas anticipé et
vous nous dites il y avait des premiers
cas de variants delta au début de
l'année en europe que n'avez vous pas
pris des mesures à ce moment là deux
remarques
d'abord je remarque c'est un reproche
qui peut s'expliquer scientifiquement
que par ailleurs ces reproches qui est
extensible à l'ensemble des pays
européens mais peu importe
toutefois je trouve qu'il ya une forme
d'incohérence à nous dire
il faut absolument anticiper et à nous
priver dès maintenant alors même que
nous sommes dans un moment
d'accélération de l'épidémie
je le rappelle plus de 150% de
contamination en une semaine
x 7 dans les pyrénées orientales x 10 en
corse
des situations qui commencent déjà à
être explosive dans un certain nombre de
départements et notamment deux
départements outre-mer et donc il ya une
forme d'incohérence total à nous dire
vous noterez n'avait pas anticipé vous
auriez dû prendre des mesures plus plus
tôt et non seulement à nous dire mais du
coup en fait on vous demande de prendre
ces mesures
plus tard alors que vous devriez les
prendre aujourd'hui et on vous prive de
la capacité d'élargir le champ du pass
sanitaires alors même que vous nous même
moment où vous demandé d'anticiper donc
à une forme d'incohérence à nous dire
anticipé et ensuite on anticiper pas
deuxième élément deuxième élément pour
répondre notamment aux députés brindeau
et à son amendement d'appel
deuxième élément pour répondre au député
brindeau et à son amendement d'appel et
pour rentrer un peu dans les jeux vous
faire une confidence mesdames et
messieurs les députés il se trouve que
j'ai une partie de ma famille très
proche qui travaille dans la
restauration
donc j'ai une femme de stéréo quand le
gouvernement prend des mesures
restrictives si je pourrais m'exprimer
ainsi mais ce n'est pas vrai qu' on ne
peut pas vérifier dépasse sanitaires sur
une terrasse je suis désolé
effectivement c'est pénible
effectivement c'est pénible mais il
suffit de le faire quand vous prenez la
commande et oui ça prend du temps oui
c'est pénible
oui c'est contraignant oui ça ne fait
plaisir à personne mais ce n'est pas
vrai qu'on ne peut pas le faire et donc
personne mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la même manière dans un dans
un parc de loisirs ce n'est pas vrai
qu'on ne peut pas contrôler à l'entrée
dans la même manière quand vous faites
un événement qui est prévu ce n'est pas
vrai que vous pouvez pas contrôler les
personnes bien sûr que c'est pénible
bien sûr que ça fait plaisir à personne
mais faut arrêter de prendre les gens
pour des imbéciles bien sûr qu'on peut
le faire
et pour répondre au député brad oh bien
sûr que les forces de l'ordre
appliquerons la loi avec discernement
mais c'est leur faire insulte de de
penser qu'ils se comportent comme des
crétins bien sûr qu'ils vont regarder la
situation est donc on en revient
toujours au même problème on en revient
toujours au même débat bien sûr que ça
ne fait plaisir à personne y compris au
gouvernement d'imposer des mesures de
restriction pendant l'été bien sûr qu'on
préférerait laisser passer partir les
français en vacances tranquillement mais
le virus il est là et le virus il
n'attend pas
[Applaudissements]
alain mathieu ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
excusez moi je n'ai pas parlé très très
fort le c'est totalement légitime le
débat que vous avez et on peut se poser
la question de factuellement on peut
comprendre qu'on demande impasse annie
terre à l'intérieur d'un restaurant et
pourquoi est ce qu'on demande impasse
sanitaires pour s'asseoir en terrasse
pour voir un coup manger une glace
est-ce que franchement au-delà de la
question de savoir si c'est réaliste
cedrico vous a parfaitement répondu
est-ce que ça se justifie
c'est la question finalement vous posez
parce que si vous considérez que ça se
justifiait vous ne poseriez pas la
question de savoir si c'est compliqué à
faire respecter ou non vous diriez il
n'y a pas le choix il faut qu'on le
fasse
moi je vais vous expliquer pourquoi je
considère que c'est justifié de demander
un passé ni terre y compris en terrasse
d'abord je vous rappelle que nous
demandons un pass sanitaires pour entrer
dans une enceinte sportive
nous demandons un pass sanitaires pour
aller dans un festival de musique j'en
ai fait vous en avez peut être fait et
ça se passe très bien
nous demandons un pass sanitaire quand
vous rentrez dans un parc à thème où il
ya des dizaines des centaines ou des
milliers de personnes qui sont en
extérieur moi je veux vous dire une
chose je ne sais pas expliquer demain je
ne sais pas expliquer demain aux
organisateurs de festivals de
compétitions sportives extérieures ou
aux personnes qui tiennent des parcs de
loisirs par exemple pour ne citer qu'eux
pourquoi à eux on demande qui met en
place un pass sanitaire plus que c'est à
l'extérieur alors qu'on ne demande pas à
des restaurateurs et à des barres alors
que les gens sont sans masque à
l'extérieur vous êtes en train de créer
une distorsion dans le droit qui fait
que je pense même que juridiquement le
pass sanitaire en extérieur dans sa
globalité serait considérée comme trop
fragile et donc on pourrait perdre
l'outil pas salutaire pour tous les
événements extérieurs
je le redis un pour tous les événements
extérieurs deuxième
deuxième argument est ce qu'on peut se
contaminer dehors avec le co vite vous
savez qu habituellement on le disait
d'ailleurs il ya peu de contamination en
extérieur le variant delta mesdames et
messieurs les députés je comprends que
ça puisse vous désarçonné et je
reconnais volontiers que ça peut
désarçonner aussi le gouvernement
puisque ça désarçonne aussi l'ensemble
des pays dans le monde qui font face à
ce variant une étude qui est paru ce
matin dans la revue internationale
nature qui n'est pas considérée comme la
dernière des rêveries revue puisque
c'est la principale la première revue
scientifique au monde atteste d'une
contagiosité extrêmement accrue avec le
variant delta en toutes circonstances
avec une charge virale augmenté de 10
puissance 3 de 10 puissance 3
c'est à dire que lorsque vous êtes
contaminé vous pardon pour l'expression
vous crachez du virus à tout va et bien
eu des pays qui ont mis en place des
systèmes de contact racing qui ont
attesté qu'il y avait même des
contaminations personnes qui étaient
assis en terrasse du simple fait que des
gens étaient passés à côté à des
ou c'est par exemple et des gens se sont
retrouvés contaminés l'extérieur donc la
question est ce qu'on peut se contaminer
en terrasse d'un restaurant ou d'un café
la réponse est oui et oui ce qui veut
dire ce qui veut dire que on reste dans
la même logique du pass sanitaires c'est
pas le ministre mes chers collègues les
ministres ce qui veut dire qu'on est
dans une logique qui n'est pas le
passage du ter ou rien mais qui est dans
une logique du pass sanitaire ou de la
fermeture
c'est à dire que si nous n'avons pas
d'outils juridiques conférés par la loi
que vous ne donnez pas la possibilité de
mettre en place le pass à lithaire en
extérieur si nous constatons qu
effectivement tout ce qu'on pense tout
ce qu'on voit à l'étranger tout ce que
nous disent les scientifiques est vrai à
savoir qu'on se contamine aussi en
terrasse alors nous n'aurons pas d'autre
possibilité que de fermer à nouveau les
terrasses et ce n'est pas ce que vous
voulez et ce n'est pas ce que nous
voulons
ensuite quand vous allez boire une bière
un café où vous allez manger des glaces
en terrasse il peut arriver quelque
chose d'assez humains en fait c'est que
vous avez peut-être besoin d'aller aux
toilettes par exemple vous avez
peut-être besoin d'aller régler à
l'intérieur vous avez peut-être besoin
d'aller d'aller d'aller vous laver les
mains donc les gens qui sont alex les
gens qui sont à l'extérieur sont amenés
à rentrer à l'intérieur et excusez moi
on est on est vous et moi en contact
dans nos quartiers dans l'endroit où on
travaille on évolue avec des bars et ses
pendants souhaite qu'ils répondent
d'abord question il répond on est
content mais vous savez très bien
comment ça se passe dans la vraie vie
quand vous avez un bar extérieur ouvert
vous avez des gens qui sont nombreux
parfois dort parfois plusieurs dizaines
parfois même plus de sens qui sont
dehors qui boivent un coude de boue à 6
et qui vont rentrer qui vont sortir du
bar et vous pouvez pas demander un
restaurateur de vérifier qu'une personne
qui n'aurait pas de passes alité à
l'extérieur au moment où il va rentrer
dans le bar ben ils vous n'allez pas
c'est pas là que vous avez empêché de
rentrer donc en fait vous vous
complexifier le quotidien des
restaurateurs et vous mettez en péril
leur commerce
je vous le dis vous mettez en péril leur
activité d'ailleurs ce n'est pas ce
qu'ils demandent ce qu'ils demandaient
les restaurateurs et là où il y avait
beaucoup de pression et vous l'avez tous
ressenti là où il y avait beaucoup de
pression c'est que les restaurateurs
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux ne
voulaient pas ils étaient prêts à
contrôler le pass mais il ne voulait pas
contrôler l'identité de leurs clients
l'annoncé par le premier ministre hier
au 13h qu'il n'y aurait pas de contrôle
de l'identité des clients dans les cafés
les restaurants par les restaurateurs et
a fait baisser la pression
pour moi le sujet désormais est derrière
nous la question n'était pas le pass en
terrasse c'était qui contrôlent
l'identité et enfin dernier point jean
n'arrêterez là il ya des bars et des
restaurants qui ont des terrasses et on
a d'autres qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'en
n'ont pas ça veut dire qu'on va mettre
en place un système où vous aurez des
bars et des restaurants qui devront et
c'est pas très égalitaire et ce n'est
pas très égalitaire qui devront contre
les passe à lithaire et d'autre
[Musique]
collègues j'aimerais vous soyez aussi
énervé quand vous voyez le virus monté
que quand on essaye de le freiner
mesdames et messieurs les députés
j'aimerais le même engagement pour nous
aider à prendre des mesures pour
protéger les français les mêmes
vociférations paix celle que vous faites
aujourd'hui je constate que la seule
chose qui vous énerve c'est quand on
essaie de freiner le virus
donc ce ne serait pas du tout égalité
entre les bars et les restaurants donc
je le redis ce n'est pas une demande des
restaurateurs ce n'est pas une mesure
qui serait conforme avec la lutte contre
le virus ça met en péril l'activité même
des commerces se dépassent à eau rien
c'est ça ou la fermeture c'est ce que je
crains réellement et c'est à dire cours
de la vraie vie tels que fonctionnent
les terrasses de bars et de restaurants
merci merci alors nous avons donc élargi
le débat et nous commencions par
monsieur molac oui merci monsieur le
président donc on doit pas avoir les
mêmes informations avec le ministre
parce que moi j'ai bien vu le communiqué
de l'ump qui dit que effectivement en
extérieur il voudrait qu'il n'y ait pas
de passes sanitaire alors il y a quand
même un certain nombre d'incohérences
parce que je me promène sur la place du
village chez chez nous là bon ben voilà
il n'y a pas besoin de passes sanitaire
mais si je sors la plancha palais et
camp des cats en train de jouer au
palais activités sportives donc à zut
alors il faut un pass sanitaire même
chose on est avec trois ou quatre
copains tiens on habite juste à côté du
terrain de foot on prend le ballon on va
sur le terrain de foot de la commune et
claque passe sanitaires aussi activités
de loisirs merci donc il ya plein de
choses qui sont quand même largement
incohérente et puis je pourrais parler
des marchés alors les marchés
effectivement c'est autorisé on peut y
aller il n'y a pas besoin de passes
sanitaires mais si on fait une foire
comme on en a beaucoup chez nous à l'ats
par contre il va falloir le pass
sanitaires donc tout ça est assez
incohérent et donc c'est pour ça qu
évidemment notre groupe soutiendra cet
amendement est le vôtre a juste une
petite chose puisque j'ai été mis en
cause tout à l'heure j'ai pas pu faire
un rappel au règlement mais j'aurais pu
pour faire personnel que dit exactement
le monde le monde dit qu'il n'y a pas de
recoupements automatique entre les
fichiers destinés à lister les personnes
ciné contaminés et qui ont succombé aux
coups 8 19 donc comment peut-on dire que
96% des primo infectées sont des gens
qui ne sont pas vaccinés
c'est pas possible tout simplement on
n'a pas la possibilité de le faire donc
c'est ce que dit le monde
et si jamais vous ne me croyez pas allez
voir les décodeurs et vous le verrez
vous même s'il a permis de mettre les
aubert mjv neige devraient pas oui merci
monsieur le président non je crois que
vous avez un problème de méthode
d'abord parce que comme ça a été dit
tout à l'heure vous n'avez pas répondu
je sais pas à quoi sert le parlement on
discute de règles qui on doit de toute
façon été édictée par décret ce qui est
quand même un petit peu humiliant pour
nous deuxièmement je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur le pass sanitaire
parce que vous dites vous invoquez des
sujets sanitaires monsieur le ministre
dans ce cas là il fallait nous faire
débat de la vaccination obligatoire si
vous sortez vos chiffres avec 10
puissance 3 là on discute d'un pas
sanitaires et non ce n'est pas aux
individus de contrôler leurs voisins et
de faire le travail de l'état
non monsieur le ministre ça se rapproche
beaucoup plus du crédit social la
chinoise en tout cas que de ma
conception de ce qu'est la démocratie
deuxièmement venons quand même à vos
questions sur l'extérieur est-ce que
c'est applicable et proportionnée en
extérieur je vais sur la plage je joue
avec mes raquettes
un troisième individu se présente je dit
excusez moi monsieur pour jouer avec moi
il faut avoir le pass sanitaire non mais
un moment donné il va falloir atterrir
si vous voulez un peu de bon sens
comment vous voulez organiser une
compétition de pétanque en extérieur
avec n'importe qui peut se joindre à
vous et quand j'entends pompon sur la
cerise que au tennis on peut se frôler
mais est ce qu'à un moment donné on peut
faire confiance à nos concitoyens et
penser qu'ils sont les premiers
responsables de leur santé et qu'ils
pourraient lorsqu'il joue au tennis
faire attention
effectivement d'une pas sandra c est ce
qu un moment donné l'état de ted
responsable de tout dans ce pays
enfin troisièmement je trouve absolument
absurde alors là on confine à l'absurde
vous nous expliquer que c'est très
efficace mais vous n'avez même pas
vérifié l'identité c'est ce cas je
dirais dit le premier ministre hier donc
à quoi sert votre contrôle les gens
défend des faux-pas sanitaires et dont
vous ne serez pas gagnant sur le plan de
l'épidémie voilà comment à la fin on
arrive avec une règle générale inamicale
qu'on n'applique pas la seule victime de
cette crise ce sera l'autorité de l'état
encore et toujours vous vous serez assis
sur les principes et en plus de noro
qu'un résultat en matière épidémique
c'est ça qu'on a en face de nous et je
passe enfin sur l'activité touristique
est en plein pic et qui va souffrir
dangereusement
ce sont les activités qui vont fermer
faute d'applicabilité biologie mais la
parole bon en fait le niveau
d'acceptabilité de principe de règles
dépend généralement de notre capacité à
les comprendre
et puis la cohérence des règles édictées
et le débat que nous avons permet de
montrer les incohérences les absurdités
les inégalités mise en oeuvre à travers
vos mesures un peu techno je veux
prendre un exemple qui m'est cher y en a
qui préfèrent le golfe
moi c'est les fêtes foraines les fêtes
foraines qui font partie de la culture
populaire elles sont inscrites au
patrimoine immatériel de l'unesco
fête foraine ya pas une entrée et une
sortie des fêtes foraines celle qui va
avoir lieu à dieppe au mois d'août sur
11 hectares de pelouses en front de mer
c'est voilà des manèges
on peut rentrer par tous les bouts ça
permet à ceux qui ne sont pas partis en
vacances d'avoir du rêve
comment appliquer le pass sanitaires
pour les fêtes foraines
deuxième élément deuxième incohérences
la croisette
la grue la rue du gros horloge à rouen
le front de mer du touquet vous pouvez
avoir sur ces espaces
des milliers de personnes qui se frotte
un peu plus qu'au tennis tu seras porter
vous n'avez pas dû jouer depuis
longtemps parce que si vous arrivez
embrasser votre partenaire de tennis en
même temps que vous jouez soit le
terrain est tout petit soit vous n'êtes
pas venu jouer au tennis donc sur ces
esplanade sur ces croisette sur ces
grandes rues il y a une densité de
population sans commune mesure avec ce
qu'on peut retrouver dans des activités
sportives ou de loisirs en petit comité
ses incohérences
ces incompréhensions c'est vision
technocratique nous font refuser la
manière dont vous appréhender le sujet
nous font militer pour les amendements
qui visent à exclure au moins pour la
période estivale ou moins pour offrir
cette bouffée d'oxygène tant attendu les
activités de plein air précités merci
monsieur benoit à la parole merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur depuis
le début de la semaine comme un bon
nombre de députés je suis les débats en
commission et naturellement ici dans
l'hémicycle et à ce stade je voulais
dire que je suis circonspect par rapport
à la compréhension par nous mêmes ici
quelle que soit d'ailleurs les bancs sur
lesquels on siège et la perception par
nos concitoyens de ce projet de loi qui
à ce stade je dis bien à ce stade et
marquer quand même du sceau de la
précipitation parce que ce qui me pose
problème je vais vous dire c'est d'un
côté une mise une montée en puissance de
la vaccination et du parcours vaccinale
que l'on comprend très bien
au départ il y avait peu de vaccins il y
en a plus et les français se vaccine est
un des graves problèmes que nous
ressentons aujourd'hui qu'une partie des
français ressentent
c'est l'inadéquation de la mise en
oeuvre du pass sanitaire que l'on veut
nous faire accepter je dirais à marche
forcée et si au groupe udi avec pascal
brindeau et un certain nombre de députés
nous avons déposé des amendements on va
dire d'adaptabilité notamment pour la
vie extérieure c'est pour une montée en
puissance en adéquation du pass
sanitaire proportionnelle à la montée en
puissance de la vaccination
parce que sinon ce que possèdent ces
amendements finalement c'est la question
de la temporalité
de l'application des mesures annoncées
par le président de la république le 12
juillet ce qui nous pose problème
personnellement ce qui me pose problème
c'est qu'on annonce le 12 juillet des
mesures qui s'appliquent dès maintenant
et dont on voit très bien qu'il ya un
problème d'application problèmes
d'application des mesures et problème de
progressivité de montée en puissance des
règles sur le terrain parce que je me
vois revenir dans mon territoire et une
bonne partie de ce qui risque d'être
voté par le parlement sera inapplicable
les jours prochains sur le t1 voilà ce
qui pose problème à ce stade si monsieur
rebeyrotte à la parole
premiers éléments ce qui nous gâchent
notre été la formule était sur les bancs
dlr c'est le variant delta et son hyper
vie ras l'itc ça notre grand problème
tout sur tous les bancs nous espérions
pouvoir passer un été un peu apaisées
seulement voilà ça n'est pas le cas et
nous sommes obligés de faire face à
cette situation
bien sûr le pass sanitaire va compliquer
la vie
mais il a pour première conséquence que
depuis les annonces du président de la
république 6,6 millions de nos de nos
concitoyens ont repris le chemin de la
vaccination et nous serons à plus de 10%
en équivalent de la population ce soir
plus de 7 millions ça c'est quand même
la bonne nouvelle sur les extérieurs
d'abord il ya de la contamination
extérieure vous le savez tous surtout
quand les personnes sont très proches et
sont sans masque
et puis par ailleurs évidemment il n'y a
pas de réelle étanchéité entre extérieur
et intérieur beaucoup d'activité
conjuguée à un moment donné les deux
nous le savons très bien et puis il ya
même des lieux qui sont semi ouverts
semi fermée on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas échapper un pass sanitaire qui
concerne l'ensemble de ses activités
et c'est pour ça que nous voterons
contre ces amendements
mais si je laisse la parole à man
bonnaire et monsieur 1000 yens se
prépare madame bonnaire à la parole
merci monsieur le merci monsieur le
président alors depuis tout à l'heure on
entend beaucoup de choses autour d'une
forme d'incohérence et il me semble en
effet que cette incohérence
malheureusement ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui mais date depuis le début
de la gestion de cette crise sanitaire
par le gouvernement vous corrélés le
fouet le souhait de la protection de la
population et de corréler l'obligation
d'un pass sanitaire du fait de la
contagion par le variant delta
aujourd'hui nous savons tous est
regardée l'étranger puisque vous avez
nommés les pays à l'international depuis
tout à l'heure nous avons un recul et
nous savons aujourd'hui que les vaccins
quel qu'il soit ne protège pas ne sont
pas efficaces par rapport à ce variant
delta 107 un premier constat
deuxièmement deuxièmement nous savons
également nous savons également que les
personnes vaccinées permettent autant la
contagiosité que les personnes non
vaccinées
ça vient d'âtre si j'ai découvert la
moder ça vient d'être reconfirmer hier
par l'ordre des médecins en italie donc
j'aimerais qu'on explique une fois pour
toutes
à quoi va servir ce pass sanitaires si
ce n'est à empêcher les français si ce
n'est à enfermer les français mais
aucunement ni à être bienveillant par
rapport à leur santé vous faites depuis
le début de la gestion de cette crise
absolument n'importe quoi s'il avait été
question de soigner cette épidémie ça
fait depuis longtemps que nous en
aurions signé avec le virus je vous
remercie monsieur le président à tarnos
merci la parole est un monsieur 1000
yens
nous écoutons monsieur milliards si
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
rapporteur
madame la présidente de la commission
messieurs les ministres je viens
d'apprendre un truc terrible
tenez vous bien pour circuler avec ma
voiture j'ai besoin d'un permis de
conduire avec une photo dessus je dois
être en mesure de le présenter
c'est attentatoire à mes libertés c'est
totalement attentatoire à la liberté
donc mesdames et messieurs les députés
je veux bien depuis qu'on se réunit sur
cette crise sanitaire
vous avez sur les bancs des oppositions
je ne dis pas qu'on a raison tout le
temps mais sur le banc des eaux sur les
bancs des oppositions vous nous
expliquer toujours ce qu'on aurait dû
faire mais a posteriori jamais a priori
vous n'avez pas lu à gérer cette crise
on a peut-être fait des erreurs mais
personne sur les bancs des oppositions
n'aurait aimé être à la place du
ministre de la santé nih du gouvernement
notre leur principale préoccupation
c'est d'éviter de nouveaux mâts de
préserver la santé des français moi ça
m'amuse pas le pass annie terre monsieur
milices ça n'amuse personne mais il est
totalement réalisable de contrôler
effectivement se passe sanitaires et
puisque monsieur auberge nous a entendu
tout à l'heure vous appeler à la
responsabilité des français
vous ne pouvez pas dans la même phrase
appelé à la responsabilité des français
est présupposé que la plupart d'entre
eux auront ne faut pas sanitaires ça ne
tient pas debout
ça ne tient pas debout enfin monsieur
molac puisque vous aimez le monde
lisez donc un article sur les sur les
parcs sur les parcs astérix éclosion mer
de sable
égouttez les collègues qu'un en égout de
monsieur mathieu may est le sien milliet
non mais écoutez le go pro du pas
salutaire se fait très bien donc arrêter
de raconter des bêtises aux français ça
ne prend pas
mes chers collègues
on a écouté ma même bonnaire dans le
calme on peut écouter monsieur 1000 yens
dans le calme comme un monsieur le
président best
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres hommes nous
sommes tout à fait prêts à croire que
nous sommes dans une situation grave et
nous le voyons nous voyons effectivement
le variant delta nous voyons les
chiffres qui augmente qui doublent plus
que chaque semaine et donc il faut
prendre des mesures
oui nous en sommes convaincus et nous
sommes presque convaincu que pour se
protéger encore davantage
il faut effectivement se passe sanitaire
en extérieur avec bien entendu le retour
des gestes barrières c'est à dire les
basques ce que nous avons du mal à
comprendre c'est que hier on nous
expliquait que pour les personnes ayant
le pass sanitaires notamment nous
pouvions enlever le masque en intérieur
et là on a quelques soucis si vous
voulez de logique
c'est à dire que soient tournées dans
une dynamique de l'épidémie qui
nécessite de prendre toutes les
protections nécessaires
et quand on nous dit que les personnes
vaccinées peuvent également être
contaminés et être contagieuse même si
elles le sont beaucoup moins que les
personnes non vaccinées alors si on a
vraiment à coeur de freiner l'épidémie
est d'éviter au maximum toute politique
de reconfirme ans de couvre feu alors il
faut avoir des gestes barrières à la
fois en intérieur et en externe et
filippo on est en écoute monsieur
malendure monsieur le ministre vous
entendre sur cette question
pour savoir aujourd'hui quelles sont les
meilleures politiques à mettre en oeuvre
pour on est prévenu mais des politiques
qui sont logique et compréhensible
nous pensons sincèrement au niveau du
groupe agir ensemble que ce qui est
clair logique est alors compréhensible
et accepté par la population merci merci
madame harel à hadji à la parole et
monsieur bernard istis se prépare ça
devrait être le dernier orateur
merci beaucoup monsieur le président mon
jeu je rentrerai pas dans le débat qui
consisterait amener des gens à
s'embrasser sur un court de tennis ou
cher monsieur pour reprendre votre
exemple du permis de conduire oui
évidemment que il vous faut un permis de
conduire que vous pouvez faire contrôler
demain je suis agent de sécurité sur un
parking
je ne suis absolument pas fondées à vous
interdire l'accès au parking sous
prétexte que vous ne souhaitez pas me
présenter votre permis de conduire et
vérifiez votre identité
c'est le rôle des agents de police dont
votre exemple porte en lui-même la
contradiction qui est l'esprit qui régit
cette disposition
donc s'il vous plaît ne nous prenez pas
pour des idiots aujourd'hui vous nous
amenez à légiférer dans l'urgence j'y
reviendrai pas sur un pass sanitaire
dans le cadre d'une épidémie dans le
cadre d'une quatrième vague liés aux
variants delta on né le 20 juillet moi
ma question monsieur le ministre c'est
que mon collègue maurice ballot vous
interroger au début du mois de juin sur
le variant delta à ce moment là vous
avez balayé d'un revers de la main
circulez ya rien à voir
pourquoi ne pas avoir anticipé nous n'en
serions pas là
j'en profite du coup pour vous parler de
deux nouveaux variants californien
l'epsilon et le lambda
qu'est ce qui va se passer est ce que
vous allez revenir le voir en octobre en
nous disant finalement y est cinquième
vague lit un nouveau variant est oh là
là on n'a pas vu
on attendait excusez moi je crois que
c'est votre responsabilité d'être en
capacité d'anticiper et de proposer des
solutions sur la question du pas
salutaire la question c'est celle de sa
lisibilité de son application
on voit bien on voit bien dans des bacs
on est en train d'avoir c'est totalement
kafkaïen je ne pense pas que ce soit
notre rôle dans rendre de rentrer dans
le sou détails de la mise en oeuvre très
concrète à l'échelle du territoire
il me semble que notre rôle aurait été
de définir une règle qui n'affronte y
lisent pas les français
je pense que nous sommes toutes et tous
dans cet hémicycle parents enfants
frères soeurs cousins cousines
bref que nous avons autour de nous des
proches que nous ne souhaitons pas voir
contaminé avec ce variant avec ce ce ce
virus donc à partir de là je pense que
nous pouvons aussi dicté des règles
qu'ils fassent confiance aux uns et aux
autres et qui responsabilise des
français plutôt que début on a laissé la
parole et le ministre répondait merci
monsieur le président je vais poser des
questions extrêmement simple et précise
on nous dit tout à l'heure monsieur miss
nous dit la contagiosité du var un delta
et 10 puissance 3 supérieur à aux autres
ok lui je vous crois sur parole ce qui
est assez rare quand même mais on va
faire comme si d'accord on est en
terrasse on n'a pas de masque quelqu'un
passe dans la rue vous nous avez dit
quelqu'un passe dans la rue du coup sans
masque on est contaminé
je crois que je je je croise plus de
gens dans la rue khobar quand qu'on
puisse en penser
je croise plus de gens dans la rue
khobar
donc la première mesure d'urgence qui
serait à prendre face à la contagiosité
du var delta c'est pas le pass qualité
c'est de dire remettons le masque quand
on se balade dans la rue et ça vous le
faites pas pire on n'a pas un élément
moi je suis je ne suis pas pour dire que
le vaccin ne protège pas contre le
variant delta mais j'ai lu l'étude de
l'institut pasteur qui dit que le vaccin
protège moins contre le varlin delta qui
compte le alpha et je sais plus quelle
autre et dans l'étude de l'institut
pasteur
ma question est simple combien de
combien de pourcentage de protection at
on quand on est vacciné face aux
variants delta est ce que c'est 100 %
je ne le crois pas et si ce n'est pas
100% alors à ce moment là tout est
devenu en absurdie totale puisque pas
sanitaires vous rentrez dans un lieu
clos vous pourrez enlever votre masque
et en plus vous n'êtes pas contacter
paca contact donc effectivement à la fin
si nous ne sommes pas aussi bien
protégés contre le variant delta que
contre les autres variantes avec le
vaccin c'est tout vos stratégies qui
s'effondre et à la fin on aura
effectivement le pass sanitaires à la
fois leur confinement et le couvre feu
etc
on a besoin de savoir pour avoir prendre
des décisions éclairées
sont annoncés soit on ne sait pas mais
vous pouvez pas être comme ça dans des
mesures générales d'application générale
et moi voir demain c'est qu'on s'est
tous les français monsieur le ministre à
la parole bien
quelques éléments de réponse rapidement
d'abord quel est le principe le principe
de la loi madame la députée a la rage le
principe de la loi c'est que vous nous
donniez la possibilité d'utiliser des
moyens de lutter contre l'épidémie si la
situation le justifiait nous on s'engage
à utiliser les mesures appropriées au
bon moment le temps nécessaire juste le
temps nécessaire et après les supprimer
c'est pas un débat nouveau j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre à un député la
fondation midi hier qu on a eu ce débat
il ya quelques mois sur le logiciel
cidep quand j'avais demandé aux
parlementaires à l'assemblée et au sénat
de nous laisser conserver les données
des patients testés dans cidep au delà
de trois mois avant d'écraser les
données la réponse a été non suite au
débat avec les oppositions à l'assemblée
le sénat et la commission mixte
paritaire nous avons perdu la
possibilité de conserver les données si
d'impôt de la trois mois je l'avais dit
on les utilisera le temps de la pandémie
après on les écrasera on les gardera pas
non c'est juste trois mois vous n'avez
pas de raison de garder plus longtemps
et aujourd'hui vous nous dites il ya
plein de français qui ont eu copie il ya
six mois il ya neuf mois et qui peuvent
pas voir leur castany terre qu'est ce
que vous avez fait au gouvernement
pourquoi vous n'avez pas conserver les
données et ben oui on les a écrasés en
fait on a suivi la loi la loi c'est vous
qui la fait donc ce que je vous dis
aujourd'hui c'est que dans les taxes
dans l'état actuel des connaissances
mais oui mais j'ai déjà dit mme enfin la
répétition parfois ça permet d'ancrer
les choses le député et j'aimerais bien
qu'on puisse tous apprendre j'essaye
d'apprendre
j'essaye d'apprendre des erreurs nous
ont pu commettre je pense je pense je
pense monsieur le député que vous pouvez
vous appliquez la même laissez-nous la
possibilité jc le pass annie terre au
delà des situations fermé si la
situation est nécessaire nous le ferons
si la situation ne devient plus
nécessaire ou si on se rend compte avec
les données de la science que ça ne se
justifie pas nous le supprimant juste le
temps nécessaire
la différence c'est que si vous ne
permettez pas de le faire dans la loi
quoi qu'il arrive nous ne pourrons pas y
recourir
si vous nous permettait de faire dans la
loi si besoin d'où pourront y recourir
c'est exactement la raison pour laquelle
nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est que nous avons fait le
choix là où nous pouvions passer par
arrêté avant la loi d'état d'urgence
nous avons fait le choix démocratique de
confier les pouvoirs que nous avions
auparavant en crise sanitaire au
parlement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle c'est le dixième texte
je viens défendre devant la
représentation nationale puisque nous
faisons évoluer les outils à mesure que
les connaissances évoluent et clé est
que la situation sanitaire l'exigé
ensuite monsieur le président baisse
vous poser une question qui est légitime
très légitime et même cohérente qui
consiste à dire si je la résume vous
nous demandez vous nous demandez de
juste d'imposer le pass alité en
terrasse alors que vous nous dites qu'on
ait pu porter les masques à l'intérieur
quand il pas de sanitaires je vous dire
une chose le principe je le redis c'est
le haut conseil de santé publique c'est
pas le gouvernement
le haut conseil de santé publique nous
dit une chose il nous dit par définition
tue toutes les personnes qui se
retrouvent à l'intérieur sont vaccinés
ou négatifs pour le virus
il ya le risque résiduel de contagion
est très faible et donc il n'est pas
nécessaire de porter le masque et dans
le décret que nous avons pris qui
reprend cet arrêté du haut conseil de
santé publique
nous précisons la pression est
importante que les préfets pourront
déterminer localement
si le masque reste nécessaire dans les
lieux fermés
appliquant le pass alité en fonction de
la situation épidémique et je me suis
exprimé hier pour vous dire monsieur le
président que très sensible très
sensible à ces arguments et on peut pas
dire que je sois en général moins 10 ans
dans la gestion de crise
je suis plutôt fait c'est plutôt d'avoir
le maximum de mesures de protection
je vous ai dit que nous travaillons avec
les préfets qui aurait décision
imminente qui sera prise concernant le
barde le port du masque dans les milieux
fermés qui appliquent le passé ni terre
considérant un la dynamique épidémique
très forte et structures tout le
territoire national et 2 les nouveaux
paramètres de contagiosité du variant
delta donc nous verrons vraiment cela et
je ne peux pas vous faire une réponse
aujourd'hui je peux pas avant d'aller
contre l'avis du hft
nous devons évidemment avoir cette
consultation mais je suis très sensible
à ce que vous avez ce que vous avez
souligné
enfin pour répondre et j'arrêterai là
pour répondre au député bernalicis et
puis répondre quand même je pars
remettre une pièce dans la machine mais
dire madame bonheur que quand elle dit
des inexactitudes on peut pas vous juger
pour ce que vous dites dans l'hémicycle
mais je crois que c'est l'histoire qui
s'en chargera madame la députée
vous avez laissé bernalicis poser une
question vous avez vous avez suggéré
l'idée selon laquelle le vaccin serait
pas efficace supérieur delta je vais
vous donner je vais vous donner est
selon nous un coup devant john broehner
c'est votre choix
coquerel on écoute la ministre monsieur
le député birmanie si ce monsieur merci
vous avez vous avez posé la question de
la la fois vous avez émis l'idée que le
vaccin serait efficace quels sont les
chiffres en vie réelle on n'est pas dans
des lettres études de laboratoire on est
en vie réelle avec une double dose de
vaccin arn messager vous étiez à 83 4 %
de réduction des contaminations pour les
formes symptomatiques avec le avec le
variant anglais ont été de 4 83% de
réduction avec le variant delta la même
double dose du même vaccin vous
confèrent une protection
à près de 80 % 7 88% pardon c'est à dire
4 % de moins 88% contre les formes
symptomatiques
donc si la question est de savoir est ce
que le vaccin est efficace pour tenir
delta la réponse elle est oui oui oui
si tous les vaccins dont nous disposions
pour lutter contre les maladies
contagieuses comme la rougeole la
diphtérie la poliomyélite ou la grille
pour ne citer
le 210,9 est identique qui est pour
contre rejeté le 9 183 pour contre
rejeté le
87 pour contre rejeté le 30 sept
pour contre jeter le 662 identiques qui
est pour pour contre rejeté et
maintenant nous abordons un vote
électronique
c'est le centre de nasri danticat donc
chacun gagné sa place
le scrutin est ouvert ce scrutin est
clos voici les résultats votants 240 x
1229 majorité 5 15% 2 contre 127
maintenant n'est pas adoptée nous
maintenant nous allons voter sur les 568
de 568 star vote électronique également
chacun put regagner sa place
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votants 234 exprimé
223 majorité 112 pour 95 contre 128
rejetée nous abordons maintenant le vote
499 là aussi vote électronique même avis
la commission et du gouvernement
le scrutin est ouvert scrutin est clos
[Musique]
voici les résultats votants 230 exprimé
222 majorité 112 tours 94 contre 128
rejeté à nous retrouvons des mentale
vote à main levée le 38 qui est pour
contre rejeté 709 n'a pas été défendu le
366 kg et pour contre rejeté alors il y
avait un amendement soumis afin
d'obliger nerfs sous-amendement je vais
d'abord on voit le sous-amendement 1186
le même avis défavorable plus
ouvertement qui est pour quand
je t'ai je vais jouer l'amendement 908
qui est pour contre jeter le 41 qui est
pour quand vous jetez et nous abordons
le même caillou le 777ème carew et
sénateurs
mister mystère est celui-là aussi
monsieur le président madame fuster est
là sur le 400 il y aura un identique
avec madame carew vous êtes membres et
donc voit pas tout le monde spontanément
merci ma mercer merci monsieur le
président je voudrais d'abord m'adresser
à monsieur le ministre si vous le
permettez je suis comme tous mes
collègues depuis hier à écouter un débat
qui ne peut que nous interpeller
et avant de défendre mon amendement je
voudrais quand même entendre le
gouvernement sur le fait que comment
vous ne vous étonnez pas que toutes les
oppositions
je dis bien toutes les oppositions sont
en train de vous démontrer les
incohérences et les absurdités d'un
texte ça n'est pas la première fois que
nous arrivons à nous retrouver pour vous
montrer et ça ça ne vous interpelle
jamais et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
quand même pour le moins surprenant
c'est que vous rejetez systématiquement
toute proposition qui n'a que pour
objectif que mettre du bon sens dans un
texte bourré d'incohérences et
d'absurdités et parmi d'ailleurs ce
souhait de meilleure visibilité
d'ailleurs je me serais intéressé de
savoir parmi mes collègues ceux qui sont
capables de me dire en trois phrases
exactement ce qui va ressortir de ce
texte parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on
découvre quelque chose on voit derrière
et le monsieur le rapporteur tout à
l'heure sur le tennis c'était quand même
un moment qui restera dans les mémoires
quant à notre collègue qui nous qu'on
parle pas sanitaire a permis de conduire
vos arguments sont d'une telle ineptie
que comment voulez vous que les français
à un moment vous prennent au sérieux
est-ce que vous n'entendez pas la colère
la colère qui à l'automne vasseur
d'anticipation car oui monsieur le
ministre vous avez manqué d'anticipation
quand nous vous avons pointé du doigt le
non contrôle aux frontières
le non contrôle de politique d'isolement
quand les premiers cas du delta
variantes sont arrivés du variant delta
sont arrivés quelle politique
d'isolement avez vous mis en place elle
était inexistante
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés
à vos incohérences et l'amande manque de
précisions par rapport au fait que vous
avez péché des possibilités d'exercer
dans les activités de loisirs le monde
de la culture voudrait avoir ici des
précisions sur l'objet de cette amende
sur mer cariou pour un amendement
identique 70 17
effectivement il s'agit de préciser le
mot culture dans cet alinéa qui concerne
les activités de loisirs pourquoi parce
que vous le savez vous avez émis un
décret sur la base d'une loi qui va
frapper dès aujourd'hui les activités
culturelles dans les lieux à partir de
50 personnes alors que le décret alors
que la loi ne précise et en aucun cas
que ses activités de culture en dessous
de 1000 personnes ailleurs de deux
devaient être devrait être réglementée /
/ impasse sanitaire donc pour ne pas
réitérer ce type d'imprécisions nous
demandons ici qu il soit clairement
mentionné la distinction entre les
activités de loisirs les activités de
culture qu'on clarifie la loi puisque
visiblement aujourd'hui la loi notamment
la loi du 31 mai elle n'est pas
suffisamment clair et là nous souhaitons
éviter que encore une fois on se
retrouve dans une imprécision tels que
les acteurs économiques ne sache pas
s'ils sont concernés ou pas par la loi
merci monsieur le docteur un film
monsieur le président je pense que le
conseil de constitutionnel l'a bien
précisé le
thème de lui dit qu'il n'y avait rien
d'après sinon ce terme de lieux de
loisirs et donc ce sera un avis
défavorable
monsieur milanesi pour les mêmes même
avis on revient aux deux orateurs
uniquement monsieur diarra la parole
puis monsieur la salle oui merci
je crains
monsieur le ministre que que la culture
paie un lourd tribut sur cette décision
par décret un lourd tribut je pense que
beaucoup de manifestations suite à cette
décision va être vont être annulées pour
la culture pour les activités de plaies
nous avons simplement comme pour les
activités de culture qu'est ce que nous
vous demandons un peu de bon sens un peu
de souplesse
depuis une semaine ça sera pas une
première
je vous rappelle qu'au départ le
président république avait demandé qu'à
même le pass annie terre pour les jeunes
au 1er août puis on a vu quand même la
vaccination était quand même au 15 juin
ouverte aux jeunes et que ce n'était pas
possible
je vous rappelle aussi qu'il était
souhaité également que les personnes qui
ne contrôle pas les pats sanitaire soit
puni d'un an de prison et de 45000 euros
d'amendé
nous avons dit c'est disproportionné
alors là vous n'avez pas suivi mais vous
avez suivi le conseil d'état vous êtes
aussi revenu vous revenu où j'espère que
vous allez revenir sur le licenciement
sec des soignants là aussi nous y sommes
complètement opposées que c'est une
ineptie
et d'ailleurs nous voyons madame
elisabeth bonne revenir un petit peu en
arrière de même monsieur le ministre je
vous avais dit qu'il n'était pas
possible de faire un contrôle d identité
pour les tenanciers de bars et de
restaurants je voulais dire en
commission des lois mardi
vous m'avez pas répondu j'ai bien
compris pourquoi on n'avait pas répondu
parce que la réponse elle a été de
monsieur castex hier à 13 heures de dire
oui on les tenanciers de bars de
restaurants etc ne contrôleront pas
l'identité
ce qui est logique puisque un policier
municipal ne peut pas contrôler
l'identité nous vous l'avons demandé à
travers la loi sécurité publique et vous
l'avez refusé donc c'était complètement
illogique
voilà un petit peu notre scepticisme
nous sommes un peu pop perdues dont vos
contradictions permanentes
merci monsieur la seule à la parole
un merci infirme ce président d'abord je
me permets de vous remercier d'avoir
ramené peux te calmes dans cet hémicycle
certes de l'italie qui étaient là hier
soir n'avait pas la tâche facile
les dépressions m impossible mais vous
avez ramené le calme et je vous en
remercie
je voudrais aussi dire que ce match
allait avancer des chemises bleues de
méthode et on sent bien que tous les
collègues voulaient en finir ce qui est
à la fois une bonne chose et une
mauvaise je vous remercie d'avoir aussi
redonner la parole à martine bonheur les
remerciements sont pas décomptés des
deux minutes quand même hein
simplement par plaisir les deux minutes
vous savez j'ai pas entendu beaucoup de
remerciements jusqu'à maintenant mais si
vous êtes d'accord et se câliner et il
vous arrive et dit compter quand même
avoir la 9e et alors je voudrais dire
que ce que nous avons vécu voir josé
vécu comme député repos de gatineau lors
d'une ronde parce que j'avais cru
comprendre qu'un député incarnait une
parcelle de la nation et lure suffrage
universel par le peuple souverain dans
sa diversité
et qu'elle est seule rentable de ses
actes surtout lorsqu'elle parle ici dans
cette maison
alors merci de l'avoir fait et enfin je
veux dire
le gouvernement n'a pas la tâche facile
avec un variant y apparaît peut-être une
semaine je pense que je vous demande
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire beaucoup
mieux par contre on gagne et avaient
tous être un peu moins martiaux à
commencer par nous qui décidons ya
quinze jours qu'on va pratiquer avant
tout sauter sauf moi parce que je n'en
n'ai jamais voté au coeur et qui après
change d'avis dont je pense que ce
sommet un petit peu d'ordre dans les
esprits on va réussir à calmer parce
qu'il ya une chose sur laquelle martine
bonnaire a raison c'est que tout reste à
venir
je remercie merci je mets donc voit ces
deux amendements identiques des frappes
rémission gouvernement vote à main levée
qui est pour contre rejeté discussion
commune madame lr hadj et 703 ou malades
mourraient comme vous voulez des deux
merci monsieur le président sur cet
amendement 703 l'objectif est de
permettre l'adaptabilité de ce que nous
sommes en train de mettre en place
en dépit de notre désaccord je tiens à
le redire aux situations locales et je
crois que le ministre il est plutôt
favorable puisque tout à l'heure il m'a
répondu en indiquant que l'objectif
était de définir des principes et que
nous devions ensuite faire confiance aux
mesures d'application qui tiendrait
compte des situations locales donc
contacter faisant cela est justement
faisant confiance faisons confiance en
inscrivant dans la loi le fait que les
décisions doivent être prises en
concertation avec les acteurs locaux
notamment les élus locaux les
collectivités locales qui je pense
depuis le début de cette crise montre à
quel point elles sont engagées sur la
question de la gestion de cette épidémie
parfois en capacité de mieux gérer les
situations locales que ce qu'a pu le
faire le gouvernement je pense par
exemple aux mars au masque pardon en
mars dernier et je pense qu'il est tout
à fait opportun justement dans cet
esprit de confiance justement dans cet
esprit de lisibilité et de prise en
compte des situations locales
d'adapter ces mesures en lien avec les
acteurs locaux à savoir le préfet et les
collectivités territoriales
maintenant il vise lui aussi appliquer
un seuil par voie de décret le décret
permettrait effectivement d'appliquer la
mesure d'une manière beaucoup plus
équilibrée et puis qui s'adapterait à
chaque type de manifestation et surtout
aux tailles de manifestations vous voyez
bien que une petite manifestation
organisée dans un petit village on a pas
on n'a pas la même densité on n'a pas
les mêmes risques et peut-être en plus
matériellement c'est plus compliqué
aussi à mettre en oeuvre on n'a pas
beaucoup d'organisateurs tous vos
postures des bénévoles
donc ça va tout à fait dans le même sens
que l'abandon de ma collec c'est-à-dire
prévoyons des mesures d'application
qu'ils soient tirées du concret et du
terrain merci monsieur gosselin 82,7 ces
mêmes sujets défendu madame est la gc de
même que j'ai défendue sur le 3 737
défendu le 1029 madame dupont défendu
sur
ces éléments monsieur rapporteur
discussion commune
monsieur le président la précision du
sein n'apporte qu'une souplesse bien au
contraire rigidifie l'application du
dispositif en empêchant une application
de principe à l'ensemble d'un secteur
qui compte souvent sur cette disposition
pour se maintenir ouverts malgré la
perspective de la quatrième vague avec
ce genre de disposition nous prenons le
risque de rendre inapplicable et
inefficace de le que le pass sanitaires
et une fille née provoqué la fermeture
général de citi's établissements et
quelle que soit leur taille avis
défavorable pour tous les amendements
merci alors monsieur coquerel
elle a par magie milices pardonnez-moi à
la parole et monsieur le président juste
pour préciser que ces amendements me
semble satisfaisant dans le sens où
évidemment quand les gens iront faire du
sport individuel on ne leur demandera
pas un pas salutaire et évidemment nous
fixerons des seuils en fonction des
activités par contre rigidifier le fait
que l'on doive absolument mettre des
seuils empêcherait que l'on puisse
considérer que dans certaines conditions
dans certains lieux
le pass sanitaire s'applique dès le fait
qu'il ya une personne qui entre dans ce
lieu où deux personnes serait
contre-productif parce que ou à moins de
considérer que le seuil commence à 1
mais je pense que ce serait jugée
inconstitutionnelle fin en tout cas
contraire à la loi par le conseil
constitutionnel et donc les éléments
sont satisfaits il y aura des
concertations il y aura adaptation des
seuils et des conditions de restrictions
aux lieux et aux conditions des rp mais
il me paraît contreproductif de
considérer dans la loi qu'il faut
absolument un seuil cela nous
empêcherait encore une fois de mettre
des seuils extrêmement bas pour certains
lieux qui sont particulièrement est-il
donc défavorable
merci monsieur coquerel monsieur la
salle g coquerel
posez les cités rapport à ce que disait
tout à l'heure olivier véran je pense
qu'il va revenir donc je vais attendre
un autre amendement pour pouvoir le
faire
j'ai une question à poser moi je pense
qu'il faut voter ces amendements qui
permettent d'adapter les choses
enfonçons critères locaux je me suis
laissé dire j'ai cru comprendre que pour
les cinémas dorénavant le pass and i ter
étaient obligés que certains cinémas
avait estimé réduire automatiquement le
nombre de gens admis rod aussi d'énormes
dessous de 50 bons et que leur avait été
répondu de façon à part a besoin de
passe a dit et alors avait été répondu
que c'était pas le nombre de gens qui
rentraient dans le cinéma qui était
important mais le la capacité
potentielle du cinéma bien ce que je
trouve un peu étonnant donc j'aimerais
avoir des éclaircissements là dessus
parce que ça aussi ça va être assez
curieux comme comme critère comme
critère voilà chez lasalle
merci monsieur le président ce sera ma
dernière intervention je voulais dire
que je ressens comme tant d'autres
encore chez le band café où j'étais pas
de mon café ce matin c'est cette espèce
d'inquiétude qui ne dit pas son nom qui
le dira bien un jour mais moi j'ai le
sentiment que nous sommes tous perdu
cette forme de culture de gestion des
crises majeures auxquelles nos aînés
malheureusement avait été plus habitués
qui à leur tour qu'il faudrait
travailler en même temps que nous voilà
souvent un jour la recherche dans ce
pays
de plus si vous êtes à la première fois
que nous faisons dans un monde globalisé
c'est à dire c'est l'humanité tout
entière qui est touché et on ne sait
plus très bien qui prend les décisions
qui dit que tel verset 1 20 il n'est pas
bonne qui dit qu'elle règle
et surtout nous sommes dans un monde où
les trois cinquièmes ne recevra ni
vaccin ni même masque et je me demande
ce que nous ferons et comme je veux
terminer sur une note d'optimisme jeudi
que nos travaux vont nous servir
beaucoup pour nous reprendre à l'avenir
il aimait le convoi successivement ces
amendements qui font tous deux viennent
vider falloir le gouvernement de 703 qui
est pour contre je t'ai 647 qui est pour
quand rejeté 427 est identique pour
contre jeté ma mamie mouret
david lamouret match david oui merci
monsieur le président donc cet
amendement vise à exclure les mineurs de
l'obligation de passes sanitaires
concernant les activités de loisirs les
activités de loisirs sont essentiels
pour les jeunes en ce qu'elle leur
permette de à toutes et à tous un accès
à la culture aux sports et et qu'elle
contribue à leur émancipation la
réduction des inégalités sociales si le
gouvernement décide de maintenir les
activités de loisirs dans le champ du
pass sanitaires ce que nous contestons
le doivent alors rester accessible à
tous les mineurs sans aucune restriction
ou conditions
merci donc sur ses aventures sur cet
amendement défavorable commission
défavorable gouvernement s'assure rufin
la parole sur cet amendement il est
vraiment pas normal que le gouvernement
réagisse pas d'autant plus qu'on a le
secrétaire d'état qui a en charge le ca
à l'enfance qu'est ce que vient de
proposer notre collègue socialiste c'est
à dire que a minima le pass sanitaires
devraient pas s'appliquer pour les
mineurs au moins pour les activités de
loisirs
que dit la défenseur des droits dans son
point numéro 6 où elle considère qu'il
ya des risques considérables d'atteintes
aux droits de l'enfant la situation
spécifique des mineurs n'est pas prise
en compte
le texte prévoit des restrictions pour
l'exercice de droits essentiels pour la
jeunesse la défenseure des droits
rappelle à cet égard que l'accès aux
loisirs à la culture est un 3 proclamer
que par la convention internationale
relative aux droits de l'enfant
il ne s'agit pas d'un droit accessoires
mais bel et bien d'un droit fondamental
pour le bon développement de l'enfant ce
qui se passe en général en ce moment
c'est que faute d'aller vacciner ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin
on arrose tous azimuts et en particulier
sur le 10 12 8 12 18 ans je vais avoir
une série d'amendements là dessus parce
qu' un certain nombre de voix s'élèvent
aujourd'hui de très grands professeurs
en france il ya une tribune qui est
parue
mais aussi le le conseil de vaccination
anglais qui a été suivi par le
gouvernement anglais mais aussi le
conseil national d'éthique qui viennent
dire est il éthique de vacciner les 12
18 ans pour qui il n'y aura aucun
bénéfice en terme de santé est il
éthique de les vacciner pour les
personnes plus âgées qui eux ne se
vaccinent pas d'autant plus que
j'entends des voix intérêt général à
l'intérêt général
mais tous ces avis dont je vous invite à
prendre connaissance pour vanter en
conscience mentionne bien que le risque
aujourd'hui le risque sanitaire pour les
jeunes qui se font vacciner n'est pas
mesurée donc là le minimum du minimum
mais c'est de permettre que sur les
activités de loisirs lisant m banal
monsieur le ministre vous vous le savez
enfin les mômes ils ont pris cher
pendant cette crise ça a été compliqué
et plus d'ailleurs les enfants étaient
dans les milieux fragilisé plus cette
crise a frappé fort pour les parents je
sus par an la décision de vacciner ses
mômes
j'ai pris cette décision pour les miens
et je les assume n'est pas une décision
facile anodine elle nécessite de
discuter elle nécessite de peser le pour
et le contre la crise à la taper fort et
à la fait mal à la vie associative
il ya des dispositifs dans le cadre de
la politique de la ville qui s'appelle
bouge ton été bouge tes quatre saisons
on permet aux mômes des quartiers
fragiles des quartiers difficiles des
quartiers oubliés d'avoir des activités
sportives de loisirs de nature
culturelle en établissant ce pass
sanitaires pour les mômes vous allez
accentuer la fragilisation nos mômes
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souscris aux amendements qui visent à
les exclure de cette privation de
liberté qui est inversement
proportionnelle à la capacité de les
protéger
merci monsieur le ministre vous exprimer
avant oui pour brièvement pour répondre
à monsieur rue saint et puis monsieur
jumelles et puis pour clarifier quelque
chose rappeler que le pass sanitaire ne
s'appliquera pas aux mineurs suite à
l'amendement de monsieur bouffier chat
avant le 30 septembre
donc tout le raisonnement que vous
faites mais je vais vous parler d'après
mais là vous êtes en train de faire tout
un raisonnement sur l'été sur l'été les
vacances apprenantes bouge ton été etc
non mais c'était le cas de monsieur
jumelles ça ne ne s'applique pas donc
les enfants les mineurs entre 12 et 18
ans parce que je vous rappelle qu en
dessous de 12 ans enfants ne sont pas
vaccinés aujourd'hui ne sont pas
concernées par par le pass est né vers
cet été donc ils pourront amener et
avoir toutes les activités de loisirs
sportifs etc qui le souhaitent que les
choses soient très claires ne crée pas
la confusion dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens
par ailleurs monsieur monsieur rufin il
ya des millions de mineurs entre 12 et
18 ans 2 et 17 ans qui se sont fait
vacciner dans le monde donc ne dit pas
non plus qu'il n'y a aucun recul aucune
donnée aucune étude qui laisse entendre
c'est ce que vous avez dit qu'il y
aurait un danger à vacciner les enfants
ce n'est ce n'est pas le cas on ne
rasera enfin je vous donne déjà la
réalité de la situation
donc arretez d'induire en erreur nos
concitoyens soient nos enfants
bénéficieront du loisir nous avons par
ailleurs repousser la date au 30
septembre afin de leur permettre d'être
vaccinés d'ici là et de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un passé iter il ya
toujours la possibilité
par ailleurs dans le cadre du pass
sanitaire de faire un test pour ceux qui
ne seraient pas nous avons abordé grâce
à sa cheville et la question de
l'autorité parentale notamment parce que
les cas qui ont dû vous être remontée
dans le cas de parents divorcés qui
chacun pouvait avoir une opinion peut
être différente sur la nécessité ou pas
de vacciner l'enfant et monsieur richard
nous ont beaucoup débattu il ya quinze
jours sur les enfants de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance
ça va bien avoir votre avis mais nous
débattront j'aimerais bien avoir votre
avis sur ces enfants qui sont dans les
foyers savoir ce que vous en pensez
il faut les vacciner ou pas comment
fait-on vous avez réfléchi à ces
questions j'attends vos suggestions sur
le sujet mon départ après midi au
gouvernement c'est pour quand
rejetée nous abordons le cese qui les
défend madame antoine madame en toi mais
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
au delà de tout ce que nous avons
soulevés sur ces incohérences du
principe d'un pass sanitaires
quid des modalités d'application de
cette obligation de contrôle pour les
activités de loisirs et cette obligation
elle peut être particulièrement présente
à la fois pour les professionnels à la
fois également pour les clients et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il vous est
demandé pour éviter ce contrôle qui
pourrait être intempestifs qui pourrait
être par manar que ce contrôle de passes
sanitaires il s'effectue qu'une seule
fois et au moment de l'admission
merci amendements identiques monsieur
dekker 189 défendu monsieur blanchet le
281 merci monsieur le président donc
c'est un amendement identique source et
de l'ump h qui prévoit simplement
lorsque l'on rentre de
dans un espace de loisirs que l'on est
contre les qu'une seule fois parce que
dans cet espace de loisirs on pourrait
après aller dans un restaurant pour capa
dans un cinéma
pourquoi pas dans une autre salle et
dont on conçoit pas systématiquement
contrôlés puisqu'on s'est fait contrôler
déjà à l'entrée du parc de loisirs
donc c'est vraiment un amendement de
précision et en second lieu
messieurs les ministres tout à l'heure a
été à mende adopté l'amendement 274 que
je présentais je vous demande de de ne
pas procéder à une deuxième délibération
ne voyez pas cet amendement quand une
victoire contre qui que ce soit ou un
gain nom ou une défaite le voyez le
comme une opportunité une possibilité
notamment pour ce qui arrivera sur les
terrasses pour les contrôler et pour la
responsabilisation des clients du fait
simplement qu'il n'y aura pas de pièce
d'identité obligatoire
prenez le comme opportunité pour ce qui
va arriver et j'espère que vous pourriez
vous engagez à ne pas passer en deuxième
délibération je vous remercie lac le 946
s'est il défendu défendu donc sur cette
série sera porteur ces rendements
identiques
merci monsieur le président ce modalités
de mise en oeuvre ont vocation à être
déterminée par voie réglementaire en
fonction de la spécificité des activités
habité favorable et oui monsieur le
président je voudrais apporter une
réponse pour préciser l'application que
nous ferons de cette disposition de la
part du gouvernement parce que ça me
semble assez important premiers éléments
il est évident que lorsque vous vous
rendrez dans un parc de loisirs
si vous avez été contrôlés à l'entrée
nous ferons en sorte que vous ne soyez
pas contrôlés dans
dans l'est par exemple les restaurants
ou les rp à l'intérieur de ce parc de
loisirs cela me semble aller dans le
sens et c'est le sens de ce que peut
faire le gouvernement
je voudrais toutefois vous mettre en
garde sur l'adoption de ces amendements
parce que techniquement je voudrais
rappeler ce que cela veut dire si nous
sommes obligés de considérer que
quelqu'un qui a déjà contrôlé ne
contrôlera pas dans les minutes qui
viennent ça veut dire que nous sommes
obligés de constituer des listes des
gens contrôler or aujourd'hui pour des
raisons de vie privée quand avec le
lecteur et l'application tous antique et
kobe tu vérifies nous vérifions la
validité d'un pass
dans la seconde on oublie qu'on l'a
vérifié pour protéger la vie privée pour
faire en sorte que nous n'ayons pas de
liste puisque ce sont des informations
nominatives des gens qui ont été
contrôlés dans les lieux où ils ont
taillé de contrôle et donc ça c'est la
protection de la vie privée si vous nous
forcez a considéré que lorsqu'on entre
dans un restaurant on doit conserver la
liste des gens qui ont été contrôlés et
bien dans ce cas là il y aura partout en
france ou même peut-être centralement
des listes de gens avec des attachés à
des appareils et donc à des mieux donc
ça pose des problèmes de vérification
donc ce que je veux vous préciser c'est
que nous ferons en sorte dans les
décrets d'application de bien préciser
que par exemple pour les parcs de
loisirs par exemple pour les lieux qui
intègrent eux mêmes dodo rp à
l'intérieur des erp et le contrôle ne se
fera qu une fois à l'entrée n'aura pas
besoin d'être refait mais je voudrais
vous mettre en garde sur l'adoption de
ces éléments en matière de protection de
la vie privée s'il devait être inscrit
dans la loi madame le pen à la parole
merci monsieur le président mais comme
je voulais demander a déjà quinze
minutes le sujet n'est pas exactement
celui que je souhaitais aborder mais
c'est pas grave l'important c'est que
vous me donnez la parole
moi ce que je voudrais revenir sur la
l'exclusion du pas salutaire pour les
activités pour les mineurs décidément
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
je crois que votre marque de fabrique
c'est l'arbitraire les français ont le
sentiment de se voir imposer des mesures
arbitraires tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué des annonces
apocalyptique en matière de
contamination ou le simple fait de
passer à côté de quelqu'un en terrasse
pour elle contamine et je repose la
question dans ces conditions quelle est
la cohérence du de dudu pas sanitaire
inexistant dans le métro dans le bus
dans le rer sur des marchés dans des
centres commerciaux 19 mille personnes
dans des rues très touristique dans des
restaurants d'entreprise
on voit bien que l'incohérence est
totale et il en est de même pour votre
refus d'exclure les mineurs de
l'application du passani terre pour les
événements de loisirs c'est à dire qu'à
compter du 30 septembre les collégiens
et les lycéens ne seront pas soumis au
passage et terre pour aller au collège
ou au lycée
en revanche ils vont sortir du lycée ils
vont aller faire du sport et là on leur
demandera leur passani terre et se
seront très certainement les mêmes et
probablement ils seront également en
groupe quelle est la cohérence de cette
mesure qui vise encore une fois à
imposer ne pas sanitaires pour les
loisirs pour les mineurs alors même que
les mineurs ne sont pas ceux mis au pas
sanitaire est ce que ce dont je me
réjouis par ailleurs car j'ai un
amendement sur ce sujet pour les exclure
totalement de l'application du pass à
lithaire dans les collèges ou dans les
lycées monsieur brun la parole
merci merci monsieur le président je
voulais revenir deux mots sur
l'amendement sur les sites de loisirs de
laon tous collègues blanche et parce
qu'à mon avis qui vaut pour les sites de
loisirs vaut pour les sites touristiques
à savoir un seul col un seul contrôle
appartement sur le sur le site
je pense au camping je pense au village
de gîtes
je pense aux hôtels restaurants et donc
pourriez vous messieurs les ministres
préciser la position du gouvernement sur
un seul contrôle sur les sites
touristiques car je sais que jean
baptiste lemoyne ya travaillé en
relation la profession et ce serait
l'occasion ici d'éclairer à la fois la
représentation nationale les français et
les acteurs touristiques qui sont quand
même inquiet qui jouent leur saison dans
les jours et les semaines à venir
je me revois ces amendements identiques
d'ivoire commission environnement qui
est pour quand je t'ai nous en arrivons
au 992 mais pas défendu ce faire de ma
part le 68 monsieur d'yves jeu 68 et ils
défendent une ont défendues dans la
discussion commune
le 160 qui donnerait les 160 identiques
qui donneront lieu à la demande du
groupe la france insoumise un scrutin
public de 160 n'est pas défendu mais 621
l'est et monsieur coquerel à la parole
mais un amendement qui demande de
supprimer l'alinéa 9 concernant
l'élargissement du pass sanitaires pour
les activités de restauration alors
plusieurs évocation à ce sujet j'ai bien
entendu que le premier ministe entendait
j'allais dire diminuer la charge du
contrôle des restaurateurs ce qui chacun
l'aura compris n'était pas leur mission
au simple contrôle du pass et non plus
le contrôle d'identité qui est
évidemment une exclusivité bien normal
des forces de police bon je m'interroge
cependant parce que le fait déjà de
contrôler un pass me semble est une
activité de police que l'on dont du coup
on donnerait la charge aux restaurateurs
qui ne le demande pas la deuxième chose
qui la danse et sur cette question
m'intrigue je l' ai déjà dit monsieur
vers on n'est pas là pour répondre au
jeu reparlera la question c'est que je
pense que tout ça est une protection
j'allais dire qui me semblent parties
fille ciel mais en tout cas
véritablement trop confiante sur le fait
de ne pas attraper le vide dès lors que
vous avez donné votre pass sanitaires je
pense que les risques sont importants
mais j'y reviendrais plus plus tard donc
j'aurais préféré des protections dès
maintenant dans les restaurations entre
de rétablissement des gestes barrières
etc
mais à côté de ça donc vous l'aurez
compris à côté de cette mission donnée
aux restaurateurs avec toutes les
conséquences économiques ça peut aller
j'ai deux questions à vous poser
annexe la première c'est vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que les mineurs n'étaient
pas concernés par le passage du ter
comment les restaurateurs vont ils
savoir qu'ils ont affaire à un mineur
sans contrôler l'identité est ce que
vous est ce que cette notion a été
appréhendé non non c'est pas la loi
comment comment ça va se passer
la deuxième question que je voulais vous
demander qui là aussi est un clin d'oeil
qui m'a été suggérée par mon avis xavier
mathieu ancien syndicaliste est
aujourd'hui comédien c'est que vu que
la police a été exonéré de la question
des trains pas sanitaire dès lors que
les forces de police seront appelés pour
contrôler l'identité ce que les
restaurateurs devront demander aux
forces de police le pass sanitaires pour
rentrer dans leur établissement merci
merci à l'arrêt avant de passer la
parole à madame cayeux pour défendre son
amendement g président que je suis en
amendement qui intervient ultérieurement
le 64 est identique à la note du groupe
socialiste et apparentés il y aura un
scrutin public de ce que le temps est
annoncé dans la salle de l'assemblée
madame kerriou à la parole merci
monsieur président alors je vais déjà
dit moi je ne suis pas favorable à
l'instauration d'un pass sanitaire suis
favorable à l'instauration de mesures
sanitaires c'est inciter à la
vaccination des tests des équipements de
protection dans les hôpitaux plus de
personnel dans nos hôpitaux faire en
sorte que la santé soit ce soit
comment dire renforcer pendant cette
période de pandémie et voire plus
puisque vous le savez que d une autre
hôpital public aujourd'hui et d étaient
déjà sous tension en fait avant de
rentrer dans cette crise sanitaire
mais cela étant c'est bien à cause de
cet alinéa que je suis particulièrement
défavorable au pass sanitaires moi je
considère que c'est effectivement pas du
tout aux restaurateurs aux débiteurs de
boissons de faire du contrôle du
contrôle d'identité sûrement pas mais
même du contrôle de passes sanitaires là
on est sur des données de santé
je ne suis pas favorable à cette société
de surveillance je pense que c'est
extrêmement dangereux de s'engager dans
ce créneau là c'est que là on est en
train de mettre les pieds dans une autre
société qui n'est pas la société
démocratique française si une société de
surveillance je suis désolé de vous le
dire il n'est pas normal de demander à
certains concitoyens de 2
de surveiller des autres ça n'est pas ça
la démocratie
on est en train d'entrer dans un autre
système donc je pense qu'il est fait des
risques est vraiment plus que
raisonnable de supprimer cet alinéa
merci 941 mathieu malak aussi merci
monsieur le président donc je dirais les
restaurateurs n'ont pas besoin qu'on
leur met des contraintes supplémentaires
après avoir été fermé pendant de
nombreux mois il espérait pendant la
période festival au moins se refaire une
santé financière
ces compromis évidemment s'il va falloir
que vous alliez chercher un pass
sanitaires et vous mettre un écouvillon
pour savoir si vous êtes capables
d'aller au restaurant ou pas sachant que
bien souvent pour nos contemporains il
décide d'aller au restaurant c'est pas
prévu forcément à l'avance donc déjà ça
va être une baisse d'activité des
contraintes supplémentaires évidemment
parce qu'il va falloir qu'il y ait des
personnes qui contrôlent alors sur le
ils en sont assez conscients et ils en
sont absolument insatisfaits évidemment
ils nous l'ont dit alors il y à deux
mois nous avions écarté cette mesure
alors que le gouvernement y étaient déjà
favorables c'était dans le projet de loi
et c'était les députés y compris de la
majorité qui l'avait écarté aujourd'hui
vous voulez leur maître je suis désolé
mais les ses activités courantes de la
vie quotidienne eh bien je pense
qu'elles ne doivent pas être soumis à
une autorisation avec un pass sanitaires
ça c'est ce que je pense profondément
et ce n'est pas aux restaurateurs de
contrôler les autres citoyens des
citoyens qui ne sont pas assermentés qui
contrôlent des ses autres citoyens
ça c'est un glissement vers une société
sécuritaire et mes chers collègues je
vous adresse un solonnel appel à ce
niveau là faites attention
on a eu des périodes de l'histoire où
c'était comme ça on appelait ça un
comité de sûreté générale jeu on en a 2
relative mauvais souvenir
merci les amendements étaient présentes
et monsieur le rapporteur
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président on non
l'extension du pass sanitaires à
certaines activités du quotidien doit
être appréhendé comme un moyen d'éviter
en cas de poursuite de la dégradation de
la situation sanitaire et ne rappellerai
pas les chiffres actuels c'est à dire
7000 la semaine dernière et plus de
20000 et guerre donc qu'en cas de
poursuite de cette dégradation de
nouvelles mesures de fermeture générale
des commerces et établissements
qualifiés de non essentielle
il est incontestable que les bars cafés
restaurants ont été les premiers
affectés par les mesures de couvre-feu
et la fermeture provisoire des
établissements recevant du public et que
le pass annie terre peut constituer un
outil alternatif pour les maintenir
je dis bien maintenir ouvert tout en
poursuivant la lutte contre la reprise
épidémique
car ces lieux constituent des vecteurs
de transmission du virus
donc c'est un avis défavorable monsieur
ministre oui monsieur le président j'ai
eu l'occasion tout à l'heure de répondre
sur le sujet de l'imposition du passé ni
terre au restaurant et je crois que nous
serons d'accord pour dire que cela
la vérification du pas salutaire et
pénible pour les restaurateurs mais je
croise aussi pour avoir eu l'occasion de
les consulter que si on laisse le choix
au restaurant entre le pass sanitaires
ou l'application stricte d'une jauge à
50 même d'une jauge à 50%
c'est à dire d'une division par deux de
leurs chiffres d'affaires et le pass and
it erp ou une perspective qui est celle
de la refermeture les restaurateurs sont
assez unanimement pour le passé l'inter
alors je voudrais répondre à la question
de monsieur coquerel qui dit mais
comment vous savez que c'est des mineurs
par une autre question comment les
restaurateurs qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
le droit de servir de l'alcool aux
mineurs font-ils pour vérifier que les
gens sur des mineurs
bien de la même manière qu'ils ont déjà
une obligation qui pèsent sur eux qui
est de vérifier l'âge quand ils ont un
doute pour ne pas leur servir de
l'alcool
et bien quand ils auront un doute ils
vérifieront l'âge je ne pense pas qu'il
s'agit là de quelque chose d'excessif
dans la mesure où c'est une obligation
qui leur pèse déjà pour leur servir de
l'alcool
dernier élément qui me posent
relativement questions notamment pour
les députés ou les groupes qui sont
contre le cndp à sanitaire mais pour la
vaccination obligatoire
on comprendra qu'une vaccination
obligatoire sans contrôle et sans
sanction n'est pas une vaccination
obligatoire et donc il me semblerait
qu'il serait conséquent de la part des
députés qui sont pour la vaccination
obligatoire qu'ils expliquent aux
français la manière dont ils comptent
compte rooney contrôler la vaccination
obligatoire soit par un immense fichier
sur lequel on vérifie si chacun est
vaccinée ou non soit par un moment où
dans la vie quotidienne nous sommes
obligés de vérifier que les gens sont
vaccinées ou non si on n'est pas capable
d'expliquer comment contrôler la
vaccination obligatoire et comment la
sanctionne dans ce cas là c'est une
posture esthétique
merci alors nous sommes toujours à deux
orateurs donc madame fiat et monsieur
chichement la parole oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre
effectivement dans les restaurants si on
veut servir de l'alcool à un jeune et
qu'on a un doute on va lui demander
enfin très très régulièrement on sert
plus souvent des plats que de l'alcool
c'est pas tous les jours non mettant
même en lacets pour servir des assiettes
à tous les jeunes qu'on va demander un
pass sanitaire ça fait quand même une
toute petite différence chers collègues
ben oui non mais c'est la réalité
mais monsieur le ministre qui a fait
sauter les protocoles sanitaires et les
a assoupli dans les restaurants c'est
vous c'est pas nous c'est vous qui avez
décidé que les protocoles ce rallye j'ai
dès le mois de mai en disant ça y est
c'est derrière nous ça va mieux on
enlève les masques le variant delta et
dans tous les pays d'europe y passera
pas par la france c'est vous qui l'avez
décidé c'est pas nous et maintenant vous
imposez impasse sanitaires mais
évidemment face à date pas d'hier non
c'était il ya deux mois
donc vous avez pris des décisions et
maintenant vous faites le exactement
l'inversé parce que vous avez été trop
rapide prévoir prévenir planifie nous
n'arrêtons pas de vous le dire monsieur
le ministre aké beaucoup de parents nous
pose la question de la problématique des
enfants qui vont avoir 12 ans c'est à
dire qu'ils peuvent pas ce pack signer
avant il faut attendre utilisé 12 ans et
donc le chemin vaccinale est long
imaginons un enfant va voir 12 ans fin
septembre le temps qu'il fasse son
chemin vaccinale entre l'entraînement de
foot le mardi le match de foot le samedi
tests pcr tous les quarante huit heures
pendant deux mois le temps du schéma
vaccinal emmanuel macron annoncé la fin
du remboursement des tests pcr qu'allez
vous faire pour ses enfants
monsieur chiche et la parole
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre quand on aborde la
question du contrôle du pass sanitaires
dans les bars et dans les restaurants on
part du principe que c'est quelque chose
de simple à réaliser
moi je vais encore une fois vous appelez
un peu de retenue c'est quelque chose de
pénible et c'est pénible par
construction parce que les restaurateurs
qui s'engagent dans ces métiers qui sont
des métiers exigeants ils le font d'une
part pour organiser la convivialité
ils ne le font pas pour contrôler leurs
clients et ça paraît bête mais je tiens
à le rappeler parce que la majeure
partie des réactions que nous avons de
la part des restaurateurs de nos
territoires sont celles ci ce n'est pas
dans le cadre de nos missions ce n'est
pas pour ça que nous tenons un
établissement c'est un premier élément
qui ne faut pas balayer d'un revers de
la main
au delà d'un point de vue opérationnel
vous nous dites que après tout c'est pas
compliqué de scanner un qr code et bien
moi je dis que ces personnes là elles
tiennent une entité économique avec des
réalités budgétaires et financières et
je peux vous prendre un exemple chiffré
un établissement qui fait 60 couverts
deux fois par jour qui va je sais pas
prendre dix secondes par personne pour
scanner son qr codes comme ça on se dit
après tout c'est pas énorme et bien
jusqu'au mois de décembre 2021 ça
représente 40 heures et dans une entité
économique est bien 40 heures ce n'est
pas neutre
alors vous nous dit soit vous accepter
cela et d'en faire des auxiliaires de
nos forces de l'ordre soit ils sont
fermés et ils font 0 et ben moi je ne
crois pas moi je pense que dans notre
état nous avons des forces de l'ordre
pour effectuer des contrôles et je pense
que nos forces de police et nos forces
de gendarmerie peuvent procéder à des
contrôles obligatoires si vous décidez
de faire appliquer ce pas ça me permet
en rien ce n'est la mission première de
nos restaurateurs et en rien cela
représente une neutralité économique
penser à tous ces restaurateurs qui ont
contracté
des pge qui ont effectué un décalage de
paiements de mairie de sigean c'est une
réalité économique où les soeurs
collègues
alors là chacun puisse exprimer nous
allons donc voter sur ces amendements
soumis à discussion commune
alors il ya on commence par un vote à
main levée le 992 qui est pour contre
rejeté le 68
alma levé également qui est pour quand
rejeté la nous arrivons à voter
électroniques sur le nom par 160 mais le
621 et suivant puisque 160 n'a pas été
défendu donc d'avis défavorables
commission du gouvernement vote
électronique de scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats
autant 191 exprimé 189 majorité 95 pour
67 contre 122 lendemain est donc rejetée
le 950 monsieur mac
oui c'est un amendement de mon collègue
à quoi vivait donc qui propose que les
restaurants qu'ils ont des filtres d'air
ne soit pas soumis ou pas sony terre
merci
le rapporteur pardon défendre à monsieur
ministre défavorable je vais te vois qui
est pour contre jeter le 947 qui les
défend ce cas la nive il avait la parole
monsieur président stone amendement
effectivement une autre vous pour mac
est porté par notre collègue a cru
revivre cet amendement vise à
restreindre le champ d'application du
passé militaire aux intérieurs des bars
et restaurants et exclure c'est un débat
qu'on a déjà eu et exclut son visage je
suis intéresse on sait que le risque de
propagation du virus est beaucoup moins
élevé en extérieur donc il sent il
n'apparaît pas justifier qu'une
disposition
quand même contraignante que le pass à
lithaire s'applique de sûreté rasmussen
merci dont nous sommes dans une
discussion commune mais je maintiens est
à la parole pour le mil 5 4
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues mais sur le ministre la
semaine dernière pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière vous étiez en
guadeloupe et vous avez pu apprécier un
principe constitutionnel selon lequel la
république que accueille en son sein des
peuples différents dans un principe de
liberté d'égalité et de fraternité
vous avez plus apprécié aussi le
principe d'accueil mais vous avez su pu
aussi connaître que seuls 20% des
guadeloupéens à ce jour ont accepté de
se faire vacciner
vous avez pu entendre parler des émeutes
en martinique donc de grosses
manifestations contre un couvre-feu et
autres mesures préfectorales qui change
d'une semaine à l'autre ça si bien que
nous sommes perdus
mon amendement mon amendement a pour
objectif de vous de demander au
gouvernement d'exclure les espaces
extérieurs des bars des cafés et
restaurants des lieux leur accès est
subordonnée au passable sanitaires je
pense en particulier aux établissements
des territoires de nos territoires
d'outre-mer qui sont contenus du crime a
largement ouvert sur l'extérieur pour la
bleue bord avec des terrasses ou
simplement des espaces non aménagés et
non parce qu'ils ne sont donc pas des
lieux de propagation du virus donc de
plus chez nous les personnes ne vont et
viennent de façon beaucoup plus libre
qu'à l'intérieur et ses états des
établissements qui sont en pratique qui
en pâtira les contrôles très difficile
donc moins ce que je joue vous demande
de ces de tenir compte de la crise
économique que nous traversons depuis
longtemps du fait que le taux
d'incidence du virus malgré ce faible
taux de vaccination n'est pas plus
élevée en guadeloupe qu'ailleurs et que
surtout les guadeloupéennes ne se feront
pas vacciner à la trique
il faut peut-être plus d'explications
données au compte des traditions locales
peut-être de nos superstition s'il le
faut mais la mesure qui consisterait à
imposer un pass and it erp ou de suite
ne marchera pas
merci madame la présidente jeunes varois
la parole pour les 855
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des lois
monsieur le ministre
alors je voudrais évoquer à mon tour la
situation de la restauration de la
restauration des cafés pour suggérer par
cet amendement qu'on puisse exclure du
pass sanitaires les clients qui sont
servis en extérieur considérant
d'ailleurs conformément à ce qui a été
dit par le gouvernement que à
l'extérieur on est moins soumis aux
risques de contamination qu'à
l'intérieur
je voudrais insister sur la situation
des restaurateurs monsieur le président
ils ont finalement une triple peine
d'abord après avoir vécu le confinement
l'arrêt de leur activité ils reprennent
difficilement et les témoignages
aujourd'hui affluent ils risquent de
perdre leur personnel
c'est le cas de ce jeune restaurateur
qui vient de reprendre une entreprise
qui a des crédits la moitié de son
personnel a dit je ne veux pas me faire
vacciner je m'en vais les annulations de
repas se multiplient parce que les
clients qui n'ont pas de passes
sanitaire ne vont pas au restaurant et
enfin la troisième peine c'est que si
ils sont obligés de licencier le coup le
rhône et le choix donc le gouvernement
leur impose de licencier un personnel
qui ne voudrait pas se faire vacciner
mais c'est à eux qu'incombe le coût
financier
ça n'est pas tenable ça n'est pas
tenable il faut absolument desserrer
l'étau autorisé le service à l'extérieur
sans pass sanitaire compenser
financièrement le coup d'un licenciement
est véritablement prendre en compte la
situation singulière du monde de la
restauration et des cafés
sinon nous allons tous les faire mourir
ce n'est pas possible
vous ne pouvez pas être indifférent à la
situation professionnelle de ces
courageux
restaurateurs et cafetiers merci avant
de passer la parole à monsieur pradier
pour le 710 ja forme que juré mandement
qui vient juste après le 500 la demande
du groupe u10 indépendant il y aura un
scrutin public
le scrutin est annoncée dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée monsieur bré dit à la
parole pour le 710 merci monsieur le
président je voudrais revenir un instant
sur ce qui évoquait le ministre
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
tout à leur disait que vous ne pouvez
pas y avoir de vaccination obligatoire
s'il n'y avait pas de contraintes
pénales prévues
il se trouve que le ministre ignore
totalement ce qui existe déjà dans notre
pays mais c'est le secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'enfance
aujourd'hui 11 vaccins sont obligatoires
pour les moins de 2 ans 11 vaccins sont
obligatoires dites moi quelle est la
sanction pénale prévue dans le cas où il
n'y aurait pas de vaccination pour ses
moins de deux ans aucune sanction pénale
n'est prévu absolument aucune sanction
pénale n'est prévu pour pour ces
situations là et ça n'empêche pas aucune
sanction n'est prévue dans le cas d'une
non vaccination et ça n'empêche pas que
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens vaccine de
manière très majoritaire les enfants de
moins de deux ans au fond dans tout ce
débat il ya quelque chose que vous
ignorez totalement c'est la confiance et
la responsabilité et parce que vous êtes
incapable d'instaurer la confiance et
d'avoir le sens des responsabilités pour
nos concitoyens vous en venez à des
outils de facilité qui seront des petits
absolument inefficace pour le reste ce
qui fait aujourd'hui débat c'est la
généralisation du pass sanitaires enfin
on peut pas nous dire qu'il ya une
comparaison possible entre le pass
sanitaires et les contrôles épisodique
que les distributeurs d'alcool font dans
leur bar pour les mineurs on passe à une
généralisation
on parle de mains de dizaines de
millions de nos concitoyens qui vont
devoir être contrôlée en permanence peut
pas ignorer qu'il ya un écart entre les
quelques contrôles que les patrons de
bars font pour les mineurs et la
généralisation totale de toutes celles
et ceux qui vont fréquenter les
restaurants on ne parle plus du tout de
la même échelle et donc plus du tout du
même sujet enfin il ya une question qui
m'obsède à laquelle vous n'avait apporté
aucune espèce de réponse
est ce que le pass sanitaire nous
évitera tout les autres contraintes
pouvez vous dire aujourd'hui comme vous
sentez vous semblez le présupposé
qu'avec le pass annie terre nous nous
épargnerons les opérations de
reconfirmer dit le redis que comme le
ministre l'a dit hier
et si vous leur dites c'est que vous
mentez à la représentation nationale et
aux français dans ma région
dans ma région d'occitanie aujourd'hui
nous avons le pass sanitaires et le
couvre feu
voilà la vérité c'est pas l'un ou
l'autre ce sera l'un et l'autre
merci on s'écoute mes chers collègues on
s'écoute
alors je nous emmenons à l'amendement
500 qui le présente prétend monsieur
bras dos à l'épaule qui le défend oui
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement comme beaucoup d'autres
déposée par jean christophe lagarde pour
redire au gouvernement avec les députés
du groupe u10 le pass sanitaires dans
les cafés et dans les restaurants
cwi le pass sanitaires à l'extérieur et
sur les terrasses c'est non et au delà
de cette position de principe redemandé
au gouvernement les mesures
d'accompagnement économique qu'il entend
mettre en oeuvre sa au delà de celles
qui ont déjà été prises pour compenser
la perte d'activité qui va intervenir
par la mise en place de ce pass
sanitaires à la fois dans le secteur de
la restauration et des cafés en pleine
saison touristique effectivement donc
les manques à gagner vont
immanquablement être supérieur à ce
qu'il serait hors saison touristique
mais aussi plus globalement dans tous
les sites que ce soit les sites
touristiques les sites de culture ou de
loisirs qui vont être un manque ablement
touchés par ces manques à gagner ou par
des dépenses supplémentaires je prends
l'exemple du zoo de beauval qui vient
pour pouvoir respecter les conditions de
l'obligation de passes sanitaire mettre
en place un système de test à l'entrée
pour les personnes qui ne pourraient
justifier d'une vaccination c'est 200
tests à l'heure qui sont aujourd'hui
réalisées ce sont des coûts extrêmement
important qui devront à un moment donné
être compensés par l'état
nous venons d amendements identiques de
926 madame antoine il est défendu et le
1095 également il son pari d elle-même
invente nouvelle série d'amendements
identiques le le 17 madame antoine
défendu également mais jerry pardonnez
moi non rapidement sur le 1095 on est
d'accord et bien sûr c'est un peu dans
l'autre sens les précédents depuis le 19
mai 2021 date à laquelle toutes les
terrasses du pas-de-calais ont accueilli
des clients le nombre d'hospitalisations
d'hospitalisation pardon a été divisé
par quatre alors que les extérieurs
étaient largement fréquenté le
gouvernement a affirmé à plusieurs
reprises que les terrasses rouvrirait en
premier car les risques de contamination
était moindre
aujourd'hui ce constat n'a pas changé et
il serait superflu d'interdire l'accès à
ces lieux où personne ne possédons pas
de passes sanitaire par conséquent c'est
un moment vise à supprimer le passé ni
terre en extérieur pour les restaurants
et les débits de boissons dont les
gérants auront par ailleurs beaucoup de
mal et ça a été dit de nombreuses fois à
faire respecter la tenue d'une telle
mesure merci monsieur paul
si donc nouvelle série d'amendements
identiques le 10 sept
madame antoine il est défendu et le 281
monsieur blanchet à la parole merci
monsieur président donc c'est un
amendement identique pareil sur ces de
l'ump h
les clients vont arriver à une table ils
vont montrer leurs cuillères code comme
quoi ils sont positifs ou négatifs à
l'établissement ça apparaîtra rouge ou
vert
oui mais s'ils sont déjà assis et qui
sont négatifs
il s'assied et s'asseoir voilà qui sont
contrôlés pourra être vérifié s'ils sont
négatifs et à ce moment là le
restaurateur pourra dire ben repartez je
peux pas vous servir
peut-être à la maison mais quand il
s'assoit la deuxième chose s'ils sont
négatives qui peuvent rester consommer
ils vont devoir
scannez le code de l'établissement pour
afficher qu'ils sont présents c'est ça
le pass sanitaires et à ce moment là il
est tenue normalement que le chalutage
il sans contrôle le fait qu'ils aient
bien télécharger le code pour indiquer
qu'ils étaient présents si une double
manipulation donc double temps pour
reprendre ce que disait mon collègue
chiche
ce que je veux dire à travers ce qu'ils
avaient été votés précédemment sur la
tique de 74 ya moyens d'assouplir en
mettant le passé et terme et en le
rendant efficace et opérationnel car la
crainte c'est que ce ne soit pas
efficace opérationnel contrôler et
respectée et c'est cela qu'il faut faire
c'est à l'amendement évidemment d'appel
mais je pense qu'entre les navettes là
dessus il faut réfléchir la peau site et
d'améliorer pour rendre efficace ce
dispositif car je crains qu'à l'heure où
l'on pas ce ne soit pas efficace tout
simplement les lamas crainte je remercie
merci madame le pen pour le 755 me
ministre chers collègues après de longs
mois de sacrifices sans précédent
après d'interminables semaine d'angoissé
d'incertitudes concernant la survie de
leur commerce vous accabler une nouvelle
fois celles et ceux qui ont déjà fourni
tant d'efforts depuis mars 2020 et
l'annoncent couperet du premier
confinement nos restaurateurs et
cafetiers ont été héroïques et
exemplaire ils ont fait preuve d'une
adaptabilité d'une agilité
exceptionnelles pour répondre aux enjeux
de la crise et se plie aux multiples
directive gouvernementale après les
plats remporté les masques en cuisine et
en services les paroi en plexiglas les
menus virtuel les terrasses antico vide
le recensement des coordonnées des
clients vous leur demandez aujourd'hui
l'impossible devenir des vigiles
des gendarmes et des douaniers vous
allez confier des missions de police à
des professionnels dont ce n'est pas le
métier la vocation
vous allez exiger d'eux qu'ils
contrôlent leurs clients alors que cette
action de surveillance n'entre même pas
dans le champ de compétences des
policiers municipaux
si l'exigence du pass and it erp comme
préalable à l'entrée dans un café ou un
restaurant est totalement injuste
discriminante sa présentation pour
consommer en terrasse est simplement
absurde et disproportionnée en effet les
avis et les recommandations des
autorités sanitaires nationales et
internationales précise que la
propagation du virus s'effectue
principalement dans les lieux clos et
non en extérieur à l'air libre
d'ailleurs c'est en s'appuyant sur ces
données scientifiques que le
gouvernement a décrété la réouverture
des terrasses des bars des restaurants
et des cafés le 19 mai dernier
comme première étape du déconfinement si
le risque de contamination est très
faible en extérieur il apparaît donc
inutile et absurde d'infliger des
contraintes supplémentaires aux
restaurateurs et aux cafetiers qui ont
besoin de travailler sereinement cet été
merci nouvelle série d'amendements
identiques le 64 qui le défend je le
défends mes sacs et pardonnez moi merci
simplement problème seuls ministres
l'extrême difficulté également de nos
restaurateurs aujourd'hui pour
rembourser les pieds chez eux je crois
qu'il faut que vous ayez en tête que la
plupart d'entre eux malgré les
dispositifs que bercy a bien voulu
décliner ont des difficultés sont
anxieux sont effectivement confrontés à
ces problèmes de trésorerie second
élément pour qu'un dispositif soit
efficace il faut qu'il soit réaliste et
réalisable
moi je suis un élu du littoral on a
beaucoup de ce qu'on pourrait appeler
dès des périodes de plage où les gens
rentrent sur les terrasses sont
forcément se présenter préalablement un
guichet sans forcément être en mesure de
décliner
ils envahissent ses terrasses peut être
que c'est une pratique assez courante
chez nous que vous ne connaissez pas
mais pour autant dire on sera dans
l'incapacité de contrôler quoi que ce
soit et je n'imagine pas au travers les
difficultés financières que nos
restaurateurs ressentent déjà
aujourd'hui la nécessité d'embaucher du
personnel supplémentaire pour faire ces
actions de contrôle que vous souhaitez
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
propose d'adopter cet amendement merci m
cn berger merci monsieur le président on
n'est pas là pour dans un texte
d'urgence légiférer sur le détail et
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
c'est ce que nous vous disons et si on
en arrive à ce stade aussi mobilisés en
cette période de l'année sur ce que vous
souhaitiez être finalement un simple
détail c'est bien que vous n'avez pas
accepter de retraite de respecter cette
discussion de grands principes et nous
enfermer dans des discussions de détail
et j'en prends un exemple lorsque
l'assemblée le parlement a créé le pass
sanitaires en mai nous avions dit c'est
pour les grands événements c'est pas
pour la vie courante
vous l'avez grosso modo respecter
jusqu'au décret applicable depuis hier
où on est revenu à 50 où on est revenu
au fait du quotidien en réalité et vous
avez maximiser et outre passer des
autorisations que nous que nous que nous
vous avions voté
c'est bien pour ça parce que vous avez
utilisé de cette façon de façon maximale
est contraire à la volonté du
législateur
les prérogatives que nous vous avions
donné que nous souhaitons aujourd'hui
des principes qui borne clairement
simplement et lisiblement votre action
la série d'amendements que nous
défendons là elle est très simple les
actes de la vie courante pour le pass
sanitaires on n'y est pas très favorable
dont acte mais pas à l'extérieur la vie
courante pas de passes sanitaires à
l'extérieur c'est simplement ça l'idée
défendue par ses amendements
merci à l'identique 934
ce qu'il voulait mais la brillantine var
dépasse yougoslavie que keanu qu'est le
168 monsieur des coeurs ainsi monsieur
le président cette question de
l'exclusion des terrasses des lieux dans
l'axé nécessite la présentation d'un
pass sanitaire a déjà fait l'objet d'un
débat
mais je voudrais profiter de cet
amendement pour faire deux remarques en
réponse aux propos du ministre qui a dû
s'absenter et qui s'exprimait sur la
distinction entre restauration à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
l'affirmation selon laquelle les
professionnels ne demanderait pas cette
distinction ne semblent pas refléter
fidèlement leur position si je m'en
réfère à ce qu'ils nous disent où nous
écrivent de toute évidence nous ne
rencontrons pas les mêmes restaurateurs
nous ne fréquentons pas les mêmes
établissements
s'agissant de la distorsion
s'agissant de la distorsion entre les
établissements avec ou sans terrasse
qu'introduire est notre proposition
je me permets de faire remarquer ça n'a
échappé à personne que lorsqu'il s'est
agi de réouvrir les bars et les
restaurants
vous avez à juste titre fait cette
distinction en autorisant d'abord
l'ouverture des terrasses ce qui
découlait d'une certaine logique
une certaine logique qui ne semble plus
guidé vos décisions
merci le 227 pas défendu
le 255 pas davantage monsieur est ménagé
pour le 368 oui monsieur le président
j'aimerais simplement revenir sur les
propos qui ont été tenus tout à l'heure
par monsieur monsieur véran monsieur le
ministre et qui consistait à dire que il
justifiait en fait le pas sanitaires sur
les terrasses parce que abandonné on est
obligé de rentrer à l'intérieur ne
serait ce que pour aller aux toilettes
ça veut dire mais finalement c'est une
récidive de sa part ça revient à dire
que le masque ne sert à rien parce qu'en
réalité quand on doit rentrer à
l'intérieur on met son masque et on
protège les autres et on se protège
j'ai aussi entendu que les restaurateurs
n'était favorable pas salutaire ben oui
je crois qu'on fréquente pas les mêmes
parce que figurez vous qu avant que
avant de déposer cet amendement j'ai
pris soin ce qui est la moindre des
choses de prendre attache avec les
restaurateurs de ma circonscription avec
l'umih âge de colmar et c'est eux qui
nous ont dit que ce n'était pas possible
de d'accepter le pas salutaire sur les
terrasses le contrôle n'est pas possible
le la réalité des choses n'est pas
faisable et c'est d'ailleurs donner plus
de pouvoir à des restaurateurs à des
tenanciers de bars à des uns des chefs
d'entreprise cas des policiers
municipaux c'est quoi ce pays où les
policiers municipaux n'ont pas la
possibilité de demander l'identité aux
concitoyens c'est pas faute d'ailleurs
d'être intervenu lors de la discussion
sur la loi globale pour qu'ils en aient
le droit et qu'on donne à des sociétés
privées à des restaurateurs à d'autres
professions cette possibilité de rentrer
dans l'intimité gens et de contrôler la
santé des gens c'est incroyable j'ajoute
pour terminer que ce qui était possible
quelques jours avant la tenue des
élections départementales et régionales
sans doute pour faire plaisir aux
électeurs ce qui l'a d'ailleurs pas
marché et bien aujourd'hui n'est plus
possible
je ne suis pas favorable pas sanitaire
mais encore moins quand il s'agit de
l'extérieur tenait compte de nos
amendements
monsieur peru amendements identiques
devraient les paroles monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues depuis plus de 18 mois
nous sommes confrontés à ce virus bien
sûr inquiétant qui nous préoccupe et
dont on connaît les conséquences mais
elle n'apparaît que sa transmission
extérieur demeure limitée dès lors que
les gestes barrières et mesure de
distanciation sont correctement mises en
oeuvre par les professionnels est
strictement respectés par leurs clients
selon les protocoles définis le
gouvernement a d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises affirmé que les terrasses ont
pu rouvrir en premier car les risques de
contamination est témoin alors
aujourd'hui on voit combien il est
difficile d'imposer un contrôle du pass
sanitaires pour l'accès aux terrasses
des cafés bars restaurants et que cela
apparaît très compliqué compliqué ahmed
en main pour les professionnels du
secteur qui ont déjà subi de plein fouet
la crise sanitaire les professionnels
qui n'ont pas vocation à contrôler leurs
clients comment cela peut-il être mises
en oeuvre et surtout sur des terrasses
qui sont par nature des espaces ouverts
sur l'extérieur
il suffit de regarder ses terrasses que
l'on soit en bord de mer à la montagne
dans nos vies dans nos villages qui ne
sont pas clairement clôturé et par
conséquent je ne sais pas comment ce
contrôle peut-il être effectués le
présent amendement
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
proposons des sur les terrasses
extérieures des restaurants débits de
boissons de la liste des lieux de l'absr
au caire la présentation de passes
solitaire et je crois qu'une telle
évolution irait dans le bon sens
justement de concilier le respect que
doivent avoir mes concitoyens des règles
sanitaires et cette volonté que vous le
fassiez comprendre que vous comprenez
aussi les raisons d'une vie à
l'extérieur pendant cet été et pendant
les vacances
merci mesdames nouvelle gildas paroles
volent 477 identique
oui merci monsieur le
résidents les vrais que les activités de
restaurants de cafés haut débit de
boisson ont subi je dirais un certain
nombre de perturbations sur les derniers
mois sur presque de deux ans maintenant
je pense qu'il est important de prendre
en compte des assouplissements des
adaptations au niveau de la situation et
nous savons très bien que les situations
entre l'intérieur et l'extérieur ne
peuvent pas être appréhendées de la même
manière puisque nous savons que le virus
ne circule pas de la même manière
à l'intérieur à l'extérieur vous leviez
d'ailleurs reconnu sur des périodes
antérieures antérieur quand des
terrasses au niveau des restaurants et
des débits de boissons ont été ouverts à
l'extérieur alors qu'à l'intérieur ça
n'était pas ouvert c'est donc dire que
vous êtes en capacité d'adapter et de
prendre en compte ces situations
différentes donc ce que nous vous
demandons c'est effectivement pour cette
période à venir de prendre en compte ces
différences que vous avez pu que vous
avez été capable de prendre en compte
dans des périodes antérieures donc de
l'adaptation de l'assouplissement s'il
vous plaît merci alors là il implique le
flatland 10 qui le défend madame al
aradj à la parole cet amendement vise le
même objectif celui qui a été défendu
par mes collègues précédemment c'est
celui de la cohérence et des règles
claires
c'est totalement incompréhensible au
moment où on dit aux françaises et aux
français que six ans vaccinée en
intérieur ils peuvent enlever leur
masque de leur dire que par contre quand
ils sont en extérieur il leur faut
absolument un pass sanitaires je pense
que on gagnerait toutes et tous à avoir
des règles qui soient claires je l' ai
déjà dit je le redis je pense qu'on
gagnerait toutes et tous à avoir une
forme d'adaptabilité
là aussi je l' ai déjà dit je le redis
et puis laisser une forme de liberté
dans le respect bien sûr des gestes
barrières on le dit là aussi on le redit
on l'a affirmé en commission le redis
aujourd'hui en séance
je pense qu'il faut de la cohérence et
aujourd'hui ce qui nous est propre
posez est absolument illisible merci
alors le 661 est un excellent amendement
que je ne veux pas défendre voilà le 871
n'est pas défendu le 883 pas défendent
tu a défendu le 1172 un caillou défendu
toujours dans les discussions de 484
d'un défendu monsieur diable 4,62 oui
très brièvement est dans la même veine
c'est toujours pour exonérer les
terrasses des bars et des restaurants
alors ce que j'ai pas compris c'est
qu'en commission le minisère santé nous
a dit maintenant dans les bars dans les
restaurants dont les terrasses c'est
plus dangereux qu'à l'intérieur parce
que l'état n'a les personnes ont
tendance à se rapprocher
moi je compte sur la responsabilité
nous devons compter tous sur la
responsabilité de ces professionnels qui
sont à même d'évaluer les georges qui
sont à même de faire respecter les
distances parce que si les personnes ne
peuvent pas être sur ses terrasses et
ben ils seront dehors ils seront à
proximité de ces terrasses ils feront la
fête et tout le monde sait très bien que
les forces de police n'ont pas la
capacité de tout contrôler c'est fait
merci le 640 à la parole oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur verrons
tout à l'heure nous a dit qu'il fallait
répéter pour être entendu je m'inscris
dans le processus actuel c'est-à-dire
que nous répétons pour être entendu la
la
la restauration extérieure permet aux
restaurateurs de continuer leurs
activités
le contrôle n'est pas compréhensible il
est inapplicable et donc on vous demande
s'il vous plaît d'écouter ce que nous
vous disons non seulement nous mais tous
les bancs et soyez un peu cohérent et
essayer de nous donner un peu de
flexibilité jour merci à mme de
vaucouleurs le 911
merci monsieur le président renforcement
des mesures sanitaires est rendue
nécessaire par une quatrième bague très
contagieuse
bien que les contaminations en extérieur
soit moins fréquentes
on peut comprendre que certaines
situations de consommation en extérieur
soit aussi propice à des contaminations
qu'on salle toutefois une consommation à
6 en terrasse découverte a sorti du port
du masque lors des déplacements ne
paraît pas de nature à favoriser
fortement la circulation du virus
c'est l'objet de cet amendement qui
prévoit toutefois que un arrêté
préfectoral en fonction du niveau
départemental de circulation du virus
puisse rendre obligatoire cette
disposition y compris en terrasse
découverte
ainsi alors
nous poursuivons madame plutôt monsieur
mac est pour le 89 défendu le 1132 20
portes 89
bah oui vous avez la parole
je ris merci au président il n'est pas
concevable d'exiger un pass sanitaires
sur les terrasses extérieures des
restaurants comment vouloir contrôler un
client avant qu'il ne s'assoient sur
cette terrasse le grand problème est
aujourd'hui la rupture de confiance avec
les français
or il faut absolument renouer avec cette
confiance parce que la crise sanitaire
elle nous concerne tous lorsque le
gouvernement ce qui est à son honneur a
engagé les concertations avec les
hôteliers cafetiers restaurateurs et les
représentants de l'umih et qu'un menu
suivant 10 a été trouvé il faut le
respecter
jusqu'à aujourd'hui le risque de
contamination en plein air a été jugé
faible voire très faible
le ministre vers en tout à l'heure a eu
des propos alarmistes sur ce sujet mais
franchement lorsqu à l'entrée des
terrasses le respect des gestes barrière
est demandée faisons confiance aux
restaurateurs et à leurs clients merci
donc madame porte 2132 défendu défendu
madame ménard le 39 défendu
le 748 monsieur jeudi les paroles merci
monsieur le président un amendement dans
le même esprit pour exclure de se passe
à lithaire les terrasses des restaurants
et des bars je crois en conscience que
cette mesure est à la fois inutile et
surtout inapplicable inutile parce qu'on
est à l'extérieur que cetera
s'inscrivent dans des espaces qui sont
ouverts inapplicable parce que comment
contrôler ce pas sanitaires sur des
lieux qui par définition sont ouverts ne
sont pas clos et c'est faire porter sur
la charge des restaurateurs des
hôteliers des caf et y ait une
responsabilité qui n'est pas la leur
c'est pour ça que je défendrai tout à
l'heure normalement les exonérant de
toute forme de sanction qui là aussi est
totalement injuste à leur égard ce n'est
pas à eux qu'on doit faire porter le
poids des incohérences qui ont marqué la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire de la
part du gouvernement depuis le début de
cette crise de manager peut lier les
vendus vous avez la parole oui merci
monsieur le président moi je ne
rajouterai pas d'autres arguments que
tout ce qui a pu être amené pour amener
cette exception sur l'extérieur je
dirais que tout le monde fait ce qu'il
peut que nous apprenons chaque jour et
que ce qui manque peut-être le plus en
ce moment c'est un peu d'humilité par
rapport à ce que nous amenons depuis
hier sous passe venons de passer à peu
près 10 heures sur 300 amendements et le
texte n'a pas bougé d'une seule ligne
d'une seule ligne messieurs les
ministres
aucun des arguments que nous avons pu
amener n'a été entendu alors nous sommes
les représentants
du peuple et je pense que ce qui est
clair et logique pour des parlementaires
saura peut-être claire et logique pour
la population et nous aimerions avoir
une écoute réelle
ce texte est nécessaire nous sommes
ensemble tous persuadés
mais nous aussi les parlementaires nous
sommes nécessaires nous sommes
nécessaires pour amener justement ce que
la population peut exprimer et a besoin
d'explications là en l'occurrence ce
n'est pas clair ce n'est pas claire
parce que c'est illogique et c'est
incohérent donc peut-être essayer de
nous entendre dans le sens où prenez en
compte ce que nous vous emmenons et là
en l'occurrence l'extérieur et moins
dangereux
le risque existe toujours quelle que
soit la situation il n'y a pas de
certitude il n'y a que des risques
négligeable est ce que on peut
considérer que c'est un risque
négligeable que d'être à l'extérieur et
de ne pas avoir besoin de passer ni
terre je pense que oui c'est pour ça que
je soutienne l'amendement de mon
collègue lamirault merci alors
l'ensemble des amendements discussion
commune ont été présentés monsieur le
rapporteur merci nous faire le point
merci monsieur le président on est ce
que le fait d'être à l'extérieur protège
je ne crois pas même si les risques sont
réduits ils sont ils sont importants et
d'autant plus avec ce virus delta qui a
prouvé sa compétitivité et d'ailleurs
les derniers chiffes leproux je le
répète 7000 la semaine dernière 20
milles hier exclure ces terrasses du
dispositif reviendrait à le rendre
inapplicable et d'éclats d'agde serait
trop haute et prendre le risque de
provoquer une nouvelle fermeture
généralisée des établissements pour qui
le passe à lithaire représente pour moi
une réelle chance avis défavorable sur
l'ensemble des amendements
là oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés nous avons eu ce
matin une très très longue très très
longs échanges sur l'opportunité de
mettre le passé littéraire en extérieur
pendant laquelle olivier ferrand et a
expliqué les raisons sanitaires pour
lesquels cela nous semblait nécessaire
où j'ai eu l'occasion d'intervenir
également de manière circonstanciée sur
la mise en place de ce passe au bénéfice
de sept de ses explications qui ont été
longuement donné au parlement tout à
l'heure je me permettrait de maintenir
notre position défavorable sur
l'ensemble de ces amendements merci
l'armée chaque collègue en raison du
grand nombre d'abonnements du grand
nombre de demandes de prise de parole de
l'importance du sujet on va ouvrir un
peu la discussion donc la parole et et
mathieu aubert merci monsieur le
président non mais il y a derrière ces
débats en fait deux grandes questions
qui est chargé de la sécurité collective
et comment est-ce qu'on sanctionne qui
échangent et de la sécurité collective
pour moi c'est l'état mais voilà
pourquoi nous sommes style évidemment à
ce que ce soit des restaurateurs qui
fasse son travail
on est serveur on est cuisinier en et
restaurateurs on n'est pas vigilent
c'est pas le même genre de je dirais de
métier et d'ailleurs on en est arrivé là
parce que depuis le début de cette crise
et je me rappelle très bien les propos
d'eric ciotti dès l'arrivée du coc vide
où on vous avait dit agissez aux
frontières c'est bien parce que l'état a
été incapable d'exercer ses fonctions de
police et de contrôles aux frontières en
refusant d'établir des règles de
protection qu'on en arrive à devant
privatiser l'activité de police et l'a
confié partout sur le territoire aux
citoyens de telle manière à faire un
moment donné respecter cette protection
collective
la deuxième question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on sanctionne
moi j'ai été très choqué par ce que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure la discrimination
n'est pas la sanction
ce que vous proposez ça n'est pas
la seule sanction possible quand on
porte pas le masque on n'est pas
discriminer on est sanctionné par une
amende
quand vous refusez l'obligation de linky
on vous coupe à l'électricité donc un
moment donné il n'y a pas dans le
registre de ce que peut faire l'état
c'est ce que dira disait mon collègue
pradier tout à l'heure il n'y a pas que
la discrimination entre citoyens comme
réponse au refus de respecter une
obligation dieu merci
et donc si on débattait d'une obligation
vaccinale d'abord vous qui vous
gargariser des millions de français qui
sont allés sur la contrainte s'inscrire
soit dr libre vous auriez eu un
processus parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
français civique qui procrastine et ils
ont ri se serait fait inscrire et
deuxièmement une fois que vous avez
établi le principe alors vous
réfléchissez à la sanction
voilà pourquoi je crois que cette
histoire de pas sanitaire ne marche pas
et que derrière les questions
opérationnelles d'entre eux parlent sur
les références et c'est une vraie
question ce aussi madame risquer la
parole merci monsieur le président à
vous écouter y aurait les gentils
députés de l'opposition qui écoutent
leurs restaurateurs et les mauvais
députés de la majorité hors sol mais en
responsabilité nous avons rencontré nos
restaurateurs certains tous évidemment
disent que c'est contraignant de mettre
en place le pass à iter mais certains
reconnaissent les aides qui leur ont été
apportées et nous disent à leur tour de
remonter leurs manches pour mettre en
place ce pass sanitaire en
responsabilité nous avons
rencontres ethnologie me départemental
je tiens ici d'ailleurs à remercier le
travail important de l'umih 45 et de son
président thierry dort m depuis le début
de la crise et c'est parce que nous les
avons écoutés que le premier ministre a
annoncé hier qu'il n'y aurait pas de
contrôles d'identité en même temps que
le pass sanitaires enfin en
responsabilité nous nous nous pensons
parce que là le varions a changé parce
que le variant delta est beaucoup plus
contagieux et que la contagiosité se
fait par les aérosols nous avons donc un
risque en terrasse d'être contaminés de
façon plus importante qu'avec l'ancien
varions et c'est pour cette raison qu'il
faut mettre le pass sanitaires aussi en
terrasse
c'est en raison de la contagiosité du
variant delta donc en responsabilité
notre groupe votera contre ces
amendements
merci et met ses actes et les paroles
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres
c'est vrai que depuis 18 mois on est
face à une infection virale le viral le
virus le virus change but
il faut qu'on s'adapte le le il faut
qu'on soit aussi agile que lui j'entends
d'un talent madame le pen qui misait ya
deux mois mais depuis deux mois le virus
à bouger et depuis 18 mois on est
confronté régulièrement à ce problème là
souvenez vous il ya un an pensais que
c'était fini ce n'est vous il ya deux
mois passé c'est fini
là on prend les mesures certains nous
disaient victimes en est ce qu'on peut
garantir qu'il n'y a pas de de deux
nouveaux confirmant non on peut pas
garantir par contre notre responsabilité
à nous c'est de prendre toutes les
mesures pour éviter on peut rien
garantir mais ce qu'il faut notre
responsabilité c'est prendre ces mesures
donc le virus mute à nous aussi de nous
adapter et qu'on voit je regarde est
alors encore tout senti qu une vérif
c'est assez simple c'est pas très
compliqué notre rôle est dit mot le rôle
de tout député s'était remonter auprès
de cette chambre
les préoccupations de nos concitoyens de
nos restaurateurs c'est d'écouter les
réponses qu'ils ont fait par les
ministres
les ministres de l'ordre explique
effectivement que le virus était
beaucoup plus contagieux que les choses
ont plutôt simple et maintenant notre
rôle aussi c'est de redescendre à nos
concitoyens pour leur expliquer et faire
de la pédagogie et c'est comme ça que
ensemble je pense qu'on avancera je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président la somme des
incohérences s'allonge
prenons un exemple simple d'un citoyen
qui se rendrait prochainement à une
manifestation contre les retraites par
exemple ou à une manifestation
par exemple la famille traoré irait
manifester donc pour les manifestations
rien pas de passes sanitaires
l'individu va au café boire un ptit un
petit remontant à la il est contrôlé et
pas sanitaires il rentre chez lui en
métro rien pas de passes sanitaires
comme il est provincial il prend un tgv
alors là il est contrôlé non là il n'y a
pas de passes tanit est enfin voyez bien
là il est contrôlé dans le tgv
voyez bien que cette espèce de retour en
absurdie va rendre les français
complètement dingue
alors après on va pouvoir le gloser sur
la santé mentale des français enfin vous
y est pour quelque chose
vous êtes en train de rendre notre pays
complètement complètement dingue voulait
les gens ne vont plus savoir quoi faire
les gens vont subir vos incohérente et
surtout pire ça en dit long
en fait il ya une prise en main
technocratique de notre économie et une
prise en main autoritaire de notre vie
quotidienne
voilà le résultat de ce que vous aurez
réussi à faire vous savez quand la
bêtise gouverne l'intelligence est un
délit écrivait montherlant eh bien je
crois que ça devrait vraiment vous faire
réfléchir
merci
monsieur glavany à la parole 6 merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
moi je rejoins un certain nombre d'avis
qu'ils sont partagés c'est de ce côté de
l'hémicycle
aujourd'hui il ya un certain nombre
d'incohérences qu'on aura du mal à
expliquer le jour on va se retrouver
dans quelques heures quand on sera
sortie de l'hémicycle qu'on soit dans
nos circonscriptions
oui la circulade la situation est
extrêmement complexe
oui il faut des mesures pour protéger
nos concitoyens mais là il ya quelques
semaines en a expliqué aux gens qu'on
rouvray les terrasses parce que c'était
l'endroit le moins dangereux et
aujourd'hui on fait pas la différence
alors ce que alors que dans le
restaurant ou d'un dans le bar on se
promène avec un on est obligé de mettre
un masque pour circuler donc c'est trop
difficile à expliquer on vous demande
simplement de desserrer un peu ce texte
pour la pour le bien-être de nos
concitoyens
voilà les clés les restaurateurs ne
peuvent pas avoir de pouvoir de police
non plus merci monsieur le président moi
j'aimerais à vous entendre
j'ai pas de sujet à ce qu'on puisse
débattre est ce qu'on puisse s'écouter
bien évidemment c'est le but de tout ce
que nous sommes en train de faire dans
ce cas là j'aimerais que vous répondiez
à une question
je suis vacciné on est bien d'accord que
cela ne signifie pas pour autant que je
ne peux pas être porteuse du virus et
donc contaminantes pour d'autres
personnes qui seraient vaccinées ou non
avec une dangerosité accrue on l'a bien
compris avec une contagiosité plus
importante
on a bien entendu aussi dans ce cas là
est ce que vous ne trouvez pas que c'est
contradictoire de dire que parce qu'on
porte parce qu on est vacciné pardon on
doit plus porter son masque
est ce que ça veut dire que on n'est pas
contagieux enfin je vous avoue je
comprends plus rien et je pense que je
ne suis pas la seule
ce texte porte en lui un certain nombre
de contradictions majeures et à trop
vouloir entrer dans le détail
et à trop vouloir polémiquer sur tout et
n'importe quoi
en fait on n'avance pas
donc est ce que vous pourriez répondre
est ce que vous pourriez répondre et on
égoutte on égoutte le madame
est ce que vous pourriez répondre à
cette question très simple si je suis
vacciné et que je suis porteuse du virus
est ce que je dois porter mon masque oui
ou non en intérieur et en extérieur
je pense que ça nous aiderait peut-être
à comprendre votre raisonnement
peut-être que dans l'opposition nous
sommes tous incapables de comprendre
mais restent supérieures
madame heures au seuil et merci monsieur
le président chers collègues vous nous
accusez souvent l'opposition d'être
toujours dans la caricature et de faire
voilà et qu'est ce que vous donnez vous
comme exemple si l'opposition entière
vous interpelle si l'opposition tiers
vous dit nous ne voulons pas d'une
société de surveillance généralisée
nous sommes conscients que le virus est
réelle et qu'il faut vivre avec le virus
vivre ce n'est pas télétravailler et
dormir vivre c'est aussi avoir des liens
sociaux
d'ailleurs vous voulez conserver
égoïstement nous pourrions dire très
bien nous pouvons les conserver nous
allons imposer la surveillance aux
autres mais ce n'est pas le sujet et
vous gagneriez un petit peu en humilité
à écouter aussi l'opposition
le vaccin est une piste les gestes
barrière et le protocole évidemment
qu'il faut les respecter mais vous vous
glisser vers une société de surveillance
nous vous alertons tous nous n'en
voulons pas et nous continuerons faites
attention
plusieurs collègues ont parlé ici de la
rupture de confiance entre les citoyens
et les institutions et les politiques
vous jouez un jeu extrêmement dangereux
cuir collègues
merci madame t-il si merci monsieur le
président toujours sur le même sujet
monsieur le gru le président du groupe
majoritaire présidentielle a déclaré sur
bfm
personne n'est obligé d'aller au
restaurant et bien vraiment ce sont vous
n'avez pas d'arguments parce que
personne n'est obligé de conduire pers
personne n'est obligé d'aller en boîte
de nuit personne n'est obligé personne
n'est obligé de vivre vos arguments ne
tiennent
j'attends de monsieur le président fasse
de sorte que je suis personne avec ses
arguments personne n'est obligé de vivre
vous devriez expliquer de manière
pédagogique pour arriver à convaincre
mais alors là ça ne convainc personne
deux autres choses une sanction s'il ya
une règle une règle sans sanction est
absolument inutile donc cette règle
n'ayant pas de sanction elle est
parfaitement inutile
deuxièmement évidemment elle est
inapplicable et toutes ces incohérences
font que les gens n'ont pas absolument
pas confiance
je vous remercie merci c'est plié
monsieur dharréville et on aura terminé
oui merci monsieur le président moi moi
je voudrais revenir au sujet de
l'atrium ans qui est celui d'ouvrir aux
activités extérieures l'alinéa y dit que
l'on exclut les activités de
restauration à l'exception de la
restauration collective de la
restauration professionnelle routière
donc les relais routier et les débits de
boisson au delà d'un seuil défini par
décret un clair ça signifie que notre
routiers qui se sera arrêtée deux fois
dans la journée pour manger avec ses
collègues n'aura pas été testée n'aura
pas été contrôlés mais que quand le soir
il ira avec sa famille au restaurant il
le sera donc c'est quand même pas très
clair et moi qui suis un personnel de
santé
je cherche avant tout à comprendre d'un
point de vue sanitaire
quel est l'impact est ce que le plus
important c'est d'essayer de limiter au
maximum les contaminations en contrôlant
justement c'est pas sanitaires dont dans
des lieux ou des personnes mangent tous
ensemble ou bien et quand elles
travaillent en gros elles risquent moins
de se faire contaminer que les autres ou
bien justement est ce qu'il ne sait pas
plus pertinent de se pencher sur les
lieux et la façon dont on se nourrit et
de chercher à préserver au maximum nos
collègues monsieur dharréville
merci monsieur le président simplement
pour redire l'opposition qui est la
nôtre vous laissez passer sanitaires et
nous voyons bien d'ailleurs tous les
problèmes concrets que cela peut poser
dans la mise en oeuvre et dans et dans
l'application avec des incohérences qui
sont pointés ici à travers ces
amendements sur la question de la
distinction entre l'extérieur et
l'intérieur puisque fut un temps
effectivement ça a été rappelée où il
avaient été ouverts les terrasses pour
qu' on puisse commencer à reprendre vie
dans ces lieux là et ici sa distinction
n'a plus cours c'est assez effectivement
incompréhensible d'autant que des
mesures de protection les restaurateurs
savent les mettre en oeuvre quand c'est
nécessaire et donc évidemment ça veut
dire que nous sommes dans une logique
est une logique de contrôle permanent
voire de punition et ne pensons pas que
cela soit un levier efficace pour
mobiliser la société face face au virus
et donc il ya là une obligation quelque
part une obligation vaccinale qui ne
s'assume pas sinon vous y viendrez sur
la possibilité de distinguer entre
l'extérieur et l'intérieur et nous
pensons que ce que vous êtes en train de
mettre en oeuvre n'aide pas la
mobilisation nous basons le vote alors
va commencer par des votes à main levée
d'abord le nom est donc avis négatif sur
l'ensemble bien sûr 1947 qui est pour
compte
rejeter le 1104 mais ma vie même vote de
855 même avis mais de vote de 710 même
avis même votre vote électronique sur le
500 chacun a regagné sa place
le 500 le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votants 204 exprimé
200 la majorité 101 pour 83 contre 118
rejeté vote à main levée sur 926 est
identique et pour contre rejeté
vote sur le 10 est identique à main
levée qui pour contre je t'ai nouveau
vote électronique sur le 64 identique
chacun a regagné sa place
suta est ouvert le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votants 204 exprès
de sang à majorité 5 pour 87 contre 114
rejeté le 484 n'était pas défendu dix
étaient défendus dont pied pour contre
rejeté le 462 même veine mais ma vie
même vote de 640 mais ma vie même vote
1901 mais ma vie même vote un amendement
identique 89 et suivant qui est pour
contre rejeté le 39 même avis même vote
les 748 mêmes habits même vote 1148
n'était pas défendu le 3 332 même avis
même vote
nous en venons aux 18es identique 18 pas
défendu mathieu blanchette de 518
merci monsieur le président c'est pour
une clarification tel que rédigé le
texte c'est le pass sanitaire s'impose
aux activités de restauration à
l'exception de la restauration
collective la restauration
professionnelle routière virgule ou de
débits de boissons on peut imaginer que
si on lit le texte comme ça les débits
de boissons ne sont pas inclus dans le
pack sanitaire
cet amendement propose simplement de
marquer les activités de restauration et
de débits de boissons à l'exception
c'est juste de décaler la phrase en
second lieu quand on parle des
dividendes façon c'est une question que
j'ai évoquées hier monsieur le ministre
vous avez les débits de boisson ce sont
des types n est aujourd'hui se sont ils
sont tous logés à la même enseigne et
les types
elle nous avait dit plein de jour et de
nuit quand on est à partir du moment où
il est annoncé que dans les débits de
boisson deux jours ne sera pas
obligatoire de présenter une carte
d'identité sur le passé à terre ce que
je
soir personnellement mais là où ça pose
problème
c'est véritablement pour les débits de
boisson de nuit à dérogations
d'ouverture tardive parce que ne pas
imposer la pièce d'identité à ces
établissements s'est retrouvé une
propagation possible du virus parce que
dans ces établissements
il ya une surfréquentation normal d'une
activité nocturne présente et surtout
beaucoup d'activités dansante
alors que dans d'autres activités
dansante le pass est obligatoire avec
une pièce d'identité je vous remercie
monsieur rapporteur merci monsieur le
président je ne vois pas ce qui manque
de clarté dans le dispositif puisque par
définition la restauration collective et
la restauration professionnelle routière
ne sont pas des activités de débits de
boisson avis défavorable sur le ministre
mamy pour la même avis mais tout à fait
la parole est à monsieur est elle oui
merci beaucoup monsieur le président on
voit bien que les mesures proposées à
travers le pass sanitaires sont
totalement inapplicable ce matin même le
président du groupe majoritaire monsieur
castaner sur bfm dit la chose suivante
nul n'a besoin d'aller au restaurant une
telle formulation ça montre bien que le
groupe majoritaire est totalement hors
sol parce qu'évidemment on ne parle pas
uniquement de restaurants gastronomiques
est ce que vous réalisez simplement que
quand vous avez des artisans des
personnes qui sont dans les travaux
publics qui sont à 30 km de chez eux qui
ont besoin d'avoir au moins un repas
chaud dans la journée il faut réfléchir
à cela et donc vous êtes en train
d'envoyer un message à nos concitoyens
qui est scandaleux c'est absolument
scandaleux penser à toutes celles qui
font vivre ce pays qui font en sorte que
justement les choses se passent
correctement une tel mépris de la part
d'un président de groupe majoritaire
c'est simplement scandaleux
merci je mets donc voir cet amendement
défavorable commission et gouvernement
qui est pour quand
rejetée madame aux bornes pour le 976
merci monsieur le président donc cet
amendement présenté avec madame ou rossi
temps a précisé cet article pour savoir
si les employés du secteur ferroviaire
remplissent les mêmes conditions car
vous savez qu'en ce moment ils sont très
utiles dans les trains pour faire
voyager nos compatriotes et qu' il loge
le soir dans des résidences haddock et
avec des restes de la restauration qui
est attachée donc c'est un amendement de
précision merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président il semble
que la restauration dont vu que vous
visiez relate de la restauration
professionnelle et que cette question
vocation d'être à être confirmé par
décret peut-être que le gouvernement
peut-il s'y engager avis défavorable
sinon monsieur le ministre
merci merci monsieur le président
d'abord un peu étonné je pensais qu'on
n'ose interpellé pas entre collègues
dans cet hémicycle je trouve que c'est
moins gracieux quand les personnes
concernées interpellés ne sont pas dans
l'hémicycle sur votre amendement madame
la madame la députée l'amendement de
madame euros si vous confirmer que c'est
bien le ferroviaire est bien intégrée
dans la restauration professionnelle
telles que visées à l'article je vous
propose donc de retirer votre votre
amendement sinon sera défavorable mais
c'est bien s'est bien intégré les
satisfaire merci donc avant d'aller nous
restaurer nous allons écouter monsieur
pradier
merci monsieur le président et merci à
l'assemblée pour l' enthousiasme dont
elle fait preuve à l'instant messieurs
les ministres et représentants du
gouvernement
je crois que depuis le début de cette
crise vous avez deux problèmes
peut-être qu'ils sont aussi nos
problèmes le premier c'est le fait que
vous ignorez que dans la responsabilité
politique il faut regarder deux sujets
l'urgence et la préservation des
principes la préservation des principes
n'est pas un sujet secondaire est une
des grandes difficultés moment monsieur
le ministre s'en va et de lui rappeler
que dans des débats d'urgence nous ne
devons jamais perdre de vue les grands
principes les grands principes ce sont
ceux de l'organisation notre société et
vous ne pouvez pas au moment où nous
avons cette urgence sanitaire à gérer
oublier les grands principes de contrôle
d'autorité dépositaire de l'ordre public
plutôt que de serveurs à l'entrée des
restaurants de préservation de nos
libertés du quotidien on ne peut pas au
moment de la crise voire sans porter
l'ensemble des principes auxquels nous
sommes attachés parce qu'il y aura une
société après cette les sanitaires
notre second problème pardon de vous le
dire ce sombre certitude qui a dit dans
cette assemblée il ya quelques mois que
le port du masque et est inutile c'est
vous c'est nous qui a dit il ya quelques
semaines que jamais vous ne générer les
auriez le pass sanitaire parce que il
était contraire à nos principes
c'est vous c'est nous qui a dit qu'il
n'y aura pas d'isolement contre 1 des
patients
il ya quelques semaines c'est vous c'est
nous et sur tous ces sujets
combien d'erreurs nous nous vous aurions
permis d'éviter vos certitudes ce sont
celles qui ont conduit ce pays à la
catastrophe sur la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire et aujourd'hui encore
vous avez exactement la même arrogance
exactement les mêmes certitudes pour
exactement le même résultat sur ces
trois sujets vous avez commis des fautes
graves
souvenez vous en écoutez ce que nous
avons à vous dire sur vos incohérences
et sur votre incapacité à mettre en
place des mesures absolument ubuesque et
dangereuse pour nos principes
fondamentaux
j'ai cru que l'amendement a été retiré
confirmé à la morgue il n'est pas
retirée il est retiré donc prochaine
séance cet après midi à 15h lecture
définitive du projet de loi de
prévention d'actes de terrorisme suite
du projet de loi relatif à la gestion de
la crise sanitaire
la séance est levée